[Music]
e
for
[Music]
the drama on the board has never been
more intense as the 2023 Champions chess
tour moves to the semifinals and these
two guys will be making moves on the
board and yet it's sure to be another
epic battle and a long rivalry can
Fabiano Carana finally overtake Magnus
Carlson in a high stakes rapid match
he'll have to bring his best chess
because the king is on form here in
Toronto can Notre Beck abaturov maintain
his form after sending hikaro Nakamura
home the youngster wants to prove these
guys are no longer his Heroes they are
his Rivals and speaking of Rivals Wesley
so seems to have none in Toronto he
feels the flow he's ready to go it's
time to hit the road the Champions chess
tour semifinals starts
[Music]
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive the
parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corn and even a breakdown
or two the game is over that's a w we
see a reaction Magnus Magnus Mouse
slipped oh my gosh look at y's face some
have pulled over but some oh what is he
doing slammed that foot to the floor and
just kept going any second Nakamura is
the winner not a of Maxim vajra the
Frenchman he wins the AI cup after six
stops along the way it's time for the
greatest proven ground and online chess
to drop that final pin in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove with the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to ended
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close F it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
[Music]
now
indeed we are live from Toronto Canada
once again what a beautiful wide shot of
this amazing City Toronto Canada has
become one of the capitals to the Chess
World over the last couple years and we
welcome you back in here where we've
been for the last couple years the
chess.com Global Championship now the
Champions chess tour final Danny rench
alongside James KY Levy Rosman looking
fresh over there in that suit and I
think I'm going to throw to you Levy but
because the Clos demand it you get to
have our opening thoughts here we sit
four players left four players went home
yesterday man that happened fast your
thoughts well that's the format right um
yeah I mean we've got some familiar
names in our semi-final which is going
to start today we've also got names like
nir Abdu satov who is familiar but also
very cool to see the 19-year-old on this
Grand stage has a chance to compete for
200,000 so I'm pumped guys I mean
yesterday was wild we almost had the
craziest comeback story and Hikaru but
unfortunately his journey was cut short
I'm pumped for today's games though are
you surprised that comeback story
stopped right there we know he's your
guy but really where we sit now how
surprised are you about that I am very
surprised in I mean you see him win
everything from title Tuesday to Fisher
randoms to all qualifying for candidates
like he wins everything so when he
doesn't it's like what's going on like
is the sky red type thing right but I
mean it just tells you how strong the
field is especially in the order back or
abdor right now too yeah well you saw
hik Caro's thoughts too he felt that
given how he started where he ended
wasn't so bad and of course maybe he
just ran out of steam a little bit
obviously Notre Beck of duur off is the
name still here along with the big three
in Magnus Wesley and Fabby but okay we
could talk for a long time about what an
epic day it was yesterday it was 8 hours
of a broadcast but we tried to boil it
down for you in this roughly two-minute
highlight recap in case you missed
it everything was at stake for some
players in the final round of the round
robin for others the their fate was
already sealed Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson's performance had guaranteed
them the first and second spot
regardless of the rounds results Fabiano
kowana and notc Abdus satarov had
clinched spots in the survival stage
everyone else was playing for their life
Hikaru Nakamura won his match against
17-year-old Dennis lavic but his place
in the rest of the tournament was still
not guaranteed if Ali Rea fuja won his
match against Magnus Hikaru would no
longer qualify Ali Reza was on track to
do do just that starting with a win with
the black pieces the second game
simplified down to a rook and Bishop for
Magnus against a rook for Ali Reza with
seconds on the clock Ali Resa blundered
and allowed bangus to set up a mating
net sending the match to Armageddon
white king could be in a mating
net he's losing now he's in the net
he's in the net he walks right into the
net Bishop can even and they know it
they know it Magnus Carlson gets the job
done takes it to Armageddon with the
black pieces and 9 minutes on the clock
Ali Reza survived an up and down middle
game but eventually lost on time
hikaru's survival was all thanks to his
longtime rival Magnus squeaking by in
sixth place Hikaru faced off against
fifth place finisher mvl after the pair
traded wins with the white pieces their
Armageddon game was a wild one despite
missing a puzzle rushlike tactic Hikaru
simplified to an easy draw with the
black pieces winning the match and
staying alive he's pretty much
pre-moving at this point he knows he's
safe he gets the draw luris through
meanwhile Fabiano and Notre back played
for the right to a spot in the
semi-finals the loser to face hakaru for
the other spot just like the hikaro mvl
match the player with the white pieces
won in both games setting the stage once
again for Armageddon Notre back had a
great position out of the opening but
his Advantage withered away until a
blunder allowed Fabiano to play a
beautiful mating pattern Hikaru faced
off against Notre backck in the last
match of a long day at the office
relatively conservative chess led to two
draws and it was time for one more
Armageddon Notre Beck won the Black
pieces with an aggressive bid of 9
minutes 35 seconds the young former
World rapid Champion maintained his
composure through a complex game
managing his time well and leveraging
his draw odds playing all the way to
King versus King to win the match as the
top finisher of the round robin Wesley
so was given the choice of opponents in
the semi-final and he chose Notre backck
this means that Fabiana will face a
familiar foe in Magnus in the other
semi-final
it's hard not to feel heartbroken for
the players who were sent home it's hard
not to feel exhausted after watching
that recap video of what we know in live
fashion was was many many hours but
there you have it Guys Wesley so chose
Notre Becka duur off we're going to get
to that in a second but first that meant
Magnus Carlson is stuck quote unquote
air air quotes here against his longtime
rival Fabiano Carana and let's let's
Dive Right In There Levy and talk first
about Magnus Carlson and his thoughts
versus Fabiano Carana yeah this is a an
age-old matchup really since
2018 uh that was the only world
championship match where Magnus Carlson
could not beat his opponent in the
classical portion they played out 12
draws and that was also the only time it
was ever that close at the top of the
leaderboard In classical rating they
were about three or four rating points
apart only but this is rapid this is not
classical yeah and in Rapid chess Magnus
has had Fabiano's number that really is
the story and this is rapid we are not
playing classical Fabiano has had an
unbelievable year in classical it's
rapid now it's very different format for
the third time it's rapid how how do you
build on that how do you build on your
classical your mindset going into rapid
here versus Magnus honestly I mean a lot
of times I'll ask the questions or to to
the players hey what do you need to do
like how do you get yourself as mindset
a lot of times they just say hey it's a
lot about consistency and experience
I've been here many times before
hopefully I can get a better chance
today even he Carlo says today I'm just
going to play a little bit chess if I
feel good I play good type thing and
that's exactly what F's going to have to
bring especially with these four games
he's going to have to play Magnus today
well we've talked about Magnus Carlson
dominance over his generation including
Fabiano Carana but let's talk about his
dominance as far as accuracy goes here
at the Champions chess tour final Levy
95% I would be shocked if he wasn't
ranked one on that list
uh obviously when you get into the tiny
details of Abdu satov at 91 versus
Karana at 90 it's all about the same but
we do have to remember Magnus does have
a tendency to play some provocative
chess and in his match against Fabiano
which was in the round robin stage
Magnus won that match not in the
Armageddon so he won that match in game
two when he played with the black pieces
played an offbeat opening got a very
provocative position and outmaneuvered
Fabiano so right now all advantages in
their head-to-head match today and
tomorrow point to Magnus yeah well and
as the players said and all agreed
hikaro made those comments first in his
sort of exit interview Wesley so doubl
down that the more games tends to mean
more Magnus and no one has dominated
highl chess more than Magnus Carlson
actually in the history of the game we
had some fun putting this together for
everyone here are the longest streaks
the longest uninterrupted streaks as
world number one in history you see him
there 1 2 3 4 or 4321 depending on how
you want to break it down that's right
we're in Toronto we're talking about the
Maple Leaves congrats on their win last
night by the way number four was Bobby
Fischer couple of Astros here guys they
didn't track this stat for very long
with Bobby fiser and then of course he
retired early so we should probably not
hold 54 months against him but Ani
carpov coming in at number three Gary
Kasparov 117 months there and 96 months
that's two streets pretty that's pretty
crazy and then you've got Magnus Carlson
at 150 months as of this year of in
December he is the
Undisputed uh well if you go by ratings
and the thing we just put together there
he is the Undisputed uninterrupted Goat
as far as being the highest rated chess
player in the world um I don't think
those stats surprise you guys but what
you think about that when you see it
really in front of you 150 months as
world number one why why why' they do
that why didn't they just say like 1500
days that was like what are we we
measuring babies like my baby 28 months
old like 150 why can't we combine
Kasparov you know just like
well he had 200 total it actually really
when you see it that way Gary kasparov's
two streaks that's pretty crazy that is
pretty crazy there in fact I think about
it as like you know in the superhero
movies when like you got like Captain
America and you're like what does he
actually do he's a man he's super but
he's not really that super when you got
Superman on your team type thing right
so of course that being said that's a
lot of months but I mean Casper off
having two I mean that's that's real
close that was you know he he's kind of
like Tom Cruz in the second top gun
Maverick movie it's like he was number
one and retired then they went and got
him again have you seen the second Top
Gun movie yeah okay if not I'm spoiling
it for you was a good movie I think
that's a pretty good reference well it's
a great reference thank you Gary
Kasparov is Tom Cruz but all right we've
talked a lot about Magnus Carlson and
now Gary kasar let's talk about the
opponent here Levy you take it away go
let paint me the picture how does
Fabiano Carana forget about that 19 to8
decisive score head-to-head record and
come in here I don't think he has to
forget it cuz I don't think he even
knows uh remember we're the commentators
right we got to talk about well it's 19
and8 with 15 DRS cuz we can pull the
stats from the internet these guys don't
know they know that obviously that's
what they know they know it from the
world championship match in 2018 when
Magnus won 3 nothing it was convincing
uh but even to this day he's had an
advantage he had an advantage in this
particular event winning with the black
pieces I think Fabiano is going to have
to see what kind of Magnus shows up is
Magnus going to be provocative with his
openings and provoke Fabiano into fights
considering it worked out well in the
round robin stage or is Magnus going to
sit back and let come to him we both
know that we we know they're stubborn
they're both stubborn in their world
championship match they played the same
openings over and over and nobody could
break through so I'm really curious to
see what's going to happen today
provocative Magnus or solid Magnus
making Fabby bring a positional
long-term fight to him about to find out
yeah I think uh Fabby actually has a
more consistency and playing Magnus than
anyone else I mean he played him 12
classical games there played him you
know uh however many rapid games 19 to8
there right having all the games playing
there a lot of consistency and knowing
what Magnus likes what he doesn't like
doesn't mean that you know oh this is
what he is on paper this what we going
to do doesn't mean it's going to be
easier for you but at least he has a
little bit of more consistency and
experience facing Magnus so sometimes as
you said you know what kind of Magnus
shows up can definitely dictate how
Fabby plays today hopefully he's ready
for it I think it's a good point that we
talk about Fabby losing these matches
against Magnus he's also played a lot of
high stakes matches against Magnus he's
got to get credit for that it's it
wouldn't be a storyline otherwise but
all right it's time to move to the other
story line back to our bracket reminding
you that Wesley so he chose opponent he
gave his reasoning it just doesn't make
sense to choose a world number one or
world number two no matter how dangerous
the young abduc turov might be but let's
head over to that matchup and I want to
start first with you KY actually on the
mindset of the youngster getting chosen
to play against Wesley so how how you
dealing with that I'm hated I'm like
would you going to pick me now of course
you only had two one other person to
pick but at the same time you take it
personal and I'm taking it personal all
the way through I last lost my first two
matches then I made it through and you
going to pick me Wesley yeah you might
be the top right now but I'm going to
beat you is what my mindset is Levy your
thoughts I agree you have to choose one
or two right it's like when you're
picking the teams in in in kickball or
dodgeball in school you're going to pick
the person you think is going to serve
your team better in this case Wesley
chose the person he thinks has a higher
chance of defeating over two games of
Rapid chess it's not disrespect it's
just the reality of the situation very
curious by the way had he a car roomm
made and I know he's out like who you
May the better player but I beat him
twice somewhere in the Multiverse that's
happening right now yes in in one other
dimension but he's not here so he picked
nobe well okay so why do you why does
Wesley think he has an advantage
experience right he's he's he's a decade
older if not slightly more right so he
probably thinks he has slightly better
opening repertoire to angle and kind of
deviate and and and things of that
nature so I don't know we'll find out if
he's right or wrong NRE obviously going
to come with a chip on his shoulder try
to prove Wesley Incorrect and if noyre
wins it'll be a sensation and we also
heard from Wesley yesterday you made a
great point that top level chess is
changing Wesley likes Notre backck he's
like we're boys right we just spent a
bunch of time together in a team event
right and he didn't say too much about
what happened in their casual Blitz
Games but maybe there's even more to
that right Wesley beat Notre Beck in the
round robin it did go to Armageddon but
he beat him right and maybe Wesley just
recency by us even just feels more
confident against Notre Beck but all
right we're we're excited here and uh we
we are late to get to our our fourth
team member she's here Ka we know you're
out there in the hall somewhere tune in
with what you got for
us hey Danny y that's right you guys in
there where the action is happening I'm
out here in the lounge where the
relaxing is happening this is where the
players chill out in between games and
before games we just saw Fabiano Carana
first player to arrive here for the
semi-finals actually the only player so
far to arrive and I actually met Fabby
at breakfast today as well I can give
you some inside information he was
having eggs and bacon and also listen to
this he had both tea and coffee so he
will be energized today when he faces
Magnus Carlson who yesterday he was so
relaxed he didn't have a lot of pressure
on him yesterday so Magnus Carlson in
this Lounge was in such a good mood and
for the first time in my life following
Magnus craws around for nine years now I
heard him doing small talk not going to
reveal to who he was talking but he was
talking about the weather just loving
that the sun now is out in Toronto now
it's going to a lot less packed here
today because obviously four players
left the tournament only four players
left Hikaru Nakamura has left the
premises so has Ali Resa fusa no longer
in Canada but I hear rumors Maxim vajra
and Dennis lovic are still here so
hopefully they will come down to hang
out with us today and I am keeping an
eye on this base because more players
might be coming in the big day the semi
finals about to start
Danny it's fun to hear Magnus engaging
in small talk I was out there you also
see the pillow behind you K that's
that's Magnus pillow talk right there I
if you want to show that real quick that
was a white elephant gift that Ali Resa
perua snatched after our white elephant
video and then gave it to me on his way
out and someone drew a heart around it I
don't know who did that I love
it there you go that's Magnus Carlson
he'll be there on the couch all day
might be snuggling up with that later
when we get a little tired but all right
is shocking ala did I said it's shocking
ala did not want to take that home to
it's shocking no he almost did but said
he couldn't fit it in his bag I don't
know if that was an excuse either way
Kai just went through the pleasant
experiences that the players are having
when they're chilling with us but the
next video we're going to throw right
before games get underway here in our
semi-finals is is something that maybe
goes into the unpleasant conversation of
fair play and we know that players don't
necessarily enjoy it but they've all
been super cooperative and embracing the
need for us to invest and take it
seriously and so I want to take everyone
through a behind the scenes tour to
answer the question can you really
secure over over theboard chess
tournaments can you make sure that human
play and clean play is happening the
answer is yes and hopefully you enjoy
this walk
through well hey everyone we're here at
the chess.com Champions chess tour
finals and of course Fair Play is a huge
topic for everyone around the world as
it should be including questions like
can you actually keep a venue secure can
you actually stop cheating even if it's
some of the most advanced spyware level
stuff out there the answer is yes you
can and where I just entered is where
the players enter they can go directly
to their rooms and back from here but
now we're going to walk through as if
we're a regular person this guy's going
to say you don't belong here but okay
Jokes Aside all right now we're going to
get into the real stuff all right
players are brought down into this area
before games at a scheduled time so that
they have enough time to be fully
checked for fair play this right here is
the private Lounge area where only staff
are allowed to have Electronics the
players are not allowed to have any
Electronics with them once they've
entered this area but when they come
early they do so because they need
plenty of time to get fully checked by
Our Fair playay Tech I'll try to talk a
little softer cuz they're actually
playing their games right now but okay
at some point here a player will come
over and they'll wait in this line
before being asked to enter the private
fairplace screening area once we're in
this private fairplace screening area
the players wait only one player in here
at a time I'm standing here right next
to a sir who looks like he has a fancy
device what's your name sir my name is
George I work with the fair play
Department my job is to uh detect Che
featers is to find out if anyone is
trying to get a gadget that helps him
win the game that's not going to happen
on my watch not going to happen on his
watch okay but all right this is a
little bit fancier than the normal kind
of thing you see an rfg scanner what
exactly is this is this doing that's
different it's called a nonlinear
Junction detector its job is to detect
any signal signals transmitted from
another device outside or transmitted
from a this device that is on a player
who's trying to cheat outside to a uh
foreign sender it can only be acquired
from specific countries it's not like a
normal metal detector that you just buy
on eBay and I'm going to add a little
bit more to that this device was
actually recommended to us specifically
by a firm that we hired to audit this
entire process this recommendation came
to us as a device that is capable of
detecting not just active signals being
sent I.E what rft scanners can do but
also detect signals that are sort of
enclosed within the device which would
allow more spyware to potentially
communicate on a person's body directly
to them even if there isn't a signal
actively being sent this device is
capable of picking it up I'm going to
put this down we know I'm full of
Technology here I'm going to hand this
to a cameraman who you don't know it's a
microphone I guess I don't even know why
we're doing this I'm full of the things
that are going to get detected I didn't
actually hide anything here which is
good to know maybe I should have but
okay we're going to find out we'll see
that's right don't assume anything it's
pretty phenomenal stuff thank you George
this is pretty much just a bunch of
camera for the show we do have cameras
everywhere so we're watching The Players
no matter what now after they've been
scanned they are not allowed to leave
this area like period during active
gameplay so you're talking about an area
that is maybe more secure than any over
theboard chess tournament that has ever
been secured that's what you're talking
about right let's say they come out here
again they're also watched closely by
staff the entire time out here in
addition to the cameras one of those
staff is this guy over here his name is
Greg we are also randomly scanning not
just this area George George in there
and Greg are also scanning the bathroom
on a regular basis to pick up any type
of device George is making sure that
anyone who would get anything out here
is being scanned by this which would
pick up all of the I guess the more
basic stuffs no other obvious slips
happen once they've been fully detected
by spyware and again we are observing
them every step of the way and Greg's
job is to make sure that if anyone
enters the bathroom or leaves the area
they are fully then re-entered with
security so that we keep them under lock
and key I guess if that's something you
can say that you're doing to a human
being without getting canceled so we're
keeping the players under lock and key
you can mark that down and I hope that
watching this video showed you what
we're doing I hope you appreciate it
it's some pretty high level stuff I
definitely am making a call to every
over theboard organizer to invest in
their own nonlinear Junction detection
devices cuz at this point if you're not
doing that you're not doing it good
enough and we hope that you will
consider investing in the same way that
chess.com has we
out
I didn't actually drop the microphone on
the floor I caught it with the other
hand that was off camera that's that's
movie Magic very Nimble I got a question
yeah I know we're going to have a show
here I know also we're we're always
jovial entertaining I have a serious
question two serious questions number
one how much does large scale
anti-che device and capability and
catching like we have here how much does
that cost great question yeah George
said this off camera but it was it's not
available everywhere and depending on
where you get them and some of the
details between $40 to $60,000 for
something American to really put the
whole package together yeah so as we as
we grow all of this production we have
bigger events this becomes the norm as
we try to build chess into a media
product around the top players and
competitions like this we're going to
have to seriously invest in it which is
very difficult because there's over
theboard tournaments around the world
that are like actively losing money like
the organizers in a tournament somewhere
in Europe can't spend this amount of
money so and it's a problem we've never
chess has always operated on an honor
System right and that we never thought
could actually assist you that were
microscopic right so it's an issue no
but that that is the key to that device
is it's capable of picking up
microscopic things hidden in anywhere
anywhere in anywhere that would be but
all right we're getting set for chess we
see some of the players coming in here
Wesley's already chilling Notre Beck is
pacing so we're going to throw it across
the pond and uh well you guys watch the
video David Robert and tell you David
I'm going to start with you we are
establishing that humans are playing
clean chess here have you ever felt more
human or more clean well uh Danny
frankly I'd love to be accused it means
that I would be playing great chess
superhuman chess which some of the
players out there are capable of doing
uh but I just want to give you uh Kudos
there for doing everything possible not
just for ensuring everything's clean but
for ensuring there's zero paranoia
another thing we want to get rid uh of
from the game and I want to give a shout
out to Rita because I'm feeling extra
clean makeup hair everything so thank
you to Rita who's doing such hard work
behind the
scenes we love you Rita Rita shout out
to Rita but all right hey Rita shout out
to everyone shout out to you guys we
can't wait to hear your commentary we'll
be joining you at some point in the
middle of these game is going to be an
epic day so Tanya we'll let you take it
from here take it away hey guys well
cheating has always been a concerned but
I think now more than ever where chess
is where we are transparency and fair
play is more important than ever and
that was some really really cool stuff
that we saw and it's time to get to some
even more cool stuff as the chess is
about to begin it is the day it is day
one of the semi-finals two big clashes
coming up two big fights coming up what
are you most looking forward to from the
players today everything we got the
semifinals we're down to our final four
people and with that being the case
wesle so he's taking on notbe abusar
Fabiano Carana Magnus Carlson what is
the world championship no it's a
Champions chest tour finals but two
excellent matchups absolutely Wesley so
against nck nck made it very clear with
his win over Hikari Nakamura that he is
here to stay at Top Class chess it's not
a one day thing we're going to be seeing
the best of nck for many many years to
come David yeah you don't knock out
Nakamura and not go on to have a
fantastic future in chess he's already
up there with the best mingling with the
best such a tender age but uh he's one
to watch he could be the Dark Horse only
four players left with a bit of luck if
he continues showing the aggression he's
uh displayed at this event he's
definitely capable it's going to be a
fun fight and and of course the other
big one Magnus versus Fabby that is
going to be super exciting to watch and
Ka caught up with Fabby earlier today to
check in with his
mindset it's a big day semi-finals and
Fabiano Carana plays the semi-finals
against Magnus Carlson what should we
expect Fabby well I think it will be a
very tough match for sure and um I I
don't know really what to expect I am
ready to play I'm just in a good mood to
be here to to be in the sem finals it's
already been you know a very tough
tournament and I I went through the
gauntlet I played uh all the players and
it's so far been going okay I had one
bad day but besides the second day I
actually won all my matches so if we
don't count that if I don't count the
matches I lost and I I'm doing very well
you face him so many times Magnus
Carlson what seems to be the key to be
able to beat him in a match well you
have to play at a very high quality it's
uh I don't think that there's any like
Secret
um know strategy or anything he's uh
he's a player who plays very well almost
always he of course doesn't make
mistakes like everyone and uh that's
that's the only thing you just have to
be at a playing at a high level playing
at your best to be able to exploit those
mistakes yes yes and as you say the
accuracy I think he's at 95% here in the
tour finals how difficult is it to play
against that of course it's difficult I
mean it's nobody expected it would be
easy to play Magnus uh I have to say I
didn't have any easy matches here
so it's not like I wasn't without
Challenge and uh some matches do give me
quite quite a bit of
confidence um for example well
especially yesterday I mean I felt like
I was in a good mood yesterday and
things went well despite maybe some
minor hiccups and um I feel like if I
play like I did yesterday then I'll have
a decent shot all right best of luck
today Fabby thank you thank you for
joining us Fabiano Carana against Magnus
Carlson today back to you
guys Fabby is ready to go and we are
ready with some odds uh for the clashes
that are coming up uh Robert what stands
out to you in this one I always say it
when Magnus Carlson plays he is the odds
on favorite this is proven True by this
chess.com stats team but that Wesley
nordbeck match up 60% Wesley 40%
nordbeck abatar will it be four out of
10 in this match to send abatar of the
young USC Phenom to the finals 71 to 29
David to me that feels a bit High yeah
it might feel harsh on Fabiano caruana
but it is based on recent history even
in this event alone Magnus did defeat
Fabiano in the round robin so it's about
Fabiano just upping his game he needs to
catch Magnus on off day but he also has
to bring his best we have to trust the
stats team we do but when it comes to
sports you can take the numbers and
throw them out of the window because
what matters is what form the player
show up in today and one thing's been
very clear that while Magnus is
Excellence himself Fabby has been
redefining Excellence all year Fabby has
been the player of 2023 In classical
chess and in their world championship
matchup it was 12 draws but Magnus did
take him down in Rapid history it does
speak and it has been Magnus dominating
their head to head matchup and in just a
few moments the 2018 World Championship
Fighters will be on the board fighting
for that spot into the finals of the
Champions chesta and it's handshakes
it's go time the big question what is
magnus's approach and he starts with the
kingspawn opening we haven't seen seen
him employ one E4 so often during this
finals yeah Magnus has been mixing it up
freestyling a bit but I can remember so
many clashes between these two in E4 E5
it's the main line of the Spanish the RO
Lopez opening here and Fabiano he's
backing up his chess ofal course Robert
he did so much research he put so much
heart and soul into that chess course
and no this is not an advertisement just
knowing Fabiano he trusts this opening
weapon and he's playing it against
Magnus Carlson so much talk in the
opening stage when they played in the
world champion match was about the
Sicilian Defense the rasal liimo but
from the black side Fabiano he trust
this as a big weapon and Magnus seem
surprised and this early Bishop C5 this
development it's the archangels you
pointed it out it is the big course by
Fabby un chessable and I was at the St
Louis rapid and Blitz calling the action
and Fabby had so many opportunities to
play this but he didn't and we asked him
why are you not playing your course and
at that moment Fabby was like you know
what everyone studied it I'm not ready
to employ it yet he chooses the most
important moment to go and it is an
important moment for these two players
as well nbec versus Wesley go time what
are we expecting in this one I expect
serious business Wesley plays the Kings
pun opening but he also took his glasses
off after the handshake it's what Wesley
does I don't know what that ritual is
all about I need to see I use my glasses
for that but he puts them down kind of
getting into that boss mode and we have
another Spanish yeah all these top
players they have their own mannerisms
glasses down clearing the throat
business time a replica of the other
battle will we see another arc angel or
the dark Arch Angel as uh Fabby termed
his course Moment of Truth Bishop comes
out just one square so uh this one has
deviated from the other semi-final uh
but also a slower Spanish here with
Wesley so just pushing his Pawn one
square to D3 slow build up here all the
pieces on the board maximum tension
tends to favor Abdu satoro I would say
as he showed yesterday in many of his
matches yeah Nock always brings the
fight but he does have a solid style at
his core He's just never afraid to get
into a mess and now he strikes in the
center and look at Wesley doing the same
this is getting very concrete right now
with all four Pawns in the center
staring at one another and it's Notre on
the clock he can capture in either
direction yeah this is a big move from
Wesley so it shows he's been doing
preparation as well because until this
last turn it was the game Nakamura
against Abdu satov from yesterday so
clearly Wesley while he wasn't playing
he was admiring uh the action maybe
watching our show Even and he was
studying he was preparing look how he's
landed as surprise Abdu sator clearly
wasn't ready for this porn push whether
it's strong or not clearly there will be
some poison attached and the youngster
now has to deal with the shock recover
and then react and we're seeing fresh
opening ideas on both our semi-finals
matchup they start in the same manner
with the kingspawn opening we see the
Spanish on the board with different
approaches by black uh in these ones
nbec opting for the bishop E7 while
Fabby scks to his course of getting the
bishop to a more active Square
definitely tension on the board right
now tension in the center of the board
right now who blinks first what captures
are we expecting here the difficulty for
nirc right now is he may capture a pawn
and Wesley probably will not recapture
on that square so for Nord dearbeck
there are actually quite a lot of
tactics to work through and I have to
say Wesley so has changed his style in
Toronto typically he's considered very
solid playing for small positional
pluses he's bringing the fight to NC and
he doesn't actually capture a pawn I
actually believe Bishop G4 is the best
move he's saying Wesley now it's your
turn what capture are you going to make
wow and Wesley shielding his face from
the camera shielding it from his
opponent he just pushes a pawn to H3 so
much tension in the center it's very
rare to see all four Pawns in the middle
of the board staring off at each other
like this without either side clarifying
the situation and now again big moment
for uh black right now he needs to
decide what to do with his light squared
Bishop trade off for a knight which you
don't normally want to do or Retreat uh
the one thing in favor of trading off
right now is that it does gain time for
black black would then be the first to
trade off Pawns in the center but it's
definitely a clash of home cooking of
Home preparation here one major downside
I would say of trading that Bishop for
the knights this position is about to
open up and in open positions we prefer
Bishops over Knights so n he knows that
he's got the principles down but he now
has to calcul concretely because if he
does slide his Bishop back there's the
possibility for Wesley to push Pawns in
front of his King to break a pin it
could get really wild on that side of
the board at the minimum nbec has to
consider that concrete calculation
moment here for nbec Abdu satra and it
might be a good moment to actually do a
little Deep dive as well David because
there are these options which allow
White to capture the pawn if black was
to move back with the bishop we can
express we can expect some aggressive
play from White on the king side taking
the Knight is never a happy choice to
part with the bishop beir as well uh a
big moment and we do see nbec going into
quite a think right now it requires it
yeah critical moment and uh I did uh for
a moment see abdor of give the trademark
death stair to Wesley maybe just trying
to read uh his mind there trying to
figure out how deep the preparation goes
normally when you're shocked like this
you smell a rat and you try to dodge
your opponent's preparation but the
problem is when it's this concrete this
forcing uh you have to enter a really
concrete quite a linear variation here
and you ask for a deep dive Tanya maybe
it's time to do that let's check out
what to do he Retreats his Bishop one of
uh I think the most logical options the
desirable option and O wow aggression
from Wesley so and Wesley's doing this
so quickly that he must be in his
preparation because you don't throw
Pawns in front of your king forward
unless you know what you're doing it
creates air in front of your king
vulnerable squares pawns and squares
left behind but look at how concrete
he's getting we are about to see some
Liquidation in the center but the EVR
slightly prefers white at this stage
although the E4 Pawn's about to drop and
it does drop I must admit this is scary
stuff this is risky stuff from Wesley so
but clearly he's analyzed it with uh
engines and again a big decision a
dilemma for black to take with the porn
sorry my arrows are messed up here to
take with a pawn or to take with the
bishop normally you want to get as many
pieces off the board as possible if you
want to play for safety but then you
look at the white king and you realize
it is a bit open so maybe taking back
with a pawn would be my choice the most
natural and he goes for it uh really
really interesting preparation here from
Wesley so he's banking on the fact that
his uh kind of Target here on e4 is just
stuck Behind Enemy Lines and he might be
able to pick it off in the near future I
think the black Pawn on e4 weaker than
its counterpart the white Pawn on E5
right now and Wesley's got a decision to
make uh now does he trade the Queens
does he sidestep with his own Queen
putting pressure on the black E4 Pawn
that you're talking about Queen E2 would
be a move that comes to mind here n back
also eyeing the D5 Square for his own
Queen if White Queen was the S side step
defending his Pawn not just that also
putting pressure on White's Pawn on E5
we will keep an eye out in this one
whether Wesley decides to go for an end
game or keep the tension on but let's
head over to Magnus Carlson versus
Fabian o Carana and this started with
fabby's opening of the archangels and I
have no doubt that Magnus has looked at
that course he probably has but I'm
looking at his clock he's the one
investing more time is that because he
trusts Fabby knowing that he is perhaps
the world's leading expert in this
opening that must be a part of it but
I'm looking at this position and it's
completely different from the other game
not a single piece not even a pawn has
been traded at this stage and for fabbi
he knows the main ideas and I think one
of those is to push Pawns in the center
and it's not the D Pawn it's not the E
Pawn but the C Pawn as a standard in the
Spanish you might move your knight out
to the rim to attack the light Square
bishop and then push your C Pawn but wow
he makes this kind of quiet Rook move
that catches me off guard but I have to
say I trust Fabby even if I don't
understand it he probably does yeah he
is the expert oll as uh I think 43 hours
plus of uh video footage on chessable uh
confirms on the this opening right now
uh Magnus has the pawn Center visually I
like his position but what next is again
this standoff in the center and I should
mention there's history between these
two in this exact opening they faced off
in the Isle of Man in this opening
before uh with some crazy uh tactics
there a bit later on um it's just the
two foremost experts on the Spanish
opening right now facing off against
each other we're guaranteed to learn uh
especially from the next few moves yeah
absolutely going to be a masterclass in
these structures and opening and this
mysterious move this uh shift of The
Rook from the e file to B8 is sort of
preemptive of Black's further expansion
on the queen side eventually what black
wants to do is start pushing that a pawn
down the board somewhere in the future
maybe the Knight moves forward to A5 and
the C pawn moves ahead as well
eventually trying to break on the queen
side and when that happens you want your
Rook on the open Line you want it on the
B line so even though right now it looks
a little mysterious it starts making a
lot of sense once those pawns moves
forward yeah mag is playing a bit of a
waiting game himself because in a
previous game against Fabiano I'm pretty
sure he pushed that Aon instead of the
A3 to A4 earlier on and even got it to
A5 um if I'm remember correctly or
actually maybe that was Fabby with the
white pieces against Magnus am might
have my colors revers right now David I
think you're right Robert either way we
have memories we have very fun memories
of that dramatic game from is of man I
believe it was
2018 uh a long long time ago but uh the
one thing that's surprising me is that
Magnus has burned a lot of time on the
clock here Magnus has spent more than 5
minutes as Tanya's plan uh on the board
now black throwing pawns forward on the
queen side uh so Magnus has burned this
time but it was predictable this opening
after all you know what your opponent's
famous for you research your opponent's
games he would have known I mean
chessable it's a tool that all the top
players use these days he would have
known that Fabiano has produced this
course spent months and months
researching it and then to not have
prepared deeply in this uh relatively
predictable position a bit of bit of a
surprise to me I must say and while you
were talking I did verify it was Fabiano
on the white side of that game against
Magnus Carlson Magnus won with black it
was Island Man 2017 so our memories they
were a bit hazy but we're in the general
direction and look at that Aon it's
Black's Aon going up to A4 T you were
advocating for white doing this it looks
like Fabby got there first no I love it
I love this because now the knight from
C6 can actually find itself on the
Square that has been vacated and the C
Pawn would have moved forward but right
now Magnus putting pressure and what
you're talking about these opening
Dynamics expecting the predict line
which your opponent has taken out of
course on maybe it's some sort of a meta
situation here where Magnus feels that
it's too predictable for Fabby to play
this so you know what he's not going to
play it at all in all these mind games
this is true normally when players
publish books or publish video courses
on an opening they stop playing the
opening because they know everyone has
access to their notes their files their
knowledge uh so they think okay I'm
going to make a quick Buck from uh
producing kind of publishing everything
and then I'm going to turn away and
learn something new but not Fabby he's
loyal to his beloved Archangel here and
before publishing the course Fabby
played thousands and thousands of games
and this is the point that I was making
earlier the St Louis rapid and Blitz
which he won he never employed the
archangels and then he comes for the
most important match against the world
number one and finally plays this
opening doesn't that show that he really
believes in it because if he's saving it
for some of the biggest moments in his
career like playing it's Magnus Carlson
and if any of these players make it to
the finals minimum $100,000 prize going
into their bank account so Fabby he
trust this weapon and he actually just
did something very clever he defended
his pawn it doesn't look like it but
tactics allow him defend this B5 Pawn
White's light score Bishop went to
attack it Bishop D7 says once piece is
clear the diagonal and the B file if you
take that pawn I'm actually going to
gather back my material and be a happy
camper yeah you can tell the expertise
that Fabiano has here just the calmness
as well he's displaying and frustrating
for Magnus Carson a lot of maneuvering
right now a lot of of time burnt on the
clock he needs to decide when to change
the pace when to declare his intentions
in the center it just feels too KY right
now and Fabiano is in his comfort zone
for black that is a psychological
Victory and Magnus gson needs to be
energetic right now he has to take some
critical decisions either on the queen
side or try and put pressure on the
center because it just feels that Fab's
next moves are easy to make if if white
was to make a waiting move well this one
attacks the B5 Pawn but I see it still
might be possible I was going to say
that black just wants to jump with that
knight from C6 to A5 that's really the
dream not only eyeing the light square
holes the weaknesses in the position on
the queen side but what you really want
is to get the C Pawn up the board you
want to play C5 to force a decision in
the center it's a wonderful position
where it looks like white is
overpowering Black's extended pawns on
the queen side but black continues to
defend tactic I love your knight jump to
the rim it's not looking dim it's
actually looking quite intelligent here
because black has carved out important
space face and control of key squares
over on that flank so jumping the Knight
to the rim here seems smart you are
protecting the B5 Pawn First with your
light Square bishop and that Rook on B8
once pieces land on B5 it's staring
through the dark Square Bishop that
Bishop May sacrifice itself in order to
win a piece that lands on B5 so Magnus
Fabby they have to calculate what is
happening with all those pieces staring
at that vulnerable Pawn on B5 I'm going
to put you both on the spot who would
you prefer here and why all pieces still
on the board still very tense I actually
played these positions from black and I
quite like them actually I really like
the expansion on the queen side uh I
agree Robert I don't think black needs
to pause to try and defend the B5 Pawn
With The Rook I think Knight A5 would be
the first move on my radar I'm picking
black here I also like Black's position
but I like his time more I like the way
that fabbi seems to be in Rhythm and
Magnus is the one not just because of
how he's holding his head at times and
uh just moving about in his chair I do
feel like Fabby he really trusts his
position position I don't want to read
the body language but just he feels
sturdy just by position by look and I
think that he is the one who Tred out
his main repertoire what about you David
uh I'll go white just to be different
after all Magnus has built a career on
the white side of the Roy Lopez the
Spanish this is pretty much how he rose
through the ranks and uh won some World
Championships against Anand based on his
expertise on the Spanish uh so despite
the fact I'm surprised Magnus has
invested so much time in what could have
been a position that he'd studied
beforehand um yeah still choose white I
believe in the pawn Center all right
well so far in the balance but Magnus
with his messy hair expecting a messy
position in just a few moves uh right
now this one a lot more clarified in the
center and Wesley did take the decision
to sidestep the queen trade moves with
the queen putting pressure on the E4
Pawn not much has happened David since
we left it last uh and it's going to be
a fight about who gets to those Central
pawns first yeah uh the big question is
why is Wesley so thinking over four
minutes on this last move it must be
because he's finally out of preparation
and his opening notes there must have
run out so Abdu satov huge relief for
him as black that he's finally
sidestepped uh this kind of bullet that
was heading for him with opening prep
and uh I see some forcing lines for it
maybe we can check them out yeah because
it you look at the E4 Pawn think that's
the most vulnerable but a move like Rook
e one making your intentions very clear
I think black responds with Pawn to F5
temporarily defending the pawn on e4 and
if you take Onan
Oh no you're opening up the f file I can
take back on F6 and your F2 Square it's
really vulnerable and black pieces are
Super Active yeah and uh okay I thought
I heard a clock I think that might have
been in the other board but uh right now
I'm also wondering Rook to D4 F5 might
be the answer anyway uh just you cannot
allow this Pawn to drop for no
compensation so why not open lines this
is after all where the white king uh is
weakest this is the main compensation
and yeah Black's Bishop look far
superior to their counterparts right now
far more active and because you guys
have pointed out Black's idea to go F5
try and open up the F line and Target
White's King the G4 Pawn using that as a
hook can black uh can white try to get
prophylactic about it try to stop it
with that Bishop from C2 going back to
where it came from and uh not just that
I want to get Bishop D5 if you're a
little careless yeah I really like that
idea Tanya a really nasty threat and you
stop the opponent's main idea
psychologically again really
really nice move I guess black would be
obliged to prevent your threat of Bishop
into D5 the one downside I guess would
be that this Pawn is no longer Under
Fire but uh maybe this is the best way
to at least stop an attack against the
white king if F5 is not possible then
White's King is a bit safer he instead
decides to plant his Bishop on F4 so
still maneuvering for now still in the
balance and uh we'll check back a bit
later and we are going toh check in with
our other board as this one is slow to
develop both players very symmetrical
position and there are these small small
edges about trying to get a Tempo in to
the attack to that Central pawns and
before we Deep dive into this one I
think Dany has been missing uh he's been
getting some foro about the action the
chess action and we're going to check in
with him Danny what do you think about
the positions and this opening approach
by Fabby playing the arang
archangels I love the approach by Fab
and the Archangel we know he knows these
positions incredibly well he's
comfortable I think you can see it and
not just cuz sometimes we read the
player's body language uh but I think he
I think he knows exactly what he's doing
in these positions he's right at home
and uh the eval bar of course says we're
still at a 50/50 position and of course
we are but I'm with David and Robert if
I was interpreting their commentary uh
correctly that I think this is a really
good start especially with the black
pieces for for
Carana absolutely and uh he definitely
understands and knows these positions
I've also been looking at mag Agnes uh
Danny he's been wearing the same hoodie
sweatshirt shirt whatever it is since
day one what's going on uh with that uh
also looking really sleepy and messy
hair do you think he managed to freshen
up before the game or he just woke up
like he usually
does I think the Bed Head uh speaks for
itself I guess sometimes the chest
speaks for itself I think the Bed Head
speaks for itself in terms of how
quickly Magnus got down here we know he
had a he had a good time last night
hanging out with some of his friends
here in in Toronto I don't know what
they got up to uh but he was on stream
there for a little bit but either way I
know Magnus changed into the green shirt
at some point so I'm not I'm not going
to read too much into the to the
lifestyle at this point I think we're
still pretty early on um but I think
most importantly for Fabiano is is his
uh his clock management also speaks to
his comfort and and yeah so um I don't I
don't know I mean I'm I'm kind of
waiting to see what develops here
because I look at those odds that we
have on screen a lot of the top players
even said they thought that Magnus might
be a 70% odds favorite before uh the the
semi-finals back in the round robin
stage but if he loses a single game here
especially with the white pieces I I
think uh I think things could change
pretty quickly there as far as our stats
go and Danny if I remember correctly
Fabby was out by you when he was filming
his chessable course so this position is
a bit deep down the line but how
confident is Fabiano in that repertoire
he's playing as the world champion but
do you have any Insider knowledge about
his preparation and his feelings about
this
opening yeah we talked about it every
single day actually um he was spending
long hours in the studio where people
often see me and you Robert there in our
in our headquarters but he was filming
and he said one how much he
underestimated the the difficulty of
building a chessable course because he
put so much information down but he also
said how much he appreciated reviewing
it and you see how quickly he's playing
he's equalized easily and again don't
bet against Magnus this is a 50-50
position but but yeah as far as Fabiano
goes if Magnus is going to be willing to
go into the Archangel you probably
couldn't choose an opening that is more
fresh in car's brain right
now absolutely Danny and uh before we
let you go you mentioned Magnus has got
some friends that have arrived at the
venue and I have to ask you because
we've got a lot of foro sitting here in
Oslo uh Eric Aman are the chest bras in
the
house well Eric and Aman were at their
house last night and that's where Magnus
went and visited them again probably
someone can find find Clips on the
internet but yeah Eric and Aman are
around um I'll actually be be catching
up with them tonight I don't want to
spoil any other plans I don't want to I
don't want to dox anybody as far as
things that they're going to be doing
but I will say that they will be at the
fan zone of course on Friday and
Saturday unfortunately for anyone
hearing of that for the first time uh
it's completely sold out so um you may
try to show up at the door and try to
get in I wouldn't blame you um chess is
a pretty hot ticket these days but you
will be turned away most likely unless
people don't show up and uh and yeah
we've uh we're we're looking forward to
it so o I like this view look at that we
got two boards going sorry I just got
really excited here in Toronto I love
what I'm
seeing yeah that's uh that's a really
really cool shot that we've got Danny
thanks a lot we'll be checking in with
you later and there are some very cool
decisions on the board we see on the
left side Magnus going all out in the
center with that move E5 definitely will
need the Deep dive and meanwhile on the
right side we've got Wesley updates with
Rooks being challenged on the D line
yeah I must agree with Danny I love this
angle all of the action all packed onto
one screen and uh yeah a bit of symmetry
here with both uh games having white
pawns on E5 very far Advanced Magnus on
the left board going for it now with
this last move finally pushing forward
trying to attack in the center things
heating up there as the clocks are
completely level on the right board I'm
looking at the Times Wesley so's only
got four minutes left ticking under four
minutes even still very symmetrical and
it feels like Abdu satoro might start
becoming a favorite if that uh momentum
continues I'm looking at the clock I'm
looking at the position on the right
hand side and Wesley starts to trade off
pieces and he's trading off all the
Rooks you see on the right hand board
Wesley so traded one pair goes the open
file with the second and nbe can't be
onhappy about that meanwhile on the left
hand side we see Magnus and fabbi
they're making some quick moves because
Magnus took a night with his Bishop to
ruin Fab's kingside Pawn structure then
drops his own Knight in the center that
Knight is getting very active on the
left board on your screen here so the
time's about even on the left hand side
but the position is quite messy yeah the
position is messy and uh actually two
very different types of position one
heading straight for the end game uh
that's the right board left board it's
going to be chaos I think Magnus he's
pressed that button now he is ready to
start fighting and big questions asked
of Fabiano the evaluation Bar says level
but suddenly the margin for error is
Tiny both players need to show accuracy
just to hold the balance and uh wow I
don't even know where the advantage l on
either side both of these kind of
matches right now just displaying top
top quality chess everyone on form at
this stage and look at that Rook that
nck has just flaunted on D3 He says you
want to trade sure but you trade on my
terms because if you capture on D3 that
gives nck a really really strong pass
Pawn with the pawn and uh we will wait
for Wesley's decision but big decisions
to be made by Magnus Carlson right now
as Fabiano on that left side of the
screen has just hinted at a potential
sacrifice on F3 Rook takes Knight always
in the air meanwhile the D6 Pawn is
hanging I was expecting this to get
messy but not this quick yeah just
within the space of two or three moves
when we had Danny with us uh it looked
like Fabiano was in full control no
problems at all now suddenly it is pure
chaos and I think we have to dive deep
as the players now tick down to the
4-minute mark Black's last move was Rook
to f8 I just want to recap that last
three move flurry it was here with
everything roughly balanced Magnus
decided to motor forward with his Pawn
if this Pawn was captured then he would
flick in the move he actually played in
the game removing this Knight before
then taking a pawn in the center either
with his Knight or with a pawn instead
Fabiano said okay I don't want to allow
you to get active I'm going to plant a
strong Knight in the middle and uh after
this capture White's Knight coming
forward I am shocked that Fabiano had
the calmness the incredible calmness to
ignore this porn's attack and Magnus
says I'm calling your bluff Rook to f8
hints at the sacrifice that Tanya
mentioned Magnus just takes a pawn and
now White's King is about to be blown
open take that Knight sacrifice The
Exchange right now because if the Rook
takes Knight Pawn takes Rook Queen out
to H4 The Rook on B8 will about to swing
to f8 hit the F3 Pawn the H3 Pawn's
under attack there are so many black
pieces heading in the direction of the
white king so I don't know what Magnus
sees here but it's looking very scary
for his King I think Magnus sees Fab's
clock because this means that Fabby has
to make some critical decisions and he
starts with the sacrifice but the Valar
says it's the wrong one wow this is a
very human approach not yet investing so
much material not giving up the exchange
like we were advocating I think it was
pretty much a two forked Road there and
he went for the other option now Rook
takes Knight is a threat because the
bishop is actually pinning a pawn to the
Queen the idea is that this Pawn on G2 I
was going to say was overloaded now the
black Bishop has dropped but so is the
White Knight and now he has a dilemma
The Rook is attacked this Pawn is
attacked Fabiano needs to justify his
recent decision this is really getting
sharp now can he sack they exchanged a
second time now Rook takes Bishop
because if Pawn takes the Knight hops in
there forking the queen and the Rook
this is getting extremely sharp thin
margins for both players I think
unfortunately for Fabiano his position
is a little bit more precarious he
actually takes on E3 with the Knight and
the eval bar is going up even more it
loves mag's position he was able to push
that pawn E5 open the board up and his
pieces have been flowing yeah just
compare compare this white knight a
beautiful stallion there to this black
Bishop on the edge of the board which
which isn't really participating Magnus
has it again two Choice uh position
right now take the brook take the Knight
which one are you going to capture maybe
taking the Knight because this black
Rook could well find itself trapped a
bit later on and uh I mean this is still
a crazy position White's King is
slightly Airy here I've got a favor
white just because of the beautiful
Knight but still anyone's game and that
G6 Pawn always hanging Magnus gson with
a committal decision the Knight takes
Pawn giving Fabiano a big opportunity
missed by Fabby and now it looks like
Magnus is in a driver's seat but he goes
for a different approach instead of
capturing on E1 he gives The Rook back
Still Loving that Knight on D6 threats
with the queen penetrating on F7 C6 Pawn
is hanging right now still trouble for
Fabby if you put that white Pawn on the
G file I think fabbi is pretty much lost
but considering the white king is open
that is going to give Fabby sufficient
counterplay I'm looking the clocks Faby
a little bit ahead but it's about to be
even on time I think it's anyone's game
at this point the night 96 that's a
stallion it's beautiful up in there but
the white king it is exposed the D4
Pawns in a dark square and a Black's pie
is a queen on H4 Rook on F things of
that nature there could be a
Counterattack yeah and sooner or later
at least the Knight is on a dark Square
so you will be able to remove it Fabiano
he needs to be accurate it feels like
black is the one trying to save this
game Magnus is the one trying to make
things happen meanwhile still in the
balance but uh yeah Fabiano needs to
play quickly and accurately to hold that
equilibrium and that's one of the
hardest things to do when to be fast and
precise in a chaotic position like the
one that we have in front of us and this
is the approach that has to be there
right to get the wins in where you might
not be playing objectively the best
moves but posing the biggest practical
questions to your opponent giving them
the opportunity to go wrong and honestly
that's a great description of what's
happening in the other game as well
where no dear beaar we see the eval bar
on the bottom right hand side of the
screen better for him all of a sudden it
was a position earlier on where we were
talking about like Wesley he's playing
really quickly that pawn for black was
loose Nock has allowed Wesley to go
wrong doesn't happen very often but he
is better in that game yeah they're in
the end game over there and we all know
nock's skill his expertise in the end
game meanwhile this one Fabiano does
immediately drop back with his Bishop to
challenge that stallion the White Knight
on D6 on that Outpost it is giving up a
pawn but he's saying who cares that
black C6 Pawn is weak anyway if White's
Queen goes and captures it it's more
important more urgent to get rid of the
Knight I think very good practical
decision especially with clocks ticking
down Black's King I should mention has a
nice safe hiding spot on H7 wh's King
going to be out in the open for the rest
of the
game very very interesting uh chess
being played here combative play by both
Fabby and Magnus Magnus does take the
pawn on C6 Fabby will get rid of that
stallion on D6 if Magnus was to
recapture and with the queen and trade
the Queens off I think that would just
end in a draw with Black's Rook sliding
onto d8 and picking up that pass Pawn if
Magnus wants more he has to recapture
with the pawn is he thinking of throwing
in a check and does that check really
achieve anything in The Possession yeah
the only good thing I see about giving a
check right now for white is that if the
White Queen slides back to D5 check and
then next move wherever the black king
goes takes the bishop with the pawn then
White's Queen on D5 actually stops the
black queen from jumping out with checks
herself so he does throw in uh that move
as you predicted Tanya uh really nice
spot there and suddenly Fabiano has an
issue he has to deal with those two uh
kind of past white dwns one of them is
weak luckily and he will shortly go for
it with the black Rook if Magnus can
maintain the dwn he'll win if not it
should still be a draw and the H3 Pawn
also Under Fire right now but Fab's big
idea is to slide that Rook to d8 double
down look at the traffic jam as you like
to call it on the defiled Robert does
white have enough time to activate his
own rook in the position with the open E
line I'm not a traffic cop but I do
think I'm going to clear traffic on the
defile you're going to take that pawn on
D6 we might see some some trades and
there will not be too many pieces
remaining the problem for white is yes
you can free up your own Rook but that
H3 Pawn is loose as well and there may
be a series of checks that the white
king cannot Escape it won't be a
Checkmate necessarily but we could see a
draw by endless checks and so the black
queen perfectly placed in front of a
pass Pawn Rook joining the party I just
don't see it for Magnus and he's down to
40 seconds he's under that at the moment
he plays King G2 he's giving up the D6
Pawn without that pawn I don't see any
winney chances whatsoever for white but
black may have some yeah look at this
last move Fabiano chooses the correct
Square for his Rook I actually think
black should be keeping the Queens on
the board so uh bringing the Rook to d8
would have been fine too but would have
led to a potential Queen trade Magnus is
so strong in these end games Magnus has
the pass pawns who has the safer King
it's black so keeping Queens on gives
you attacking uh potential longterm and
I do remember Fabiano uh didn't he win a
game against Alara fua with a very
similar Dynamic just the heavy pieces
the major pieces queens and Rooks where
the opponent had a pass D Pawn but the
opponent also had a weak King he won
that one with black in similar
circumstances he did and this one that's
why Magnus is trying to use his pass
Pawn saying that black can't go all in
for an attack that D Pawn is a passer
hard to stop so I think black needs to
plant his own forces on that D6 square
and I don't think there will be any
progress for either side yeah looking
very balanced now it feels like black
found all the accurate moves maybe black
can put some pressure on but ultimately
this last turn by Magnus Rook lift as we
like to say uh showing off with these
Rooks now he does have one one guardian
of the king white can always slide
across on the third rank to block if
necessary act as a bodyguard this one
should be a draw due to the reduced
material the only uh chance for Magnus
here is to try to get the Deep on moving
but for that you need the queen to
assist it from that Central E5 square
but whenever you plant it there fabby's
Rook will find activity on the fifth
rank with a Tempo so very difficult to
imagine either side making progress here
now though Queen E5 is a possibility
making sure that Black's Rook gets tied
down and it is on the board uh if Faby
was to move that Rook now the dwn moves
forward and there's a lot happening on
the right side of the board as the
players are down to seconds yeah Wesley
so against Abdu satov black is a pawn up
black has four versus two on the king
side white has two versus one on the
queen side but yeah just a bit of basic
arithmetic and Abdu sator surely is the
only one with winning chances Wesley so
maybe one of the players of the
tournament so far fighting for his life
and I chares up almost a minute on the
clock on the right hand side of your
screen on the left hand side Magnus
Carlson down to 9 seconds Fabiano with
35 he's putting pressure on Magnus on
the clock in more of the board oh my
gosh Magnus has to move Magnus really
cutting it fine he needs to just escape
this game he needs to try and bail out
with a draw he's trying to repeat right
now second time we've seen this position
can Fabiano create winning chances
hustle Magnus on the clock and there was
in the round robin where Fabiano did
decline the repetition and went on to
lose that game with the white pieces he
for the second time in the Champions
chest off finals declines a repetition
against Magnus Magnus pokes his King out
of its hiding place there pokes it out
staring uh down in the center and okay
Fabiano dancing around with his Queen
and look at the line of uh the totem
pole on the defile right now Black's
Queen is doing a great dance coming all
the way around but White's King is
seeking shelter on the queen side what a
journey what an adventure and if we look
at the board on the left hand side all
of magnus' pie are protected he made
sure that if you take this Pawn F3 I'm
going to get the pass Pawn so Fabby is
stuck playing a waiting game preventing
that D5 Pawn the left hand side of
screen from advancing he places his
Queen he blockades it but Magna is doing
an amazing job getting his own King to
safety so now it's not like the white
King's in danger but great active play
from Fabiano these players are so strong
Magnus how did he imagine that how did
he find that creative idea but Fabiano
is trying to blow open the new shelter
of the white king it's getting really
dramatic on that left board and Wesley
so meanwhile still in a bit of trouble
against adoro but still within the
Realms of safety on the other semi-final
clash it's hard to predict what do we
think is going to happen will we see a
winner in one of the semi-finals I'm
just amazed to watch the King march by
Magnus Carlson and then Fabiano Carana
striking on that side of the board not
wasting any time to get to it and he's
also eyeing a potential Aon push at some
moment and I see Robert that something
catches your attention yeah that a pawn
push for Fabiano but both players down
near 10 seconds and that on the right
hand side the advantage is going for
black no near back up dusara in that
Bishop me up the pawn like David said
but me I have to be focused on Magnus
Carlson's King he goes after Fab's King
Fabby says no so whose pawns are weaker
whose King is safer it's the ultimate
question yeah it feels like magus's King
has been in trouble for so long but no
way through uh the moves are coming
thick and fast on both boards right now
can you go a three valuation Barz
dropped Fabiano is he winning oh my God
the black Rook can land on the second
rank Rook two it's a good start but that
Queen on C3 it covers all the bases wow
it feels like there's tactics in the air
Magnus offering a trade of queens now
Fabiano will say no look at that white
king it's naked all on its own wow
coming in and behind can he take another
pawn and get some passes of his own but
that deep Pawn will start que for check
it's a deadly threat well Fabiano's now
two pawns to the good surely he's going
to turn this material advantage into
Victory and if he does start pushing the
pawn there was a threat of A3 and
finally it does arrive on the board
offering a queen trade he will reject it
because it's all about getting to
magnus's King right now so he gives away
a pawn to open the F on the left hand
side of your screen the white king is
lacking shelter so mag is doing
everything he can to put his pieces in
front of it but Fab is going after the
D5 pawn and he's got passers of his own
at some point Fabi start pushing his
pawns but some nervous moves from both
players real nerves now showing Fabiano
giving a check with the black Rook the
problem is Black's pawns act as shelter
he doesn't really want to push them
until necessary but big threat the black
Rook threatening to go to F3 with a
nasty pin on the White Queen all the
checks look at that white king though
just too be no protection around it
Fabiano needs to pounce needs to win
this game he's outplayed Magnus whoa and
there's a check on B2 is that uh super
dangerous for white king forcing it on
the a file so the king can run the
question is can it hide and it's hiding
in front of that pawn on B4 in the left
hand side of your screen you see
magnus's King there AR too many pieces
remaining he's out in the open can that
deep Pawn suddenly become a queen is mag
is actually the one with the upper hand
it's really possibly turning around
right now all three results possible a
few checks the position repeating itself
will Fabiano bail out with a draw this
position's been seen already if he keeps
checking the white king he wants more he
wants more he's playing for the win no
safe squares for magnus's King you have
to go on to the C file you have to step
forward you have to run forward with the
white king but I think it's losing you
go up to C7 it goes diagonally The Black
Queen steps up one square to A7 with
check and I think he an AM mating net
the r slide over at the end I think that
Magnus is about to get checkmated and
Magnus he slows down but he's got six 6
seconds to decide now The Rook can go
onto the C file and win the queen he
gives up his Queen Magnus Carson surely
Fabiana is going to take it but look at
the white Pawn the remaining white Pawn
is so far Advanced still not over yet
Magnus has lost his Queen but he's still
fighting he's fighting because it's all
relying on these two pawns moving ahead
and Fabiano caran on seconds can he
convert this with Just 4 seconds on the
clock I think he made those quick moves
to gain the increment reminder to
everybody 3 seconds added every single
move you make so a quick check go block
that pawn and then push your own pawns
Fabby can win this game even if he loses
Queen for those two pawns then he can
push the Pawns of his own a rook can't
stop but he give away a check wow he
just blundered the pawn with cheze he
should have pushed the other one the G
Pawn wrong choice there and Magnus is
alive look at those white pawns
paralyzing the black queen and this can
be scary for BL because now the queen
can't move anywhere with the check
without allowing the dewn to promote and
Magnus is is does he have enough to hold
this well the problem for Magnus is that
g Pawn will be a decoy it's have to
sacrifice himself The Rook on D3 can't
move because the D7 Pawn in front of the
queen will be captured both sides
they're struggling a bit here five
doesn't know where to go but now it's
winning for Magness he brings his Rook
all the way down it he chooses the wrong
Square he trapped his own Queen and it's
handshakes Magnus Carson does the
unbelievable he wins down a queen wow
miracles do happen that was crazy stuff
and we will break it down in more detail
later Magnus Carlson on the brink of
defeat turns it around and wins
unbelievable turn around Fabiano
completely outplayed Magnus Carlson but
by Fab's own words Magnus is so
resilient that you may get a winning
position but actually securing the full
point super difficult and he can't
believe it himself with that headshake
what a finish that was but we've got to
quickly jump into this one with the
players playing on seconds does nbak
have a chance to take this he has decent
chances although pawns are disappearing
actually suddenly Wesley so a porn up if
we count and uh it's just about how
passive whes pieces are whes king not
really playing a role here white Bishop
on D1 the light Square Bishop stuck this
should still be a draw it's looked
drawish for a long time but after to Tor
maybe he's been pressing too hard he's
got to be careful indecision there
putting his King on a bit of a wrong
Square he almost put his King way too
far because he put his King all the way
uh down on the a file he might not have
been able to get back so look at Wesley
suddenly the tables have turned and
Wesley could play for a win without any
risk on Advantage Wesley push the the
push the pawn he's neglected to cover
his opponent's P Pawn he could have even
taking it off the board suddenly a new
Queen is incoming Bishop D4 you could
just play your Bishop out to challenge
the dark SC Bishop he goes Bishop F six
he wants the G Pawn instead oh my gosh
Wesley so's taking it abor was a pawn up
with black he had all the winning
chances zero losing chances until he
pressed too hard but now Wesley's given
up a keep on in the position does this
give nardack hopes to hold this one it's
going to be tough White's G Pawn is so
strong simply uh that pawn is going to
March up the board and look at how the
white Bishops control the black king cut
off the black king and this bishop trade
surely can just trade off yeah oh he's
trading off all the Bishops brilliant
and nyck he's resigned because all the
Bishops are coming off the board and
this will be a lost King Pawn ending and
nbec Abdu satro gives up Wesley so wins
takes the lead in their best of four
what a dramatic big fight both players
with the white pieces won their game and
both players with the white pieces were
in trouble but Wesley so he is not going
to lose a game without an epic fight
Magnus Carlson did the same against
Fabiano Carana these players are so hard
to take down wow Magnus Carlson doesn't
only have uh the biggest ability to
convert flawlessly winning positions but
it's impossible to beat him even when he
is uh busted and we see Magnus wins with
the white Beast is West
as well from a difficult end game
survives and takes the lead what a
dramatic finish that was just absolute
incredible chess played in those last
few seconds David wow just crazy uh I'm
struggling to uh collect my thoughts
here to catch some breath because that
was fast that was Furious blunders in
the end deciding them but the nerves
jangling it could have gone either way
after sattorov on the brink of Victory
Carana on the brink of Victory both
ended up losing and Robert Fabby
declined that repetition and went on to
get such a big Advantage he he pursued
magnus's King until Magnus lost his
Queen how does Magnus manag to still do
this chess can be absolutely brutal
there's only one winner and loser if the
game's not a draw F played way better
than Magnus did in that game he
completely outplayed the number one
player start to finish from the opening
he outplayed Magnus Carlson yet he is a
zero next to his name that's the evil of
time pressure you need to have time in
your clock to make the best moves and
there were some best moves made David on
both these games what got your attention
I just want to break down that Carlson
against Carana craziness uh from the
first game of today Karana did work his
magic he tracked down he hunted down
whes King and on the brink of Victory he
slipped up played the right idea in the
wrong move order and it was here where
the drama began here magnus's King has
been living a Charmed Life it did get
checked now this wins The White Queen
but this is only the beginning and after
the king dropped back we saw a crazy
position with White's far Advanced Pawn
suddenly trapping The Black Queen
forcing it to hide on a passive square
but if we fast forward just a few moves
as both sides started pushing their
pawns it was this moment Fabiano let it
slip he chose the right idea as I
mentioned but first he should have
pushed the G Pawn H3 he simply forgot
that Rook takes Pawn came with a check
no time for Black's Queen to take this
Pawn this is not a deflection and once
the black king moved away the white Rook
slid back suddenly from a winning
position Fabiano went to a drawish
position but it was more heartbreak to
come a few moves down the line after
this check from White he simply put his
King on the wrong Square King to F7
still holds the balance because after
The Rook slides up black queen has a
checking square a safe square instead he
blocked the Queen's escape and allowed
Rook to E8 nothing to be done white will
make a new Queen next move absolutely
heartbreaking because he had the right
conversion the right Tech in mind but he
just forgot that white can actually
capture the pawn with a check one move
is all it takes to turn a chess game
around he put his Pawn on pre with check
Magnus took it and then it was even
according to the engines but much easier
for white to play CU black was
completely stuck wrong Square chosen for
the king he had a tople his King Magnus
Carlson remains King and wins game one
oh wow and the world number two has to
strike back now against Magnus Carlson
and he almost took the lead in his match
some beautiful chess being played and
we've got some beautiful functional
metal posters for all of you there are
so many chess themed uh displates and
you will find a fantastic gift fantastic
holiday gift I do assure you go to
display.com
some really cool ways to decorate your
walls and you get a very cool
33% off use the code chess to get your
33% off and right now fabi's got to be
in a bit of an off mood but he has to
leave that aside as he plays Magnus
Carlson in game two can he get the job
[Music]
done all right next one oboro what's
your take on him he show that always a
fighter when he's uh when he's done I
would say fighter that's that's a word I
would I would give for Notre back always
goes for uncompromising stuff and is not
afraid of anyone I think Notre Beck is
probably the player who runs sort of the
hottest and coldest he'll either play
really well or really badly I don't
think there's any in between and um if
he's hot he see someone to watch he's
just like always fighting and putting up
resistance and he's really tough to beat
so that's that's the word I'd use for
him AB sator will do well cuz he has
such great sporting qualities um I don't
think he can win the tournament he will
be a difficult opponent for
everybody a new opening for your wall is
here captur new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
uh so first of all what is your take on
Magnus calls growing up he was my IDE
because when I started playing chess he
became World Champion 2013 it's always
pretty cool I play against him and I'm
happy that I managed to be quickly in
the top so I could compete against him
so he's really exceptional player
and um amazing Champion I mean he still
is the best player by far I would say uh
I don't think he's as motivated in chess
as he once used to be marus Carlson is
of course he has incredbly strong it's
very hard to play against him well
Magnus Carson um could definitely be
considered the greatest player of all
time or at least in a close battle with
uh with Gary Kasper yeah it'll be
interesting to play against him see his
form um and hopefully at least some of
us can put up a good fight and maybe
maybe beat him uh the difference between
me and Magnus was uh like 300 tour
points so it means uh it means a lot so
I think that speaks for itself uh as
people like to say
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhan you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
the mud store is better and bigger than
ever get a great gift for all the chess
lovers in your life maybe a plushy
mittens we all know how mean mittens can
be actually but that is a very very cute
plushy right there go to chess.com
do shop buy as much as you can for the
holiday season and to celebrate chess
and the holiday season we are in Toronto
right now where all the great chess is
happening we started with eight players
it's getting lonely as we are down to
just four and it gets lonelier at the
top when only two will be left and
what an action we had in game one of the
semi-finals we saw two big turnaround
moments and Kaa caught up with Magnus
after his miraculous
win just wow is what we have to say
about that game Magnus what will you say
yeah
um I don't know it seemed at some point
we were both playing for for win there
uh I mean of course a lot of things
happened before that but we were both
playing for a win then he was out
playing me at some point I was down to
seconds and then I don't know I don't
know what happened but uh I mean at some
point I started pushing my pawns I even
lost my queen but um somehow I managed
to to win I have no idea what is the
secret there to to stay I guess calm
when you lose your queen there and
eventually
win I don't know uh
I at least I had a clear plan which was
to push my pawns
and but it was um yeah it was a mess
what what was the emotions there in the
final
minutes
um I don't know I mean at the end it was
just disbelief cuz um he was about to
put his King on the right square and
then he put it on the wrong square and
lost on the spot so was bit bit
surprising but how good is it to win a
fight like this no no of course it feels
great so um and for the match it's it's
huge heart rate at the end there what
was it
I don't know mine is usually not that
high but I would guess higher than usual
probably congrats and good luck at next
one thank you wow yeah just wow you guys
what a fight between them in the first
game back to you guys say crazy game
there Ka I me how do you explain this
Magnus shows up messy hair looking like
he just woke up and then he loses a
queen dead loss position goes on to beat
the world number two he looks like he
was ready for a game just like that it
was messy it was not what you woke up
and wanted but it's what you got and
it's what he made out of it that was
quite the wakeup call for Magnus Carlson
for Fabby it's not the score line but
psychologically getting over the
position that he lost David yeah it's
going to be tough but luckily there's
not that long a break luckily the chess
is about to begin again and Fabiano will
want to bounce back and for wesle so as
well surviving a big scare he starts
with with the black pieces nck has some
positive takeaways from that game one
where he did get a good position there
are some positive takeaways but he also
maybe learned a valuable lesson of
pushing too hard because that is what
happens to all of the best players in
the world Magnus Carlson included that
sometimes you push a little bit too hard
it can backfire and we can see on the
screen the opening moves are being
played and yeah there they are I see the
dark score Bishop pins the Knight on F6
there will be pressure on the D5 Pawn
but this is Mainline Theory from both
players Mainline Theory it's the Queen's
Gambit declined uh both players clearly
well versed in their Queen's Gambit law
because uh look at the way they're just
slowly just uh calmly finessing the way
they move the pieces and uh okay a trade
of Bishop for Knight um maybe some
aggressive intentions behind I'm
wondering if Abdu sattorov will move the
White Queen out the way Castle on the
queen side I've seen him do that type of
thing before in online Blitz but in
Rapid against such a strong opponent
like Wesley so how much risk do you want
to take after a heavy defeat do you just
try to get on the scoreboard make a draw
postpone the tension to later in the
match or do you try and strike back
immediately he trades off Pawns in the
center now angling for a really quiet
game but Queen out to B3 putting
pressure on black Central Pawn early
days but uh yeah strange stuff
interesting stuff from Abdu satov
fascinating opening right here and for
Abdu satov it is a white right you have
to make the most of these chances you
probably don't have those many
opportunities to try to balance out
level out the score line but losing game
one and we see a different format here
from the one we've been seeing it's a
best of four are Fabby and nardack happy
now that it is a best of four because it
gives them more margin to strike back
not only is it best of four it's best of
two sets so even if they lose the match
today there's another match tomorrow
that they can take hold of but this is a
good start to the game for nybeck he has
an imbalance already and we'll see if
Fabby can get off to a good start
because he gets the white pieces and
we're about to have liftoff here as they
shake hands the 2018 World Championship
match between these two was epic let's
see if Fabby can get an epic comeback
started right now the sweater is off
Fabiano means business it's no more
Spanish torture it's the Sicilian
Defense instead and wow this is really
Hawking back to 2018 Robert flashbacks
of uh the opening debate consistently uh
discussing this exact opening uh in that
world championship match and okay a
trade of Bishop for right now Magnus
Carson playing the moves quickly this is
yeah I mean so many memories that was
one of the tensest world championship
matches I've ever seen and uh we're
arguing that uh this opening again uh
it's at the Forefront of both players
mind but A4 there now Magnus paw so in
the first game we were talking about the
Archangel that was really Fabiano Carana
main weapon here this at both of their
wheelhouses because 2018 all of their
games when fabbi was white headed into
this line but it's Magnus who is really
he's taking his time at these stages you
saw a flank pawn move for Fabiano the
knight jump behind it that Knight's
going to reroute into the center and
perhaps Magnus is saying this idea is
unfamiliar to me I haven't studied it
either recently or ever and Fabiano
perhaps outsmarting his opponent the
night developing on the edge is when
Magnus takes a pause uh perhaps not the
most topical most popular move in this
position uh you do see the night jumping
towards the center of the border the
Deep on moving forward open up the
bishop how much of a surprise is this
for Magnus Knight to A3 uh it definitely
is a surprise it's forced him to pause
for the first time in this game but it's
not the scariest surprise yes White's
Knight might relocate towards the center
to a really nice square but uh there's
no concrete threats and there's no kind
of tactics no calculation to be done yet
Magnus I think he's pausing because he
just wants to figure out how to set up
the black pieces firstly to fight
against White's Knight coming into C4
next move but uh also just maybe coming
to terms comparing with the ideas that
he actually does know that he was more
familiar with and uh we soon see him
bring his Bishop out this is a clear
reaction to White's plan the White
Knight at least temporarily was
prevented from using C4 but Fabiano
replies quickly as far as I know Pawn to
A4 this whole plan with white was
advocated by Alpha zero and all these
neural network engines so modern chess
uh played and uh yeah mirroring this
2018 World Championship that we've been
discussing and another pawn move by uh
Magus Carlson here which to me is
interesting because he supports the E5
Pawn but also vacates a square a
potential Square for his Knight to land
on where it can get to the edge of the
board from H6 and to F7 is are those the
kind of opening setups that Magnus is
aiming for bring your knight to F7 and a
potential kingside Castle absolutely and
the pawn on E5 is now extra well
defended and if you put your knight on
F6 a turn too that pawn was a bit loose
so look at Fabiano he brings his own
Knight towards the the center and that
Bishop on E6 that Magnus put there it's
his Bishop's Advantage he's the only one
with a light score Bishop he can take
this Knight doubling Fabiano's pawns
we'll have a wall of Pawns on the SE
file all of them doubled but look at
fao's development compared to Magus he's
ahead in development he does not mind
this capture one bit Yeah Magnus he has
a big decision if he does take that
Knight as you mentioned Robert it pretty
much means he's happy with the draw he
just wants to lock things down trade off
his long-term advantage of the bishop
pair uh just to shatter White's Pawn
structure balance out uh kind of make
things more symmetrical there if he
refrains from taking the White Knight it
means that he wants to play more
dynamically more ambitiously and I think
Tanya's plan of developing blacks pieces
first of all that black knight um that
is the most likely option um interesting
here but it is a slower maneuvering type
of position not sure that's exactly what
Fabiano wanted from the opening I'd be
surprised if Magnus decides to take that
Knight on C4 I hear you that you know
it's a good way to shut down the
position but I think Fab can still try
to push there because look at the pieces
that remain white would have a dark
Squad Bishop which would find itself
easy Targets on black spawns on C5 and
as I say it Magnus does take it but I
don't think this is without poison for
black we can imagine White's Bishop
developing to either E3 or A3 targeting
that C5 the double pawns that Magnus has
eventually the a pawn can move it start
moving up the board Magnus develops but
how much of inequality is this really I
think that Fabo might actually take this
KN because then is left with a bad dark
score Bishop staring in the air and that
A4 move that Fabiano played early on
Rook lift time take that Knight away
bring your own Rook up to A3 slide it on
over to the D3 scare with your queen try
to take over the only open file on the
board I'm not exactly sure where the
white knight will end up but if he takes
that Knight and reroutes his Rook I feel
like he may have the long-term
chances all right things are building up
in this one and we're going to check in
with our gang in Toronto it's Dany and
James joining us guys what a crazy game
one that
was yeah t it wasn't as hype when I
intruded in the middle of game one but
the energy was electric here as both
those games came down to the wire we
were out there with Levy Maxim is
hanging out with us that's mvl we've got
Cy and all of us were just on the edge
of our seats and I think Robert said it
well and I want to just throw to you you
saw notor just learn a super valuable
lesson about going up against so yeah of
course I mean you go up against the top
dog like that you best not miss right
and of course you pushed in a in a
position that he was drawn in he wanted
to push he wanted to play for more and
that's just his fighting Spirit not
backck loves to fight but you got to
take those draws you got to take what
you have and not just push I mean he's
not Magnus there obviously Magnus was
able to push a little bit he got away
with it but Wesley you're not going to
get away with that as solid as he is
Wesley so solid Flex Ley Serrano you're
not going to get away with that notb he
doesn't beat himself he doesn't beat
himself and I just want to add something
an anecdote that Christian Trill gave me
obviously catching up with his friend
Father IO in a heartbreaking moment but
just I call it Magnus bias itis off ant
but it's like hypnosis you had this game
where Fabby he pushed and he went for
the win he played A3 to open up magnus's
King but then in the critical moments it
was giving up the H Pawn with Czech
Fabby would never do that playing King
F6 instead of King F7 Fabby would never
do that and biggest of all instead of
Rook C6 fabbi was winning on the spot
with Queen C6 and Rook F4 like it's over
and it's one of those moments where you
don't understand the hypnosis
bias and thein that Magnus his group you
see things and it's just obviously needs
to forget it in Focus now but the energy
in the room was insane and then just
like what did we just watch with both
those guys Wesley and Magnus winning
games they had no business winning Danny
we've been talking about the exact same
thing in the studio about Magnus just
living rentree in his opponent's head
and I think it just felt like that the
the last few moments now with such short
turnaround time between the player
between the games and everything that we
just witnessed what is it like what are
the players doing between game one and
game
two honestly I mean Fabiano was was
stoic out there it's one of the best
parts about him he has short-term memory
like we say but he also didn't look
super happy right that's that's one of
those gut-wrenching ones you almost
would rather have gotten blown off the
board than have literally been a move
away probably from Magnus resigning like
Queen C6 instead of Rook C6 so I know
you saw it too but it it was a hard one
to shake off if you're Faby it was
definitely a hard one to shake off but I
do like as I mentioned before Fabby just
got the he came and talked to mvl real
quick he was like what about this A4
they just said a few moves couldn't hear
it too much but I knew they were talking
moves he was like ah okay all right cool
said something smile grabbed a snack and
went right back in like nothing happened
like I didn't was about to just beat
Magnus and lost very quickly love his
mindset and his psychology there yeah
and I'll say Notre backck similarly was
clearly not happy but also these guys
have the ability to shake it off so
anyway crazy stuff if we're in for that
all day I don't know that um I'm going
to I'm going to be able to make it butt
hope you guys are enjoying the tension
as much as we are over there we're
loving the action uh Dan we're still
getting over all that we just witnessed
but of course game two is on we will
check in with you guys later on Wow uh
just I can imagine for Fabby getting
over what just happened and for nbec as
well to bounce back to try to get it to
get it together in game two it's not
easy the biggest wow of everything that
they just said was that when Fabby won
the queen for Rook he could have won the
queen for free I wasn't even thinking in
that direction but if he' gone Queen C6
and a rook C6 a less intuitive move but
one that if you give him even five more
seconds on the clock to actually sit and
think he would have found it instantly
so that's going to be one that hurts
Fabiano it clearly has given Magnus a
reason to smile we saw his interview
with Kaa and this position should also
give Magnus a reason to smile there's
only one open file not much is happening
here I don't think Fabby even believes
there no chances in this game yeah the
players just calming their nerves after
what we just witnessed in game one Crazy
Action all around let's check in with
nbec Abdus satov he also suffered a
defeat in game one from a really good
position so again for him it's important
does he manage to create chances or will
he play Slow try to just stop the
bleeding it's a long match two set three
sets to play out uh he is though going
for those dark Square weaknesses that we
see in Black's Camp a csb structure
night A4 to me this looks like nck
doesn't need time to calm down from what
has just happened he is ambitious in
this one definitely the other semi-final
kowana against Carlson looks like the
Cal after the storm that looks likely to
fizzle out towards a draw as Fabiano
recovers and uh kind of gathers himself
after that heartbreak of the first game
Abdu sator also heartbreak for him but
he doesn't care he wants to fight that's
the kind of Mantra for him throughout
the entire tournament yes he's lost a
couple of games here and there but he
always seems to bounce back and he's ch
chosen a really uh kind of interesting
opening idea I must admit it's brand new
to me what he's done giving up White's
dark Square Bishop trading it off very
early on and installing a very powerful
White Knight in the center and this
White Knight on the rim as tany mentions
is heading into fresher pastures it's
coming in into C5 as well it looks like
White's got stability of course it's a
slower position this cpad structure that
arises from the Queen's Gambit like this
one um it does mean that normally you
need a lot of maneuvering it's very very
slow but he's trying to play it as
energetically as possible Pawn to F4 not
really uh launching an attack yet it
just looks like a very nice controlling
type of move but uh it's definitely
pressure on Wesley so to break out of
what looks like a bind right now it's
those positions where white can play on
both sides of the board we see the
Knight and queen binding down the queen
side meanwhile white also hinting at
Pawn expansion on the king side for
Wesley where does he find his breaks
well he went Rook C8 just now he may be
intending to play C5 but that's not easy
to accomplish with the White Knight The
Pawn in the center and the queen all
lined up I love these positions for
white in quicker time controls this
isn't quite a Blitz game I think in a
Blitz game honestly black gets Blitz off
the board quite often but it's just not
a comfortable situation to be in for the
black side because your Pawn breaks the
C5 one hard to accomplish white on the
other end can start throwing even more
Pawns of the I wouldn't be H3 Follow by
Pawn G4 let's storm pawns up the
kingside and go for a deadly attack I
love it Robert that's where White is
strongest that's where white has placed
his Rooks after all uh yes there's one
long-term deficiency in White's position
that's the backward E Pawn it will never
really step forward safely without being
traded off or simply one uh so you're
kind of playing around this Pawn but
this is the side you've committed you
have the beautiful statue uh the granite
statue here there Knight on E5 and uh
your Rooks of pois so why not open lines
and I think we'll see that it's nbec
style uh Pawn to H3 it does take a while
to set it up but once you get a pawn
forward you can slide the White Queen
across as well then start pushing
everything towards this black king and
uh meanwhile Wesley has to bank on the
fact he can break out on the queen side
but not so simple yeah it's a very good
position for Abdu satoro right now it's
good air quality as well it looks like
he's uh loving life in this game as he
aims to bounce back and he does need to
bounce back and he's done it before
against Hikaru he did lose the first
game then won the second one then won
the armagen and once again we see nbak
at least hinting at a position that's
going to be extreme ex imbalanced once
those pawns start moving Wesley will be
under pressure and will have to find
play on the other side of the board and
it's traditional wisdom your opponent
goes for the flank attack you strike in
the center I think it's going to be a
race about G4 and C5 well you're talking
about a race you're talking about time
I'm looking at Wesley's clock 6 minutes
and 34 seconds compared to over 10 for
no dearbeck he plays with this speed
that's actually quite imposing it's hard
to deal with and I look at this position
we're talking about Pawn H3 Pawn for you
can put your King on the H file put a
rook behind the G Pawn things like that
are going to be scary and even now I
feel like Nock he can put his Knight on
C5 if he wants he plays A3 maybe he'll
play Pawn to B4 just to clamp down on
the queen side that C5 idea that break
in the center it's not happening anytime
soon yeah I love it we talked about
great air quality this is just great
chess in general NC I mean I'm going to
go study this one because it looks like
he's put Wesley so out of his comfort
zone and that is such a difficult thing
to do it's very rare to see Wesley after
17 moves of what is a very well
established opening uh the most
classical historic of openings the
Queen's Gambit and black struggling for
moose struggling for a clear-cut plan
white has full control in the center
Queen side I'm normally a proponent of
Black's positions uh in this type of
opening but yeah here I'm just really
struggling it's just really beautiful
for white the last two moves is a
perfect example of playing against your
opponent's ideas for nbec he pushes the
pawn to A3 he was hinting at expanding
the B Pawn for forward just making sure
that Wesley never gets that Central
Breakin remember if Wesley doesn't get a
central Breakin it gives nbec a free
hand on the king side to start pushing
his own pawns up the board and Wesley on
his own turn stops that idea so he
stopped the advance of B4 but every pawn
move has its own set of consequences and
that pawn on A5 it takes away a key
Square from Black's Queen where it could
have helped that c pawn move forward to
C5 so with no Queen A5 coming up does
thatan make it more difficult for Wesley
to strike in the center if I'm not I'm
just playing for that King set attack I
know that's sometimes called you
tunneling but I don't see what black
does to stop it very easily and it's
actually just a decent move pushing your
Pawn to H3 it supports that pawn push
and I'm not seeing how Wesley
accomplishes his ideas and one really
annoying thing for Wesley that Knight on
E5 it's such a nasty piece there because
even if black tries to take it there
will be uh some problems in that
scenario for example if you bring your
let's say go H3 and go Knight D7 let me
get that Knight off the board Pawn to F5
just use the pawn as a battering Rim
that Bishop is trapped and you're just
in grave danger at this stage this is
one of those situations where I would be
deeply uncomfortable as Wesley so so
after H3 I David maybe I have to throw
it to you like what should black do to
stop these obvious ideas that white is
about to unleash yeah it's difficult
Robert I think H3 psychologically would
have been a great move as well he's
actually played Rook to see1 so maybe
saving that one for later but H3 and uh
it's not just the fact that it does uh
kind of scare the opponent but it also
forces Wesley to burn a lot of time like
is this a threat first of all if it is
how do you guard against it Wesley would
have been in the tank for a long long
time Rook C1 is a controlling type of
move so I don't hate it but uh it does
bring the Rook away from what could have
been a nice uh Square maybe supporting
the E Pawn later he I think he's just
trying to shut down on this Square clamp
down on C5 as long as black cannot push
the pawn on this flank he can play H3 G4
at will later on it might be time to at
least hint at removing this Knight maybe
with the bishop and you just sit at the
right moment you might be able to
capture or throw a knight into E4 even
at the cost of a pawn he does play this
move but I think we all still prefer
white here in the studio we're all
loving what nbec has done in the early
stages no question about that and not a
back style it is one where he if he gets
the opportunity to play for the
initiative he doesn't back down so
definitely H3 is on his radar it is on
his mind but I like that move Rook to C1
because it really makes sure that blacks
be he Pawn never really gets moving
because of the pressure on the SE file
if we just from a broader picture zoom
out and think about the last few moves
that nbec has played it looks like he's
playing on the king's side as well as
the queen side he's not only thinking
about his own attack but he's making
sure that Wesley's counterplay on the
other side of the board is stopped and
there you have it so he's combining
ideas full board awareness he's showing
restraint and I think that is a sign of
maturity that he's able to recover from
that first game get a nice plus and play
his own
terms yeah all right well this one will
definitely be put be putting uh Wesley
so Under Pressure but let's move on to
our other game where Fabiano Carana on
the score line is a little bit under
pressure uh and we see an end game
pieces have been traded off only a rook
and Knight remaining but is white can
white try for more simply given that the
pawn on A5 is up the board you've got F4
ideas but it's black who strikes first
in the center yeah and maybe this was
out of necessity I actually have a
feeling that Magnus is a bit complacent
or he has been in the last few moves
because it was dead level it should
still be roughly level but he's been
forced to take concrete action when he
would rather have just been sitting and
uh pretty much just setting up this
defensive formation and uh look at this
now white does have a big threat on the
board White's Knight after this Pawn
trade is coming coming to D3 next move
where it would attack two pawns Black's
E Pawn is undefended in the sense there
now isolated as well and the head of
Black's Pawn chain on the queen side the
black C5 Pawn also
undefended suddenly I think Magnus might
be starting to feel a bit uncomfortable
if he'd put the Black Knight on a
different Square perhaps he would have
shut down all of these ideas for good
and there's something misleading here
the black Rook is obviously on an open
file White's Rook is actually on an open
file you may think I'm crazy what is
Robert talking about what's happening
here is that when the White Knight steps
forward out to D3 to attack that head
Pawn the one on C5 black will be forced
to play the move B6 and when you play B6
white can take that pawn on B6 and now
that Rook on A1 sitting on what would
seem like a starting Square it's open it
can Venture into enemy territory A6 or
A7 and start poking and prodding so that
Rook A1 idea from Fabiano he kept his
Rook there very clever play by him yeah
and uh Magnus the problem is how does he
stop this idea um I was going to say
earlier if you he had simply put the
Black Knight on E6 he would have guarded
this Pawn he would never have had to
touch anything on the queen side and it
should have been a simple draw but
Black's Knight just just unable for the
moment to find any nice squares again
Magnus would love to kind of teleport it
over to an outpost but too slow white is
getting there first with a beautiful
night jump and suddenly pressure on the
world number one Magnus Carlson um it
looked like a draw should still be a
draw with best play but some questions
to answer and if we follow that line
through I think the most logical
continuation as Robert mentioned this is
certainly uncomfortable with the white
Rook coming in uh suddenly big big
threats coming uh behind the c Pawn
coming behind the G Pawn it's only a two
result game black is the one defending
white can apply pressure with zero risk
and ideally black could trade off the
Rooks but the king is doing an important
job for black as well Rook D7 loses on
the spot because I trade Rooks steal
your E Pawn steal your G pawn and that's
game over so it's one of these things
where you want to cure your problems in
the seventh rank but the solution and da
would say could be worse than
disease wow Magnus cson on the defense
in an end game not something that you
get to see every day uh but in my head
it's hard to imagine any reality any
world where Magnus gets outplayed in an
end game we know that he is one of the
best players of all times when it comes
to this stage of Chess but Fabiano
Carana not only putting pressure on the
board but the clock as well ahead by
almost 3 minutes now Magnus on a think
so perhaps the clock difference will
increase on this move Magnus realizes
that he is uh going to have to defend
this for a very long time yeah there's
something in the air in Toronto we're
not used to seeing Magnus get outplanted
in an end game but we're not used to
seeing Fabiano blunder tactically and
just feels like everyone is just reeling
from uh kind of the drama that's
unfolding and talking of drama that's
sunfolding Robert White's Advantage has
massively increased just in the last few
moves since we were last here and it's
White's turn right now so that Queen on
C2 can just steal a Pawn on e4 and white
has both massive pawns on E5 and F5 that
can push forward in the near future
Wesley so blundered just a couple turns
ago so if we can dive in and analyze the
last few moves Wesley had a difficult
decision we were talking about this for
a while that he was a bit passive that
the ideas were easier to execute from
the white side but if we just go back a
few turns when um NC was able to push
his Pawn up to F5 Wesley tried to
sacrifice a pawn in the center and after
F5 here I think black has to go F6 a
really really difficult move to play
challenging that pesky Knight in the
center still holds in Black's position
you don't need to even take this bishop
on E6 if you don't want it white should
have a superior position but what he did
in the game he retreated back to D7 and
after the Knight was captured on e4 this
is all of a sudden just an extra Pawn
for white and it's a great position
winning chances for nyback yeah I think
what he might have missed is that he
cannot capture this bishop now if he had
simply taken back the bishop then series
of captures a series of takes takes
takes and whoops there's a double attack
a simple Knight Fork would have won
material for white so he was obliged to
take the White Knight off in the center
but this is how he's established these
powerful pawns now here at nbec and yeah
simply a pawn Advantage these two pawns
are glorious ious the White Knight is
clearly Superior to its counterpart
especially if it jumps in and I don't
know how you even try and save this game
if you try to go for this porn then
white can simply move the knight in yet
again the problem is this bishop is
attacked pressure there so the black
queen has no time to go and capture and
Wesley's desperate now he's throwing
even more pawns away to try and free up
his Bishop a good try but uh White can
simply capture if he wants to yeah and
uh nck this is move number 23 getting
such a big advantage against the hardest
to beat player on the circuit definitely
a big achievement I think the score line
in this match is not reflective of the
quality nck was also ahead in game one
and there are already a lot of tactical
ideas you're pointing out that the C5
Pawn is hanging uh David I'm also
looking at trying to open up Black's
King side I'm not sure what I want to
start with whether it's the F Pawn
moving forward or sacrificing the e-
pawn I'm actually I really want to
discuss this with you guys give up the
ewn force black I like that Robert uh
nodding his head in approval so E6 you
take that pawn and now I'm not I don't
want to capture that back I just want to
blow open your king side I want to go F6
I want my queen on G6 and this is the
kind of Chess that we expect out of nbec
as well is this something that's on his
radar definitely I mean uh the greedy
player in me is saying take a porn play
on try to uh just collect and uh win
long term but why win longterm when you
can win on the spot and point to E6 as
you mentioned Tanya would be a dagger
blow to Wesley so's position here I
don't even see how to try and fight on
yes you can move the bishop that's
attacked I think the variation you
pointed out is just too strong this
battering ram blows open the black
position Pawn takes Pawn for example a
check and everything drops with Tempo uh
White's Rook will soon come in to end
the game uh so this is just Unthinkable
and if you cannot take this Pawn you
have to move your Bishop what do you
play do you attack the White Queen I
mean this looks just too powerful you at
the very minimum maybe there's even
stronger but you can uh ask the black
king to step out into the open now you
can deliver a bunch of checks pawns
aren't going anywhere you're actually
material up this just looks terminal E6
might be the strongest of them
all and uh this is a big moment for nbec
does he go Pawn hunting will he be
materialistic right now will he play
more will he play for Wesley's King and
E6 is on the board it's a move that n
irback could have played in a second but
I think after that first game he's biing
his time a little more making certain
that his ideas are good but this is
clearly strong as we're just showing if
you take that pawn it's kind of a
removing the guard tactic it allows the
queen to venture into the G6 Square
lader that F7 Pawn the golden Pawn
Central to the king's defense and that
pawn on E6 Pawn on F5 all the pawns are
going forward and the black king I don't
think is surviving yeah really thematic
really typical sacrifice to blow up in
the opponent's king remember this one at
home and uh AB TF using it to great
effect and how critical is the clock
situation right now given the position
position a big task ahead of Wesley to
defend it pieces is falling down while
he does trade uh a pair of minor pieces
and now he's taking does white still go
F6 yeah do it clearly that's his plan
Abdus satoro if he doesn't play F6 now
then uh it would be less consistent and
actually material is suddenly level but
it's all about the black king and it's
about the white Rooks The Rook on F1 is
perfectly placed that other Rook is
going to hit the queen on the defile
then Barrel on down to the seventh Rank
and this is what NCA is doing he's
clearing the seventh rank of black pawns
that means the King has no shelter and I
think actually this is a very quick
knockout if you take that pawn Rook D1
Rook D7 it looks over look at Wesley so
on the camera he looks already defeated
pretty much he just went to pick up a
piece to fiddle with but he's only got
two minutes defending is harder than
attacking he's going to have to watch
out for the White Queen to switch those
Rook slides as Robert mentions it is
another heavy piece position and we saw
how dangerous those can be in the
previous clash between Carlson and
kowana
uh when it's just the major pieces Rooks
and queens it's all about King safety
black is about to have none of that at
all and uh you can simply take on G7 if
you want to uh maybe there's even
stronger but just rid the black king of
its shelter and long-term white is
winning excellent play by nber abov he's
up a pawn he sacrifices two Pawns in
return to blow open Wesley's King he's
going for blood in this one look at the
determination on him on the screen as
well uh he's got some pleasant choices
to make but sometimes having choices is
the biggest problem in chess he can
slide that Rook to the open file with
Tempo hit that Queen he can also further
go on to pick up the G7 Pawn but both
looking very pleasant he decides to
bring the final Rook into the attack
looking strong looking good Abdu satoro
also in terms of style of the position
it's right up his Ali loving to attack
loving the initiative Magnus said
himself in that interview we saw earlier
uh he loves to pounce when given an
opportunity Wesley normally likes a bit
more stability than this one he wants
kind of stable positions where he can
outmaneuver his opponents here he's
clearly just getting attacked look at
Black's pieces all planted on their back
rank Queen trade offered white is
definitely going to say no White's Queen
likely to slide across now repurpose
herself she's so agile this White Queen
is likely going to be the piece that
delivers the killer blow and Checkmate
in one threatened this is a pin on the G
file Queen takes porn you have to guard
against it Wesley is forced into ugly
defensive moves Rook to F7 he's holding
but maybe not for long that's what it
looks like you don't even have time to
pick up the F6 Pawn because the G Pawn
was pinned Wesley so is in big trouble
and you mentioned it David that uh nck
loves to play for the initiative and
it's something that Magnus has spoken
about nck as well uh there was this
interview and I'm going to butcher the
name of this but David I need some help
for you on this podcast is it the shack
Snack Shack snack means basically what
does it mean chess talk chess okay so on
Shack snack uh Magnus mentioned that
Abdus satov he's not the biggest talent
amongst the youngsters but he's the one
who's got the most sportsmanlike
qualities give him the opportunity to
get the initiative he takes it with both
hands he's always in the gym Pumping
Iron very serious and well prepared is
that the nck we're seeing it absolutely
is but I heard the word snack not only
am I hungry it looks like Fabiano is too
he stole he snacked on the C5 Pawn on
the right hand side of our screen if we
do a quick count of material Fabiano is
a pawn ahead against Magnus Carlson I
know Magnus leads this match Fabiano has
played better than Magnus and on the
left hand side of our screen nordbeck
and Wesley they're about to enter that
time trouble territory down to a minute
left and you see the eval bar no longer
does n dearbeck have the advantage so
maybe he let his pressure linger a
little too long and W's able to escape
yeah we cursed him the commentators
curse we were talking about how great
those sporting qualities are how
ambitious he is always jumping on the
initiative Abdu sator he's still better
I really still like White's position in
that one but Wesley so suddenly
defending and suddenly holding things
together and really really impressive
tenacious stuff there so both games in
the balance it looks like Karana is a
favorite Abdu sator still a slight
favorite in his one as well uh both
players with white with the winning
chances but it's not going to be easy to
convert and Magnus makes his move he
brings King the bar is going up and up
and up so it seems like Magnus has gone
wrong on numerous occasions already two
games into this match and the left hand
side of a screen Wesley he's froze
he's about to make a move with 40
seconds left he brings his Rook on over
to f8 and the bar starts creeping up
it's such a natural move defending a
rook but now is the time for no dearbeck
the left hand side of your screen
everybody Pawn takes Pawn right next to
the black king you rip to shreds Black's
defensive resources there are not many
pawns there it looks really tough to
defend for Wesley I'm going to point out
one trick on that left side of our
screen where if white does take Pawn
takes Pawn black will have the time to
recapture with the Rook because you
might think black's Rook on f8 is
hanging but but watch out there can be
there's a checkm in one on G2 and look
at that big move that is big chess by
nbec Abdus satov a rook sacrifice
impressive stuff there Abdu satarov we
mentioned he loves to attack and he
overworks the black Rooks right now the
two black Rooks are tied defending each
other Tethered to each other and he's
trying to deflect one away so the White
Queen can go and capture the black Rook
on F7 out of the blue out of nowhere a
shot in the dark suddenly Wesley so in
trouble look at the clock as well the
evaluation bu shot up Checkmate again
threatened he's panicked weso he did not
react well to this but incredible
tactical awareness from aboro the
tenacity from abatar it's reminiscent of
Carana fuja with a rook sacrifice in the
final rank Wesley down to 5 seconds he
needs to make a move he does give a
check the white kick can escape and
meting one was threaten he brings his
Rook back you can take the rook and you
can go F7 isn't that just winning game
over if he sacrifices his Queen right
now Abdu satov he does it it's on the
board Abdu finds the finishing touch
you're also threatening to promote to a
knight with a nice Fork on the black
king and black queen this is simply game
over weso resigns Abdus satra of the
comeback kids strikes again leveling the
game and in what style amazing
performance that sacrifices the queen in
the end with a win wow it's good that
the players don't see the Evo bar swing
up and down because for notc he was
always on the prowl he gets the dub
evens up the score and Fabiano Carana
right now was looking to nybeck for some
wisdom some advice hey can I Channel
your spirit here and nb's looking at
that very game and as we see nyback
storm off he should be feeling proud of
himself and Fabiano wants to join nck
back in a one-1 score yeah fantastic
game there one of the games of the
tournament so far and Meanwhile we're
left with this semi-final car kowana has
still this extra porn we talked about
Magnus Carson had to give up a pawn uh
just to prolong the fight and it's not
just that but it's a massive strategic
Advantage Magnus you can tell the body
language there not confident at all
right now we're at move 44 and Fabiano
with a bit of time thinking he needs to
land the killer punch he does not want
to let Magnus Slither away survive like
he did in the previous game it's looking
great for Fabiano Carana he is the time
to think just a game ago when he had the
black pieces he had a winning position
but he was down to those final seconds a
great time management from Fabiano he's
controlled the board he's controlled the
clock and I think he's just a couple
moves away from ceing the deal we
actually can see a white knight on C6
it's putting pressure both on the far
left Pawn on A7 you see the clock for
the players and for Fabiano I think it's
now time for him to bring his Rook into
the action a knight it can't work
operate by itself it's not a lone wolf
help with the Rook yeah and that's a
juicy Square I was going to say the
center of the board but he chooses
another one also attacking Black's
weakness and you can see that black
spawn so much more vulnerable right now
The Rook the Knight that Magnus has tied
down to defend right now uh and it is uh
all Fabby in this end game but will it
be enough the Knight is jumping you've
got to be a little careful of not
getting trapped but there's that B7
Square defended guarded by that pawn on
A6 that keeps the Knight safe yeah and
that's the key Pawn just next to the
clock White's Pawn over on A6 next to
magnus's clock is holding everything
together but also a potential Queen two
squares away from touchdown from
promotion Magnus is chasing this Knight
desperately around the board but it does
have one Safe Haven anchored by that
pawn and we'll see it drop back black
spawns just weak he needs to move
quickly though Magnus Carlson no time
but how much of a psychological moment
is this well I was going to say does he
come back with the night but Fabby is
not repeating this position he knows
that he's close to this one brings The
Rook to defend that Knight on d8 no
checks on C6 black stops it is it time
to jump in with the Rook to the Central
Square now it absolutely is he should
have done it before but he's given a
second chance bring your Rook forward
your knight can always escape to that B7
s Square might still be a good move here
but with the Rook either joining on D5
or d8 I think that magnus's forces are
overwhelmed and Fabby he's spending
quite a lot of time here he's getting
himself into that time trouble that he
needs to avoid yeah that's the only
thing that can save Magnus Carlson now
the clock as we saw in the previous game
and Fabiano does bring his rook in still
no threat but the realization that black
has barely any moves will make him more
confident right now Black's Knight is
stuck if it ever moves the White Knight
comes into C6 with a check Black's King
maybe moose okay he checks with the Rook
but this is only helping the white king
come around the white king is actually
going to March up the board via the H
file this infiltration white king is
going to step up up and in and magnus's
defenses are crumbling he tries
counterplay with his Rook but this
allows the White Knight FREE and that
break out A7 Pawn so that one is going
to fall that white Rook goes to the
final rank kicks that KN on out of there
A7 drops that pawn that was thrust all
the way up to A6 it was early on where
he went A4 it went to A5 it has not
stopped mov moving the pressure
continues and I think it's about to be a
winning material for him but he takes
the E Pawn instead I'm not such a fan of
this but he still has the same idea in
mind that being said pawns are starting
to disappear and if everything
disappears black will be able to
sacrifice a knight maybe for White's
remaining pawns later but now he's
removing the defender Black's Knight
kicked away and the aorn drops Magnus
cson in big big trouble White's a PA is
two squares away is going to promote
that is a big pawn and Desperation there
by Magnus he's just trying to create
some with checks white still has to be
careful that KN jumping around there are
checks on the board Fabby needs to get
his King to safety and then the a pawn
wins the game I was surprised he moved
his King up but it goes back around
Knight back to B5 the pawn is
Unstoppable as long as he can bring his
Knight back push A7 The Rook actually
covers the promoting Square I think
Magnus might even just resign here yeah
you look at him and you got the feeling
he's about to give up Magnus Carlson and
that's it hand shakes Fabiana Karana
level the score with a win against the
world number one he was winning in game
one did not finish the job but he gets
it done in game two he has the utmost
belief in himself he just out Magnus
Magnus Carlson he beat him in a
technical end game it looked like there
shouldn't be much hope to win and
Fabiano Carana got the job done he walks
out of the playing Hall a much more
confident man he's proven again that he
can take down Magnus Carlson in any game
yeah absolutely there's so much history
between these two players and today
there's so much Glory on the line as
well Fabby Strikes Back nck strikes back
and Kaa caught up with Abdul satov after
his big win against
Wesley here with the comeback kid ndec
you must be just so happy right now yeah
I'm happy um that I managed to come back
and win a game but obviously um I was
also a little bit disappointed because
it was first game where you know I had a
Advantage like risk-free um end game
that I managed to lost but yeah I'm I'm
I'm quite happy
that I you know I quickly come back yeah
I mean Wesley so he has hardly lost a
game ever how are you able to beat
him yeah um played an opening um where
which um he played against me and
uh I got a kind of in position and he
spent too much too much time there but I
couldn't find anything and I think he
missed F5 after Knight
E4 after which it's completely lost for
black I think and we're definitely now
going to see this match go to four games
what will be the strategy now in the
final two games I'm just keep keep um
keep keep the momentum and uh you know
I'll try my best and yeah it's I'm I
will be not surprised if if we'll head
to our meon right well congratulations
and good luck next one thank
you equalizes against Wesley so back to
you guys n back in his cool Puma
sweatshirt playing some really really
cool chess there against Wesley so and
levels that match is it fair to say that
so far even though the match is 1-1 nbec
has been the better player I think in
both matches the player that won game
two has played the better match and it's
one to one because of the defensive
tenacity the resourcefulness of both
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson but I do
think Fabiano Carana and NC abdar have
played better in their matches yeah I
have to fully agree and I also have to
apologize for earlier calling that
Carana Carlson game to come after the
storm because there's no calm here
there's no chill out in Toronto there's
just Blood on the board players throwing
everything at each each other on every
single move every single game absolutely
this is why we watch chess this is why
we believe for moments like this the
comeback moments of players who are
underdogs on paper but this guy he is
the man to beat right now what a
performance in the BR Robin and it's not
back Abdus satra the youngest ever World
rapid champion who has to get the job
[Music]
done
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
n
[Music]
Fabiano Carana yeah Fabiano has been a
machine recently well he's done that in
the past of course there was a singfield
cup in 2014 we won7 in a row two against
me I think he's a great player but I
still like my chances he calculated
calculates just brilliant it's weird to
say but he's really On The Rise now he's
maybe the most prepared player in the
world so he's is really in good shape he
won the singfield cup and grandchester
he's been
playing very well in classical chest and
also he's been playing reasonably in in
Rapid and Blitz yeah I don't think it's
likely that he'll that he'll win the
tournament but he has a chance to do
well for sure he has shown uh incredible
results this this year in classical
chess one of the best players of our
time and and one of the you know biggest
favorite of this field well Fabiano
easily is the hottest player at the
moment he's had the best results over
the board in 2023 very formidable
opponent I think for for him if he gets
his positions out of the open is great
preparation he's he also has a great
chance to win but I mean we'll see what
[Music]
happens
to
[Music]
while it's cold in beautiful beautiful
Toronto the semi final action is heating
up we have been seeing some dramatic
chess some big turnaround and uh
Precision by players with very less time
on the clock we spoke about how how nbec
has been the better player so far in the
last two games against Wesley but Fabby
as well does he have the upper hand
against Magnus today there's no doubt
that Fabiano woke up stronger than
Magnus Carson today the first game he
was on the brink of Victory just one
accurate move and it would have been
lights out Magnus would have had to
resign instead we saw that last minute
turnaround the second game out playing
Magnus Carson in an end game we have to
give that the utmost credit it happens
so rarely once in a blue moon and the
way he did it Mak it look easy uh Fabian
bang in form right now there's a reason
why Magnus Carlson has always applauded
Fabiano and said this is a serious
Contender to the throne no matter who's
up there Fabio can get it done it's
almost a shame that he's the same
generation as Magnus Carlson because
otherwise we might be talking about Fabi
Carana in that light but he's proving it
against him head-to-head Fabiano he can
get it done he just did it's one to one
two games left
today Magnus Carlson definitely needs to
wake up now after that last game and
Fabby just continues continues to
impress Ka got a hold of Fabby after
that spectacular game to
win so I called nordc The Comeback Kid
so I guess I will call you the comeback
man congrats on a great win thank you
how did this go about well I think that
we're both playing rather poorly so far
first game was a disgrace to put it
mildly uh of course okay we were in time
trouble so that can kind of excuse some
of the blunders but I think the blunders
were too massive and second game he got
a very comfortable position slightly
better at some point I mean okay he's
he's definitely not risking he blundered
King F1 already I'm not worse anymore I
think he probably blundered King E3 as
well and he started to get worse he
started to drift into a bad position and
then it was uh kind of difficult to
defend well strong words there about the
way you guys are playing it's definitely
entertaining is there nerves involved
here do you think the reason for those
inaccuracies I don't feel really nervous
I just think that uh yeah the first game
was um
I mean okay with time pressure and these
complications of course you you tend to
make some serious mistakes but like my
last mistake also I missed I think Queen
C6 probably just forcing winning a queen
and probably I missed Checkmate by force
at some point uh to lose that was kind
of
um kind of tilting but okay I've I've
been in some unfortunate situations
before so and you have equal equalized
momentum now on your side how can you
use that going into the two final uh
rapid games well now it's like the
familiar situation two two games like
all the previous matches that we played
so um yeah I don't know I I I want to
try to improve my play a bit and try to
play a bit more stable but I I am of
course very glad to be to have equalized
the match well congrats on that one good
luck in the next one thank you all right
this one will be an interesting one
definitely four games in the match with
Magnus and Fa back to you
guys what on Earth was that Fabby I mean
to us it looks like chess from another
planet and he says we guys have been
playing poorly what do you make of that
chess players are always critical of
themselves and that's what helps them
get better as players because when you
analyze your own games you always are in
the search the objective search for the
truth and for the players to get better
at their high level is to be
self-critical to always look for
improvements that's true when I was
working my way through the ranks as a
youngster I came across so many
opponents who said I played great I
dominated I crushed my opponent and
those were the players who never really
kind of make that next step it is that's
why we see the top players being their
own harshest critic and Fabiano I think
deep down he'll know he's played pretty
well he was only harsh about himself
because of one or two blunders in the
first game but the general flow the
general momentum is on his side and uh
yeah he if he can uh continue this form
I think he might be the favorite for the
rest of the day and for Magnus he's of
course experiencing this flow that Fab
is bringing on so what do you think his
mindset is uh do you think he's really
waking up now and realizing that Fabby
means business today I think Magnus has
been through it all so this is not his
first rodeo he's suffered against
opponents who outplay him including
Wesley so has done that very thing but I
think for Magnus what he needs to do is
play one solid game overall instead of
uh this kind of Shifty games hoping for
something he just needs to stabilize he
of course is the best player of all time
so when he wants to get it done when he
feels settled he can get it done and the
other player who's failed to keep it
solid on the board so far is Wesley
David what was the big turnaround moment
in that game yeah I just want to
highlight one moment because actually
Abdu sator played a great game from
start to finish but the Tactical flurry
at the end was so impressive and
actually some really hidden nuggets some
gems in the Tactical uh sequence at the
end that I wanted to show everyone at
home in this position Black's defenses
look like they're holding up with two
Rooks stacked up on the file keeping
their King nice and safe but White's
Queen is so strong this Rook as well
really well placed and this was the
killer blow to overwhelm Black's
defenses Rook to d8 a shot in the dark
out of nowhere and uh here Wesley so did
collapse very understandable Wesley had
no time on the clock he did indeed take
this Rook he should perhaps have blocked
just tried to cut up into a ball but uh
a good position for white nonetheless
instead Rook takes Rook was met by a
capture threatening Checkmate in one and
Wesley here gave a check this is very
clever forcing the white king to H2
dropping back his rook and after white
sacrificed the queen pushing forward his
Pawn next move I think Wesley was
banking on the fact he could have played
the move G5 hitting the white Rook if
the white Rook moves anywhere The Black
Queen could have given a nasty check now
hence the reason the King was forced to
the square and now it could have slid
back to f8 blocking the white Pawn but
it was this position Wesley resigned
because he'd suddenly realized after G5
white doesn't promote to a queen white
promotes to a knight a beautiful Fork
here a royal Fork the king moves the
Knight takes the queen and white ends up
and peace to the good I love it when
players unearth these tactics and we get
to see what's going on in their brains
the wheels are turning but they are
finding these unbelievable tries and
credit to Wesley for trying to trick
notbe you couldn't trick him because
he's not going to promote to Queen he
knows how to under promote he's going to
get that Knight fork and get the job
done Magnus cson and Wesley so boths
outplayed in game two in their own
territory their own style NC Abdu satov
with the aggressive Suffocation strategy
in his game playing on the king side
playing on the queen side just
incredible stuff by him and then the end
game that we saw the end game technique
by Fabiano caruana the favorites on the
paper that start of Magnus being a 71%
having those odds going into the final I
think that's a bit shaky right now well
I think Magnus is still the favorite
just because he's Magnus Carlson but I
will always say that it's just true but
Fabiano is proving that in this match
this is the day where perhaps Fabiano
could take him down magus completely has
to turn around his gameplay it's not the
Magnus we're accustom to seeing but
that's all credit to Fabiano who's
forcing him into uncomfortable
territory and the good news for players
is that where they're playing it's great
territory because they've got great wow
I wasn't expecting that they've got
great air quality and you can win this
very very cool wave plus air things
device and it's signed by the one and
only world number one Magnus Carlson so
get your air things device to keep a
check on your air quality to get those
rating points up to play some of your
best chess yes robit can I ask a
question does that help me remember
positions like Magnus did when I don't
even have to see them but they air
things devices over there if I get that
cuz it's right there I can take it will
that help me yeah I feel like if we
start playing I mean the bullets and the
blitz that we've been playing before the
show with this air things uh device on
I've already gained like 50 points on
chesc so it might be working and this is
the one that'll be coming your way so
head over to our social media channels
uh to uh get a chance to win this Magnus
Carlson signed air things quality what
about the quality of play that we're
expecting from the players going into
game three what's going to be the switch
up from Wesley and Magnus I'm curious
about Wesley in particular because he
just was shaken and Wesley is somebody
who's usually very stoic he always is
just playing these calm games he draws
quite regularly so I'm wondering for
Wesley this opponent notbe ofar if he's
particularly uncomfortable for him it
does feel that way just judging by the
first two games uh but then again if
Wesley is able to go back to basics is
able to strip away all of the kind of
tactics the energy out of Abdus Toro's
position I still I still do think he
should be the favorite but uh these
players they're going to have to adapt
their strategies on the Fly I think game
by game we'll see players start to kind
of switch up their openings switch up
their uh kind of the way they've been
playing the games and here we see Carana
back at the board I can't wait till this
third round yeah Magnus Carlson loves a
challenge and a challenge it is uh the
best version of Fabiano Karana has shown
up to this semi-finals match Magnus will
he start with one E4 an opening that did
get him into trouble in game one the
players are ready to go are we expecting
Magnus to switch it up on move one maybe
the first game didn't go according to
plan for the world number one but he is
quite a loyal
of 1 E4 and I think the big question is
whether we'll see the Archangel again
this variation of the Spanish it looks
that way Magnus Carlson repeating his
opening from the first game and Bishop
where is he goes for it he sticks to the
tri and tested his scores the archangels
which worked to perfection in game one
it was nothing about the opening that
got Fabiano into trouble but let's
remember Magnus did get an advantage at
some point and here he pushes the pawn
up two squares rather than one so there
is a change in this opening from Magnus
Carlson and FAO quickly darts his Bishop
out to G4 pinning that Knight to the
queen we have totally different
territory here in the third game of the
match do you think Magnus in the break
he instructed his second Peter hin
Nelson to go watch all 43 hours of
fabiana's Chess of ball course you know
on fast forward and maybe at Double
speed just to figure out what what to do
against this opening honestly not a bad
idea of course we're exaggerating a bit
but to look at specific lines see what
Fabiano himself recommends uh maybe
Fabiano wasn't completely honest with
all of us maybe he kept some Novelties
to himself but this is something that
you should do if you're a chess player
at this stage uh at this level where
Anish giri Fabiano whoever it is
releasing these video courses you can
actually gain insights into the
repertoire yeah and meanwhile we see uh
both sides Castle it's pretty much the
end of the opening stage now but the top
players they know all the plans in the
ensuing middle game Magnus just playing
a really slow uh kind of setup here with
white not overly ambitious I think he
just wants to play himself into form
frustrated of course with the first two
games and uh still pressure on Fabiano
to fully equalizes black to either
clarify the center break out in the
center or to just activate the rest of
his pieces uh but I'm excited this is
shaping up to be a really tense middle
game and Fabiano has shown a tendency
just to slide his Rook on over when they
Pawn tension like this but five he's
thinking right now so maybe he is
successfully taken out of all of his
preparations now he's on his own and
it's a good idea to slow down once
you've made these moves you pushed the
pawn to B5 your Bishop has come out to
G4 now there are these little uh little
moves right do you start with the knight
jump to A5 do you side side step with
the Rook to the B file at the right
moment you want to break open on the
queen side with the B Pawn so it's
really a good moment that Fabby has
slowed down and it will decide how this
middle game progresses depending on uh
fav's approach over the next few moves
uh Magnus looking relaxed let's see if
Wesley is looking relaxed as they're
about to start there game three and that
classic not a back that's there yeah I
don't think anyone pulls it off in
current world chest just like abdor ofan
and the deaths over first move on the
board again Pawn to E4 it looks like
we're very much headed towards Kings
Pawn territory in all of these
semi-finals today and it is another
Spanish opening yes it is White's Bishop
landing on B5 putting some pressure on
Black's Knight will we see copycat with
the other game previously uh no
Archangel from abor he prefers to
develop his Bishop just one square there
we go more classical territory here very
interesting how both players nbec and
Fabby have stuck to the opening that
they chose for game one the thing is
they lost those games so sometimes
were're results oriented but the play
was good from both of them it was not
their opening fault so it's smart of
both of them to stick to this opening
that did them well in terms of
equalizing and for nybeck in particular
I think he needs to stay solid you don't
want to play overly risky stuff in the
opening against Wesley so he punishes so
many players he started with six match
wins in a row but now that I think about
it Wesley's most recent match before
this one was a loss to Fabiano Carana
then he just lost his last game to nbec
kataro so if we cut the tournament past
round six when he started with the
Perfect Score there's something when you
are leading the tournament that you
start getting not
but you don't need to win as much he was
already through the semifinals do you
think that can affect him definitely it
feels like yesterday was a bit of a rest
day for Wesley so yes he lost to Fabiano
early on feels like distant uh kind of
Forgotten history at this point but
Wesley it feels the wind has been taken
out of his sales um yes he was on that
hot streak and normally when you're on a
hot streak you don't want kind of an
easier game or a non-important game you
want to keep pushing keep pushing
challenge yourself uh for more and more
and yeah Wesley he hasn't replicated the
form he showed in the first few days uh
just in the last 24 hours but uh this
one in the meantime still a very kind of
typical position for this opening he's
traded off a set of Pawns on the queen
side and white is getting ready to build
a big Pawn Center um early days of
course uh there we saw the air quality
shout out to air things I wanted to say
great share quality as well in the uh
playing Hall Magnus today with great
hair quality and uh I'm hoping for more
of the same notbe with great stare
quality so did yeah we keep doing this
forever but Wesley something's going on
what is he bothered by right here he's
shaking his head a little bit I know he
doesn't like to look at his opponents or
sometimes he covers his eyes just so he
can focus on the moves but it does seem
like something's bothering him he looks
very uncomfortable and I can understand
the uh head and hands to just avoid any
of those noack stairs but it actually
feels like something about the position
Wesley is not pleased he gets up and
leaves maybe he knew we were talking
about him and that's always
uncomfortable when someone's talking
about you but you can't hear but I'm
actually wonder if he's still thinking
about the previous game so far early
stages in this one maybe he's just
thirsty grabs the water but I don't know
something about Wesley seems different
than those first six round robin matches
yeah this body language is sometimes uh
it occurs when the top players kind of
mix up their move order maybe he wanted
to play a different variation this last
move uh it's very provocative and uh
maybe he had another idea in mind but
sometimes the hand kind of Acts before
the brain clicks into gear you play a
move and then you realize oh wait I
didn't want to play that one makes you
smile and in general Wesley's looked in
a great mood this whole tournament so I
don't think uh it will distract him too
much of course he'll be able to refocus
and uh on the bright side he has
surprised NC here really hard to do that
he's so well well prepared the young USC
grandmas and pawn to D4 I should mention
there's also a big threat in the
position if White's Pawn steps up to D5
now Black's Knight on C6 is trapped so
for the first time in this game there's
drama there's tension and a player
sitting in for a deep think at this
stage can mean a couple things either
they're out of their preparation or as
you said perhaps Wesley did something
that he moved a little quickly he didn't
start by pushing his Pawn to H3 to stop
any pins on the diagonal and we see nck
takes this Pawn on D4 and now he can
slide his light sore Bishop out to pin
the Knight to the queen and start asking
white some important questions and maybe
that was uh exactly the questions that
uh Wesley was preempting and he's not
sure how he is going to respond to them
the centers opened up Black's got a nice
developing move with the bishop we will
see how this one progresses let's jump
back to Magnus playing with the white
pieces similar structure similar setup
right now but Magnus hasn't yet made the
move d4 which for now is under control
it's really all about who gets the
central breaks in in these openings does
black get a successful D5 in is white
able to get a good D4 in with D4 under
control for black the break under
control what are the players fighting
for in this one wow fighting for squares
and fighting for threats apparently
kowana look at the black queen and black
Dart Square Bishop look at how they
pierced down this diagonal towards the
white king there was a big threat on F2
uh Tanya you mentioned white breaking
out in the center that looks like a
distant dream right now I don't think
it's ever going to become a reality uh
Fabiano yet again showing the Archangel
is in great shape there's only one open
file a pair of Rooks have been traded
along that file black controls it white
is not able to strike in the center
white position is perfectly healthy I
don't want to act like Fabiano has an
advantage but no difficulties whatsoever
so I think Advantage Fabiano from the
perspective this is a game with the
black pieces he just won with white in
game two this looks really stable hard
position to imagine black going wrong
but then we're talking about Magnus
Carlson here he's going to keep the game
going for a while but Fab is doing
everything right thus far wow and look
at that Knight it's rerouted itself to
the king side eyeing that F4 square a
white knight meanwhile also trying to
get to the light squares and uh while
these players fight it out the position
strategic strategic battle we will head
down to Toronto where we are being
joined by Levy and he's with Maxim VRA
who's hanging out in Toronto right now
to break the position down for us what's
up
Maxim know that she asked you what's up
Maxim yeah all good I mean you know
there's nothing to be proud of from uh
the past few days so you know I
definitely didn't deserve to to to be at
this place of one of these four players
so my place is here for today at least
well we really appreciate it and um
obviously before we get into the
specifics of this Fabiano Magnus matchup
we just saw what happened there in the
first game we were all sitting watching
and just ooing and a at the screen at
watching this queen versus Rook end game
so my question to you is
how do you bounce back from that
psychologically what does it say to win
that second game with white for
Fabiano well first of all I think it's a
big relief for Fabiano to have won uh we
saw him briefly after he lost and of
course he was very pissed but I think it
helps that it's not a classical game
where you have one day to Pond to ponder
over uh your thoughts here you just like
okay in 5 minutes I have to go again mhm
you know just reset mentally sometimes
it's easier said than done but like I
think it helps also maybe at least it
would have help me that it's not a game
where was particularly dominant he was
on the defensive throughout the game he
got this unexpected
chance um and then yeah he should
definitely have won but let's say draw
could have been some sort of fair result
like it's maybe a 0.75 Point difference
not a straight one point difference and
then he was waiting the next game game
he could put pressure definitely played
it safe in the opening so to not to at
least cut the bleeding and then when he
got his chance uh he took it then it
would have been lethal if he actually
didn't hadn't converted his Advantage
cuz at some point it looked like it was
uh going on the right on the wrong track
right and uh this could have been uh
really decisive noise come back and uh
yeah match is one1 again all of fresh no
obviously and and now it's basically
back to the format that it was before
the semi-final now it's just the best of
two except it's two sets yeah yeah yeah
right of course of course yes um what
are we thinking about this position that
we have on the screen it's very
reasonable position like uh I mean Fabi
is going to get his Knight to F4 so
that's a good thing I don't think you
can go G3 although I would consider it
like Bishop takes um then Knight three
back to H2 you attack this Knight on H5
it's upon second
sacrifice but the problem is then Bishop
F2 is always I mean the pawn on F2 is
always hanging so I don't think it can
work right now so probably you have to
let the Knight come to F4 you're an E4
player your entire career basically you
don't play E4 E5 with black you're a
sicilian player so you are you used to
seeing more of these types of positions
when you're on the white side or do you
try to avoid s like do you not like that
Fabiano has these Queen and Bishop
pointed at f2 and control of the a file
I've had manyel in my life uh even the
couple with black but like not really in
classical but um yeah it's very
reasonable position for both sides I
think um this of course Queen and Bishop
uh can hurt the pawn on F2 quite badly
but worst case you can drop the bishop
back to E3 just I feel like Magnus has
lost Ops to get an opening Advantage
here so he'll be maybe trying to outplay
one way or another but it's not going to
be easy like like this position is very
comfortable to play for for Fabiano last
question before we go over to our other
semi-final I am curious about the fact
that Magnus repeated the opening for a
second time right he didn't exactly
repeat it cuz he went A4 yeah he went A4
but just to you know just to play into
the arhangel period just to play E4 I
mean he could have played D4 C4 Knight
F3 so is he just kind of poking and
seeing at different things that Fabiano
wants to do with black I I don't think
it's a bad idea in general uh I just
think it was taken by by move Bishop G4
I think he he recked briefly um his
lines after A4 and didn't expect what
happened next and but yeah I mean
Fabiano is obviously always extremely
well prepared and you know but Magnus as
well so like he's not he doesn't have to
back out from from a theoretical fight
like he played against me in numerous
night ofs and Grandfield so right uh I
think we are going to bring up our our
second semi-final matchup here um and
and here we have it on the screen this
was also a was also a Ru Lopez but it is
very different yeah and I thought it had
gone well for for Wesley actually um but
it's not that obvious
like he has control over the
center um so this Knight on e4 you have
to make a decision now it's been
attacked probably you want to sacrifice
a pawn maybe play C5 yeah give up the
pawn and up to to um to enter some uh
equal end game at the end like to I mean
Pon but you you still get equalities
like I would consider either Rook d8 or
C5 probably C5 right away I don't see
why not right because also it's
important just for viewers Pawn on I was
going to say like Queen on E2 is
attacking the pawn on B5 I don't even
see that okay but C5 is is is well timed
because because Queen B5 maybe even C4
and Rook B8 yeah you can trap the queen
but C5 somehow
defends both okay and there it is we see
it on the screen so it defends tactics
on e4 and B5 at the same time which is
very unintuitive for most audience
members I think yeah yeah um yeah I
think it should end in a draw like you
take everything and then hook
G8 I think you know also like first game
looked like it was going to end in a
draw sure yeah of course and and then I
think not back over pressed and then was
uh what exactly what exactly is the idea
it's like if white takes on e4 with
Knight right now black is going to take
back white will it trade everything you
take you trade everything you play Rook
d8 and you have and you have ideas of
Knight D3 as well so like because Knight
D3 right away maybe you get Bishop E3
and then D5 is always in here MH so I
think he want hook d8 and if DC even
Bishop C5 CU then you're also Hing at f2
when you play Knight
D3 okay it could be a bit uncomfortable
but I think it it ends in a draw in the
end so nck is looking to offset
potentially a one Pawn Advantage for
Wesley with some active piece play
likely will win the pawn back and I mean
we did see in that first game there was
a long long long end game and even if he
doesn't like it's going to be an equal
sh game like and we see that dc5 is even
on the board so looking like this one
will head to a draw we still pretty
unclear situation in the Magnus fby game
but uh thank you Maxim for joining maybe
we'll get another one with you and we're
going to send it back to Oslo yes Tanya
and the guys take it away do your job
guys thanks lovey well that was a good
break Maxim so thanks for taking over
and do uh jump in guys whenever you've
got a moment to break this action down
for us that we're witnessing and Maxim's
take on this is that this is perhaps
going to fiz fizzle out into a draw
would you agree with that uh I'm never
going to doubt Maxim in a Spanish
opening in a Ry Lopez he's been playing
it as long as I've known him since we
were kids uh so I trust his judgment uh
Maxim there's a chair here if you want
to fly over and give us more of a break
and uh yeah meanwhile it just feels like
everything's being traded off but
there's a threat on the board right the
pawn on F2 is hanging the bishop the
black bishop and the Knight is lined up
against it is it time for Wesley to
start trading off those pieces in the
center yeah just like the first game
between them there's a white Pawn on the
black side of the board in the center
and there's about to be a black Pawn on
the white side of the position but all
these trades should liquidate far enough
where there won't be many pieces
remaining so let's say you take this
Knight on e4 let's say black takes the
bishop and you keep taking and we get
this whole uh thing down where all the
pieces come off on the E4 square at this
stage the F2 Pawn is under attack with a
knight D3 Fork at the end so I can take
this pawn and once we oh I blundered
apparently cuz maybe my knight gets
trapped down here yeah this looks
natural Robert just to point out your
idea this looks like a very logical
double attack but perhaps the Knight is
running out of squares as you mentioned
uh a bit stuck on C1 uh but maybe just
the same idea different move order uh
would be uh the more accurate way of
doing it we're actually headed in this
direction and uh I do think maybe in
this position night D3 first and just
same idea you'll win either uh the
bishop the pawn or this pawn and most
likely this should fizzle out towards a
draw So currently n back down a pawn uh
in the line that we're seeing but it
looks like the pawn will be recaptured
with the ease again with which nbec has
managed to equalize with the black
pieces is that advantage nbec in the
match well if he can draw this game then
certainly and I you know may while I
overlook certain tactics here you know
will not and at this moment he's not
actually forced to take this bishop on
e4 I'm wondering if Wesley's a little
bit more ambitious than just let's
settle for a draw trade off the pieces
because his dark squore Bishop hasn't
moved but as soon as it does right now
his Rook on E1 actually protects the
light squore bishop and let's not forget
that black has these weak Pawns in the
position the queen on E2 is aiming on
over at the pawn on B5 the D5 Pawn is
isolated so I do think that Wesley is
considering just developing his Bishop
one square in the diagonal hitting that
Black Knight on B4 and I do believe that
Wesley has a better position yeah we'll
learn a lot about his mindset just in
this next move if he does trade
everything off heads straight for that
drawish end game then it means Wesley
isn't quite feeling his best or maybe
he's believing in his chances if we do
get into a ultimate Armageddon but uh if
he keeps the tension it means he's
feeling ambitious feeling sharp feeling
confident um I like your idea Robert uh
I must admit I thought Bishop takes
Bishop was pretty much forced but you
can just defend your Bishop on B1 move
the other Bishop out the way and yeah
the game goes on I saw Wesley shake his
head though he quickly did a little one
of these so I he could be seeing that no
matter what he does it should be equal
but I feel like he should try this is
his game with the white pieces he should
play on wow okay so this is a moment and
we see he does decide to play on so
developing the bishop defending the
other Bishop with the Rook we'll see how
nbec reacts to this but let's uh jump in
and see how Fabby has been reacting out
of the opening now on this one Maxim
said that it's time for Magnus to give
up all hope of getting an opening
Advantage uh and we can see why right
like the bishop and the queen lined up
attacking that D4 Pawn also x-raying the
F2 Pawn the F line is open blacks
managed to get the knights on the center
of the board and now no doubled pawns as
well white needs to be careful about the
Pawns in the center it does appear as if
Fabby once again proving the AR Angels
hold strong look at the clock Fabby is
up nearly 2 minutes on time the Evo in
his favor he's the one pressuring not
just the center but also the king side
that Bishop on G5 for white it's kind of
in no man's land out there and that
Knight on H2 Knight on F3 those are
Superfluous Knights the late Jeremy
Silman wrote about these in his books
they're fighting for the same squares I
think black can get very active right
now Queen to A4 comes to mind for me
because Bishop A5 becomes a threat and
then white can't successfully play the
move Pawn to B4 I just feel like White's
pieces are Tangled At This stage of the
game easier for five to play and even
though he's in a think right now he's
aheading the clock yeah this looks
really strong White's position could
fall apart instantly partly due to the
threat of Bishop A5 partly due to
pressure on the D5 Pawn he actually
forces the issue he played H6 uh forcing
white to take on the F4 Square so now
there's an imbalance still very healthy
and uh White has to be really really
careful I mean this diagonal it just
looks like if black gets time to play a
move like E5 in the near future there
could be uh just tremendous tactics and
uh yeah Magnus Carson how does he
improve his Knights that's the big
question one of them uh Robert as uh
mentioned that Superfluous you need to
activate one of them you need to get
your king to safety somehow but you
don't really want to take a time out to
slide your king into the corner Pawn to
H4 he's getting ready to play G3 next
move to boot this Knight out of his half
of the board yeah and you asked the
question how do you actually get rid of
these super fluous Knights and I think
this move H4 also allows White's Knight
to jump forward uh to the square G4
which earlier would not have been
possible with that pawn on H3 to just
point out a small tactic that stopped
this from happening black can actually
take Knight takes pawn and then the F3
Knight is on pre so the move H4 aiming
at tying down Black's King side but also
freeze up that Knight on H2 that's
really not doing anything and I like
this move that you earlier B up Robert
Queen to A4 such an active move not only
eyeing again the D4 Pawn taking away
some key Quest but Bishop A5 a big
threat on the board not easy for Magnus
to meet he might have to slide his Rook
away from the e file and perhaps he's
doing just enough to hold everything
together but Fabiano he's the one on the
offensive he really is playing a better
match than Magnus Carlson today at this
point I don't think there's any doubt
he's not facing any issues at the
opening with black he outplayed him with
white I think Magnus is feeling
Fabiano's might right now and this is
scary when Fabiano has had the 2023 that
he has winning these classical events
he's over 2800 again the only player not
named Magnus Carlson to be over 2800 fet
and now we see fiveon improving his
rapid Blitz game as well he won the St
Louis rapid and Blitz before this David
I'm liking Fabiano's chances in this
game yeah he's in the flow Fabiano not
just in this game in the year in general
it feels like he's got half an eye on
ding Len's Crown right now Fabiano he's
just been improving week on week uh
month on month especially with his speed
chess and big threats all angles of the
board it's just one glance here uh our
eyes do not deceive us the black Queen's
so active the Black Knight so active
Black's Bishop perfectly poised compared
to all of their counterparts clearly
Superior here look at the clock as well
double the amount of time as Magnus
Carson Fabby in charge bossing it can he
convert it though that's the uh big
question Magnus needs to pull the break
and just try to hold this one try to
survive this game it's not going to be
easy for White and the clock keeps
sticking away from Magnus as he now goes
under three minutes a threat on the
board he either needs to move the Rook
or S side step with the queen I don't
believe the pawn push to B4 is something
that you really want to make it's so
committ ties down that pawn your queen
to defending that which means that for
Magnus it's not a pleasant choice to
make the most the most natural move to
me in this position would be to place
the Rook on the Open Sea line yeah that
is the most natural move but one of the
ideas that we've been talking about for
black is pushing the E Pawn forward
opening unleashing that Bishop on B6 it
looks scary so look at Magnus he's
offering a queen trade he's trying to
establish an endgame where the Queens
are off the board there won't be an
attack but black should still be better
all of White's pieces are on his first
four ranks black has this Knight on F4
The Rook situated on f8 that can slide
on over to the a file I really like this
position for Fabby there's no risk here
and Magnus looking away from the board
we see on the camera I think he's just
uh disgusted by his position right now
he knows that he's on the back foot yes
he should still be okayish with wh but
he's the one reacting and uh yeah he
wants to be dictating the pace this is
not going according to plan for the
Norwegian right now Queen to D1 to trade
or not to trade Queen's on the board off
the board what do we think I trade him I
think that black is still better trade
Queens bring your Rook to the open file
there's no risk whatsoever in Black's
position you play with a free hand yeah
that seems uh really something that Faby
would enjoy it feels like a position for
two results get the Queens off the boat
control the only open a line get your
Rook down the boat to attack white
spawns everything looks really good and
you said things are not going well for
Magnus in this game things haven't been
going well from the start of the day for
Magnus including the game that he did
win which was quite a miraculous save by
him Fabby for the second time for the
third time during the match with a
better position but again in the end
game will it be enough or is he going to
get more ambitious trying to keep the
Queens on the board he's thinking for a
little too long when you're playing
against Magnus you have to put the
pressure on the clock as
well okay he allows the quein to come
off but he's saying only on my terms and
he plays this move E5 that we mentioned
earlier it's a very committal move
because longterm for black structure if
you don't don't land any tactics after a
trade you might be left with some weak
pawns but he is cracking open that
diagonal for the black Bishop very
ambitious move from Fabiano I was going
to say it is up his alley to kind of
maximize uh the advantage to try and
keep Queens on potentially uh to try to
play for tricks but E5 here I'm trying
to do some quick calculation he has to
be really careful Magnus Carlson to hold
things together but now Fabby also needs
to be careful in some ways because if
there is a pawn swap on E5 black is
Saddle with his isolated Pawn so
long-term that can become a weakness is
I all about minimizing risk in the
position I thought trading the Queens
was good but you see that E5 pawn it
doesn't have its best friend in the
Jason file it's isolated eventually that
Knight on H2 can jump into G4 that E5
Pawn could be a goner so I'm looking at
this position now with a double-edged
lens where I think Magnus will have some
chances not just to sty the offensive
threats of Fabiano Carana but if Fabiano
goes wrong Magnus can actually play for
a win down the line a very committal
decision by Fabby without trading the
Queens he goes for the central break I'm
slightly surprised with this one but at
least it makes Magnus going into a think
and burn some critical critical seconds
on the clock and eventually he does fix
that weakness on E5 and this was Fab's
idea something that nobody in the studio
expected Fabiana Carana with a pawn
sacrifice wow this is dramatic stuff
right now nobody spotted that as you
mentioned Tanya now he keeps the Queens
on but he's broken this diagonal open
watch out for sorts of Knight jumps
later into D3 W Magnus Carson he's
holding things together by a thread his
Knight defends his Rook but this
diagonal it feels like there's some
tactics Brewing look at the clock as
well Magnus in big big trouble Fabby
such ambitious play totally different
position from dingly Ren against Yang
neami but it's that moment where the Eva
bar doesn't change and yet it's a sudden
wrench in the plans of you weren't
expecting this let me go for more I
think now Faby can just take this Pawn
E5 he's keeping the Queens on the board
my fear for black was with the Queens
off the board perhaps that E5 Pawn can
be targeted but not here not when black
has all the Firepower aimed at the white
king a really testing move decision from
five caran let's see if Magnus can
handle it this is fighting Fighting
Chess from Fabby objectively maybe it
wasn't the strongest option but he just
plays the most challenging line for f
for Magnus to actually handle and now
with being under a minute the Queens
stay on the board there is pressure on
that Rook on E1 I do like magnus's
defensive move play faing the queen on
the second rank defending not only the
B2 Pawn the F2 Pawn also the central E
Pawn on the board but it looks like
Fabby he's very ambitious about his
chances right now yeah and rightly so he
also has half an eye on the clock
Fabiano Carana three and a half minutes
against under 1 minute so it's the right
thing to do to randomize it to play
dynamically he captures a Pawn on that
left Board of our screen right now and
Magnus moves the white Rook away so
still in the balance object objectively
but black having all the fun uh we see
the other board though Robert uh right
now between wesle so and Abdu satarov on
the right of our screens what do you
make of that one we appreciate those
players they're so phenomenal but right
now there's little separating them on
the right hand side of our screen I
think all attention is on the left hand
side where there's much more tension and
for Fabiano who still has over three
minutes on the clock his time management
has probably been his best attribute
today and look at this move Knight back
to step forward into D4 he is trying to
crack down on White's defense if you
could start trading some pieces in front
of that white king that F2 Pawn in
particular is especially vulnerable that
Rook on f8 can slide up to F4 that
Knight can go to D4 or to C5 there are
so many questions that Magnus needs to
answer he's got 35 seconds left this is
exceptional combination of being
strategic with the night maneuver along
with the sacrifice that we just saw an
ambitious player with the queen move
he's just combining all these different
aspects of the game and playing it to
Perfection once again in driver's seat
Fabiano Karana a queen trade on offer
this time does he go for it or perhaps
step forward with the queen to B3 trying
to maintain the tension the E4 Pawn is
also hanging there's a bunch of options
here for Fabiano I think he'll be really
reluctant to go into any end game so I'm
expecting the black queen to move away
and uh I'm not sure where exactly but
just keep the tension keep the pressure
on Magnus Carson right now the
evaluation bar might say it's kind of
only slightly in Black's favor but I
think in Practical terms big big
Advantage for Fabiano and I think
Fabiano's okay with a lack of tension if
it means he's stealing pawns I like
Queen takes Pawn in the center and he
does as well I mentioned earlier he was
snacking on Pawns in game two snack on
one in game three he can just move his
Queen back somewhere that Knight on F3
cannot move the bishop on B6 the dark
score Bishop on the left hand side of
your screen that left board that Bishop
is aiming towards the white king that
Rook next to the black king is aiming
towards the white king So Magnus took
with his Rook it was the only option now
I think the Black Knight it's the last
piece to join the party Move That Knight
he goes in it's coming to D3 this looks
really dangerous yeah Magnus he's really
walking a tight rope right now he needs
to find super accurate moves just to
stay alive 15 seconds for the world
number one Fabiano creating threats
Knight to D3 that black knight jumping
in further is a monster threat how to
defend against it and there we see
Magnus drops his Knight back a big
blunder according to the evaluation bar
can black just continue the journey with
his Knight can you continue the journey
or is there a killer blow on the spot
are there sacrifices does Knight take
spawn with the idea of Queen sliding
over to the king side on the board if
the king takes the Knight Queen G4 is
that the killer move that's game over
that there's nothing that Magnus can do
his King side isn't shambles he drops
not just a pawn but his defensive
resources and The Rook is going to slide
in here for black as well unless his
King becomes vulnerable Fabiano he's
just in charge he could take that Knight
with his Queen even he's up a pawn at
minimum game over simply no way Magnus
Carson survives this one we saw him lean
back in shock as Knight takes G2 that
Knight sacrifice appeared on the board
and it wasn't n a surprise it felt like
something was brewing for a long time
the evaluation B was stubbornly stuck in
the middle but we were saying it
momentum black momentum black he takes
with a queen no risk attached to this at
all he's a pawn up and he's about to
cash in on the second Pawn on F2 three
pawns he's going to take on F2 a queen
trade will happen then his Rook will
take the pawn on B2 as well it's going
to be three extra pawns for Fabiana
Carana in an end game completely
hopelessly lost for Magnus and he goes
for it uh Magnus is going to need more
of the miracle that he survived in game
one I don't see that happening Fabiano
Carana really bringing his aame today
Magnus Carlson is about to go down in
game three going to go down in flames
look at him he looks away yeah he's
devastated Magnus with 14 seconds kowana
his clock handling has been exemplary as
well this game he's just been dominant
from start to finish and magnus's only
hope now is to somehow leap forward with
a white knight combine it with White's
rook and create some counterplay but
looks like a dream even if black just
ignores everything pushes pawns it feels
feels like black is winning uh just on
default here there's a red carpet rolled
out in front of that B Pawn just push
your past pawn and on the right hand
side of our screens we are seeing some
trades on offer there whoa wait what in
the right hand side it looks like Wesley
so just gave up the pawn next to his
King with check and the Evo bar didn't
react so some craziness happening on the
right hand side we'll get to it but all
attention is on Fabiano Carana just a
couple moments away from beating the
world number one Magnus Carlson look at
Magnus on the camera just frustrated
there just throwing his pieces down the
pieces he was fiddling with he looks
ready to get out of here he looks ready
to resign wh King marching forward but
what's the plan there simply is none
Black's B Pawn is going to soon March
down that board he's not giving any
chance to Magnus to jump in with that
Knight to F5 First kicks The Rook out of
the seventh Rank and now the B Pawn will
arrive on B4 he Fabby playing extremely
solid giving absolutely no hope here and
he pins that Knight oh that's just nasty
because the Knight can't move anymore
Rook trade is completely losing he could
push that B Pawn at long last yeah he's
going to do it and a bit of a mirror
image I just want to say on the boards
right now black in both of the games has
a dark squared Bishop versus a knight
black both games has a Pawn on B5 a pass
Pawn on B5 it's as if the players are
kind of watching each other right now
Magnus coming in with the white King The
Other Board getting dramatic as well
very dramatic there was an E6 that was
played and it was completely ignored
that is high nerves by nbec what an
amazing decision there looks like Pawn
on the right hand side on the right
board Pawn takes Pawn his check but that
Queen on A2 it can actually capture that
pawn so you're not losing the house what
a fine by nbec abusar on the left hand
side of our screen we just saw Fabby he
brings his King to G8 if the white king
goes up diagonally it looks like it's in
a check main it but the black world can
kick the king away so that King Will
Survive and unfortunately for Magnus it
doesn't look like he will survive as the
B Pawn at long last is going up the
board and now the bishop dominates the
White Knight as well and Magnus will not
have enough pieces to fight against the
pawn the bishop defends the B2 Pawn next
and The Rook will go down to C1 to wrap
it up just don't get checkmated the
black king is out on its own the good
thing for well we see resignation that
one is over Fabiano in control from
start to finish Fabiano Carana takes the
second win and the lead in the match
with that backto back performance Magnus
Carlson has to win on demand a must-win
fourth game and we see it on Magnus he
is feeling the pressure he's on the
ropes and Fabiano is a punching Magnus
Carlson is lucky to even have one point
in this match Fabiano's completely
outplayed the world number one and
Fabiano has deserved his 2-1 lead and we
could see another 2-1 lead in this
matchup here because nbec abatar he
escaped the worst he's actually up upon
that pass B Pawn that Fabiano won with
not's trying to do the same but this
Pawn might drop there we go the White
Knight Retreats it's such a mirror image
it's also rook and Knight versus rook
and Bishop also a dark Square Bishop
also a B Pawn but that has disappeared
it's been traded for White's H Pawn and
now two versus one in terms of Pawns on
the king side alone Knights are short-
range pieces they really Thrive against
Bishops when it's just one flank they
have to worry about this should be now a
draw looks like Wesley so escaped what
was a really dangerous end game there
Wesley can be feeling very relieved with
that he's under 30 seconds right now but
it shouldn't be too tough to hold it
given the clock situation as well with
such little material on the board uh and
I think what most black can hope for is
a Bishop was his rook in this oh but
that would be dangerous if you get that
we saw Magnus Carlson beat ala fuja just
yesterday in that kind of end game but
the good news for Wesley is pawns are
all on the same side of the board as
David said Knights being short-range
pieces they are difficult pieces to use
to track down pawns on the other flank
so I think that Wesley's got everything
under control if the Rooks get traded
it's still going to be a draw there are
many ways for him to hold this half
Point yeah Bishop for Knight trade draw
Rook trade draw everything here uh
leading to a hold a ball position he
moves his Bishop C1 keeping the game
alive nybeck he got to be careful not to
push too hard like he did in an earlier
game but uh yeah it was just the
disappearance of that black bwn that we
saw as we jumped in uh that secured this
healthy save for Wesley so I say safe uh
presumptuously but it looks like uh
nothing too much to worry about will
nobec trade the bishop for Knight maybe
the best bet right now uh the only way
to keep the game going he oh he's going
to push some pawns he's so ambitious the
youngster he's got this Champions
mentality of just fighting it out till
the very very end keeping as many pieces
on the board as much tension on the
board and making Wesley earn that half
point he's making Wesley sweat he is and
he's just challenging Wesley move after
move Wesley is putting up sturdy defense
and for nck I've told the story before
but he was in a game where he was
actually down upon and a draw was
offered and he declined it so when he's
up a pawn there's no way he's just going
to give an easy draw to Wesley so he's
rerouting his Bishop watch out for
Wesley I mean you just can't blunder
anything but all his pieces are defended
and it's always tricky cuz Wesley does
have a knight and it is a nck who's
touching the 10c mark So NC has to be
just a little careful right now yeah you
don't want to walk into any night Forks
luckily the black king and black Rook
are on different color complexes
therefore cannot be forked by a knight
and now the pawns are rolling now the
pawns are pushing um one thing that you
mentioned another uh game in earlier in
the tournament Robert is that the bishop
and Rooks porn the bishop and black H
Pawn uh they do not combine Black's H
Pawn promotes on a light Square
therefore white is able to maybe trade
off Rooks give up the White Knight for
Black's Gort later with a draw but still
a while away from that I'm proud of you
for bringing that up though cuz I always
mention and people get tired of it but
it's true that if the Rooks are off the
board all the night White Knight has to
do a sacrifice up for the G pawn and
here we see nor continuing to press he
wants to push those pawns and Tanya if
we can get that rook and Bishop versus
Rook that does give not back legit
chances and now that Pawn's on G4 maybe
becomes vulnerable that's a big Target
now and Black's Rook is perfectly placed
toh start giving the check and creating
some pressure against that white G4 Pawn
right now you take the Knight luckily
for Wesley it comes in with a check and
the G4 Pawn still hangs he's doing
everything right though Abdu satov he's
putting pressure on White's Knight and
things are collapsing for Wesley so this
is a check o the black H6 porn is up for
grab so he might be holding but suddenly
it's dangerous suddenly you got to be
really really careful what is this end
game magic that nag always manages to
create white king is could be an ating
net if you're not careful I thought that
black king was going to go forward up to
F4 White Knight it's trapped almost and
you get to take the PA with check and
move your Rook with check so you're now
two full pawns ahead is NC abaro Wesley
so shakes his head as the second Pawn
drops nck is winning this position but
can he finish the job I think he will
finish the job what has that white
knight done is committed the cardinal
sin of placing itself on the edge of the
board and it's not coming back blacks
two pawns now connected pass pawns
should win this this game and the black
king should go up into the position he
goes back for a turn but it can go
forward and help deliver a checkm net
against the white king and they're two
pawns there the Knight is far away
Wesley just making move after move on
the increment it looks like right now n
Beck is all under control but just 7
seconds for nck the pawns push forward
bites rook and Knight completely lacking
any coordination in this position and
you can see Wy shaky hands pure
determination from nyb it's just grit
his hard work is ping off one move away
from winning that pawn is about to get
to H2 there two of them black has two of
the pawns though and Wesley resigns n
back Abdul satov also gets the backto
back Victory and takes the lead in his
match against Wesley so the magic of
Toronto comes to a stop for Wesley maybe
that script has flipped the USC Phenom
gets a win we saw a brief smile on his
face but ever the competitor look at
that Steely determination he's is going
to get prepared get set for game four
because he knows Wes is going to give it
his all wow amazing amazing stuff two
players who perhaps at the start of the
day were The Underdogs on the paper of
course extremely strong but who would
bet against Magnus Carlson and Wesley so
and right now it is these two names who
are playing catchup to Fabiano kirana
and nbec Abdu satov and that Magnus
blunder of falling retreating back with
the night it wasn't a one move blunder
it was incremental pressure by fav yeah
incremental pressure we were calling it
we were saying momentum black momentum
black things are turning threats are
appearing and that's when human error
Creeps in that's where the blunders
occur and in the end Magnus did slip up
Wesley sorry not Wesley Fabiano pounced
yeah and tough question to answer but
who's impressed you more right now so
far is it not back or Fabby this is not
just taking the easy way out there's no
way to pick between them they both have
played super well with both colors
they've outlasted their opponents and
they continue to increase the pressure
it's as you said it's not a one move
thing these blunders don't happen at
thin air for them it's just how much
pressure they're applying and their
opponents are not able to keep up they
really are not but they've got one more
rapid game and Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so have to they're in a must-win
situation it's not going to be easy
David two fantastic games excellent
chess played here what stood out to you
I'm just going to pick out Abdu sato's
ice cold moments where he showed no
nerves at all and in the end crashed
through to win against Wesley so Abdu
sattorov actually had to find a really
cool move just to survive earlier in the
game and it was here that he played uh
after Pawn to E6 the ice cold Bishop C5
just moving out the way this E6 move by
Wesley was genius this Pawn is
Untouchable if you take it with the Rook
this would have landed a nasty back rank
Checkmate if you take with a pawn then
White's Queen jumps in with more mating
threats if you take with the queen
meanwhile then Black's Bishop on A7
would have fallen simply moving the
bishop was genius and if Pawn takes Pawn
as happened in the game Black's Queen
now swoops back to save the day and the
pressure on the White Queen meant that
we transitioned into an end game and if
we fast forward just one moment later a
few moves down the line we saw Wesley
eventually crack it was here in The Rook
end game still with a drawn position the
White Knight went in the wrong direction
he first needed to give a check forcing
the black king to make a decision and
then jump with his Knight going for the
hbor instead always remember never put
your Knights on the edge of the board he
went the wrong way Knight C4 and got
kicked to the edge of the board a pawn
dropped and Wesley lost and we keep
calling nir beaar the endgame wizard the
whiz kid but he's showing fine tactical
awareness to be able to sacrifice his
Queen the pawn could be captured three
different ways he doesn't want it he
finds the right solution and he keeps
applying that pressure it is ceaseless
it's really impressive so impressive and
just this Universal style of his he's a
attacking he's aggressive when the
position demands and Flawless endgame
technique sheer Brilliance control of
nerves those Steely stairs this has been
some amazing amazing display of strength
by nbec Abdu satov and Kaa caught up
with the man of the moment the boy of
the
moment momentum just seems to be the
word here in Toronto today ndec taking
another win congratulations yeah thank
you thank you what did you make out of
this
game yeah um
he he prepared um this this line I guess
yeah after A4 B8 is not not a good
reaction but okay I just wanted to you
know play some some rare move um but I
think he got a an advantage there and
after that I kind of played played well
and you know he he had a opportunity
several times to to go to end game game
with Pawn up but um he tried to keep the
pressure but then he messed up and um I
got um opportunity
to to to you know to win the pawn and
after Bishop C5 I guess he could have
played Rook
D5 which I wasn't sure I I think it's
pretty dangerous for black there like I
know Rook D5 Queen A7 I play like Knight
E5 or something yeah it was it was
dangerous but he he didn't see it yeah I
mean yeah I'm quite happy that I managed
to win a you know drawn end game so yeah
it's just going well we've uh talked
about how difficult it is to beat the
solid Wesley so of course but getting
him into some time trouble there uh
playing an incredible end game is that
basically the
secret yeah I mean he's very shaky in
time trouble I
think um so yeah that was um that was
point in this in this game but uh
looking at another match we are doing
exactly same same results though that's
yeah yeah that's that's funny actually
so we're going to have two players in
must-win situations there in game four
for you a draw is enough to win the
first match so what can we expect from
you heading into game four um just I
I'll try you know to play good chess and
yeah we'll see uh congratulations again
good luck in the last one thank you all
right NC up to saturo he's uh on a roll
this youngster back to you guys nag with
quite a hot take there that Wesley saw
is shaky when the clock goes down he's
been fantastic so far is still a little
early to congratulate nbec because the
job is far from over but we can
congratulate our winners of the LOI
contest and these vinyl records are
headed your way so big congratulations
to the winners and the records will be
signed by the winner of the Champions
Chester finals lot of
Celebration uh going on in the Champions
Chester final with some unexpected semi
finals action world number two in the
lead against the world number one the
battle continues in Toronto after this
[Music]
break
are you up for some puzzles James I hate
puzzles we have some puzzles you did
this last year right how' you do last
year yeah I did very poor well I
I right to move 10 seconds yes sir yes
again another one that I've seen but I
don't remember the solution of course
you seen them all of course um
time um I think it's A4 so A4 is
incorrect okay in games you know you
like those come on you got this one but
not sacrificing three points and then
winning you actually are on something
there what you got have a H5 what okay
now I got another 10
seconds I'm going to guess that it is uh
it's A4 Bishop A3 and then I think it's
Knight C5 there n that's it is you got
to reverse it reverse just flip it
around flip it flip everything you close
A4 is in there so the problem is in my
mind is like I'm trying to recall
something rather than
calc like I know I've seen correct
correct this one I might actually fail
cuz like I mean it's probably H5 Tak
yeah M yes and here of course there's a
debate yeah right yeah G6 take yep E6
got them Bishop A3 is forced and this is
like the only moment that will trip me
up oh wait I can I can play Knight C5
take no I'm not what is it is I think
it's uh H5 takes G6 takes E6 Bishop A3
yep and then white looks totally
lost give away two cpon for nothing I
mean on the glance I would guess H5 gh6
E6 then Knight B4 and the pawn queen and
and A4 exactly beautiful beautiful and I
think it might be G6 F E6 Bishop A3
Knight B4 Bishop B4 a he too hot stop
the coock stop he keep going that's it
that's it you got it right
he E6 Bishop A3 let's go Dennis okay
Bishop takes one more let's go let's go
ah let's go take H H yeah GH G6 yep
takes FG
mhm yeah E6
okay Bishop a three yeah only me yeah
like before fish FES got them let's
go um wait do I have Knight B4 take A4
that's it there we go dub come on I I
don't know what it is the problem I need
a fresh on so that my mind is not
actually trying to remember cuz then I
spend like 5 Seconds trying to remember
fresh ones guys we need fresh ones forar
he's seen them all guys he's seen them
all no Taro has seen this one recall
test for him so you seen it
before right white the move 10 seconds I
know it you I know okay well go ahead
definitely tell the camera what we got
I'll just say queen F5 check oh yeah
queen of five check in the endend yeah
yeah it's probably my least favorite
type of puzzle yeah correct that is 100%
correct I've seen it but like I I don't
yeah it's so annoying because I don't
want to uh no I would go with Perpetual
if I if I I was playing in BL bullet yes
F yeah not that's not the solution of
course yeah I have yeah bro I'm going to
guess that it's Bishop takes E6 nope
nope okay Knight F6 or something Knight
F6 mayy okay he got the right move but
she got to finish it though bro he got
that chip in his brain bro he got the
chip KN of six exactly right throw the
iPad like what is this no no way no way
no way no no no way no I I I would of
course I would if I would think like one
hour or I you probably find it yes so
Knight of six Bishop takes C3 E3 F3 and
then after King takes G6 oh there's
Queen to F5 and Bishop H7 there it is
total iPad ah queen of five oh heat he
got it let's go fyro let's go baby yes
sir ah queen of five come on there it is
yeah nice very nice very nice that's a
pretty one a pretty one very hard been
very difficult interested to see how I
guess hear would be the best here yeah
or maybe F yeah we have to recall kind
he actually seen it one seen it before
but I have no congratulations on winning
the event in fact I mean
uh I'm I'm just waiting for the check
though waiting for the check but we
warmed you up Wesley you feeling warmed
up baby come on man Flex Le so here
right thank you very much
congratulations on all your success man
we'll see you in the T I hope I can f my
queen like that please we'll love to see
it
[Music]
beautiful metal posters and we've got so
many of the chess themed one just for
you you'll find some fantastic holiday
gifts ideas there so head straight to
display.com chess and there's a very
cool 33% off uh use the code chess and
find the perfect holiday gifts for all
the chess lovers around you and for now
all the action is happening in the city
of Toronto and it is heating up in set
one of the semifinals we've had such
unpredictable results Magnus Carlson and
Wesley so are playing catchup to Fabiano
Carana and nbec Abdu satro so much
dramatic action turnarounds we we've
seen brilliancies we've seen uh and uh
Ka caught up with Fabby after his third
round Victory what a
performance here with Fabiano Carana
that's two in a row you take the lead
here Fabby what was that like yeah I
think it was a very interesting game I
was putting a lot of pressure on him at
some point because he misplayed it with
Bishop G5 for sure it's not a good move
and um yeah and then I got this very
beautiful Knight on F4 Bishop on B6 I
felt like I was pressing for an advant
Vantage um of course once I was already
completely winning I started to make it
messy in time trouble okay probably
never really messy but getting low on
time and and making it a bit too close
but overall very happy with this game
yeah and Magnus even lower on time uh
blundering there in a little bit of um
time trouble so how does it feel to be
able to force him into that time trouble
yeah no I would this was the kind of
game I was hoping for also in the first
game I was hoping for a very
double-edged fight that's why I chose
this opening um because you really get a
tough fight it's very risky for both
sides and I felt like my chances in the
match might lie in in these types of
positions so of course it's still one
tough game to go yeah well uh you're you
talk about the opening here m is with
the white pieces going into something
that you made a chessable course on so
you are obviously very familiar with
that so um are you happy when you see he
comes there with that how do I say
Archangel yeah and well the chest course
is called the dark Archangel and uh yeah
and I made this course but it's not EX
exactly what I recommend what I play
today so it's I played this line against
Alexander Guk in 2021 and I haven't
really played it since but uh it's a
very interesting line very sharp the
computer doesn't like it for black but
it's not so easy if you don't know it
especially too well then it's really
tricky for both sides so having white in
the final game to win the match how
confident are you feeling right now I
think I'm playing better and I'm feeling
confident but of course these must-win
situations they have their own um
yeah they there specific demands and uh
we saw that Magnus was in the situation
against Ali Resa I hope to do better
than Ali resit did good luck in the
final rapping game thank you all right
thanks for joining us Fabiano car he's
in the lead back to you guys he is in
the lead and really interesting insight
there by Fabby how chess is about posing
the biggest practical questions to your
opponent even if it means not making the
best moves David it was quite a game
three by Fabby what what impressed you
the most well it was uh the use of the
opening the way he outmaneuvered Magnus
in the middle game started creating
threats and he used the dark Archangel
and it was dark storm clouds gathering
around the white king Fabiano in this
position set up a really sneaky threat
and Magnus fell into the Trap Black's
Bishop already perfectly poised aiming
at the F2 Square The Rook indirectly
hitting the square as well Black's Queen
on a Super Active post he asked the
Knight to join the action Knight to F4
trying to come into to D3 and this is
where time trouble played its part with
1 hour on his clock Magnus might have
found the saving idea of going on the
attack against Black's King a really
difficult one to find though Knight to
G4 with the idea that the tactic that
happened in the game Knight takes G2
would have allowed a Counterattack
Knight takes H6 and actually here white
has his fair share of the chances but of
course no time to spot that extremely
difficult Magnus instead retreated the
Knight and walked into the real trap
Knight takes G2 bang Fabiano spotted his
chance and the black queen simply coming
across the white king stripped of its
shelter King takes Knight The Black
Queen gave a check won the material back
and a few moves later black emerged with
a three point Advantage fantastic play
by Fabiano yeah unlike in Harry Potter
there is no defense against the dark
Archangel so Fabi Carana continues to
use that to his success Magnus Carlson
he's been struggling at this stage he is
down by a point and during the rest
period he was all by himself not to
steal a Selene Dion song That's a
classic but for Magnus this is New
Territory being down in the match four
games yeah they say it's Lonely at the
Top but right now it's lonely for Magnus
Carlson in the playing Arena and you can
just tell that this is not the narrative
that he was expecting on day one of uh
the semi-finals there is of course the
big game four that's coming up for both
Magnus and Wesley they are in a must-win
uh situation to take it to Armageddon
it's not just the score line both nbec
and Fabby have have just been dominating
today yeah two to one doesn't even
really Encompass what we've seen I think
that they could have already won the
match the two of them first a two and
out points takes the match both Fabby
and Nera could almost be upset that they
don't already have that score yeah wow
and what are we expecting because uh it
means that nbec uh sorry Wesley and
Magnus both start with the black pieces
as well and uh they've got to get the
job done with black otherwise it is set
one over and in just a few seconds we
will have the action as the players are
ready to go Wesley with the black pieces
handshakes how does he create his
chances it's not going to be easy it's
not Wesley style to go all out with
black he normally plays really rock
solid and uh wow Pawn to D6 already that
hints at a pick a pits uh defense and
this is provocative stuff he's giving
white the center he's uh asking AB St to
come for him I'm going down memory lane
a little bit but didn't Wesley didn't he
need a win with the black piece against
Maxim Vash lra just a couple days ago he
played some kind of dodgy opening line
Maxim was much better according the
engines but pressed a little bit too far
and Wesley was able to win that game and
go through in the arm again so Wesley he
has that experience and while Magnus
waits for his game to start he is
looking for inspiration in this one
watching as the action unfolds it's kind
of like a king's Indian defense setup by
Wesley of course wh spawn is still on C2
right now but it's exactly the approach
that we see top level chess players have
whether it's Hikaru or Wesley when their
back is against the wall they often go
for these Fano positions out of the
opening yeah and uh the top players they
borrow ideas from each other that's
maybe why there is this trend to just
kind of occupy the first two or three
ranks allow the opponent to come for you
in these must-win situations with black
and how funny would it be if Magnus
after watching this game repeats
Wesley's opening copies and uh at least
all the pieces are on the board so uh no
forcing line no end games which Abdu
sator thrives in clearly uh Wesley I
think he's at least chosen A wise choice
here in the uh beginning to keep chances
alive for later and happy memories I
just checked I was right he did beat
Maxim VRA from the black side of this
opening it was the opening that was able
to secure him that Victory it was down
the line but he has some good fond
memories of playing this from the black
side that said what nordbeck is doing is
the right thing he's not just playing
passively keeping his pieces on his
first few ranks he in fact brought his
Bop out and is playing a standard way
against the
PS all right this one is going to be a
battle and this one will also be a war
as the players are getting ready
handshakes will be and there we are we
are about to start big question will
Magnus takes similar setups as the one
that we saw with Wesley and I think we
very well could happen on the board
we've seen him employ the hippo where he
develops the pawn on the sixth rank
takes out pieces in a kg way just to
avoid any trades David
you know Magnus best what is going on in
his mind about his opening approach
right now he's just wondering how to
throw Fabiano off how to get out of the
books and uh how to ensure he avoids
preparation it was funny as you were
talking there Tanya I was thinking what
would I do I would probably play B6 and
then Magnus played it he beat me to the
punch but uh this move it's uh very
provocative again doesn't fight directly
for the center but it does allow blacks
light squ Bishop to Fan ketto so um it
depends on how Fabiano approaches this
does he try to punish black for giving
away the center giving away a bunch of
central squares or does he just try to
transpose into better known Waters he
plays F3 one of the most ambitious moves
here robbert trying to build the biggest
Pawn Center possible for white I think
it's a good decision from Fabiano
because it does make your uh diagonals a
little bit loose your dark squares can
be taken advantage of later but you're
playing in a princial manner if your
opponent is playing on the flank you
play in the center so the F3 move to
play E4 next I am interested to know why
Fabian was thinking at this stage I
think he can even take the Knight to try
to bring a black piece in the center
then strike with E4 to gain a Tempo so
far so good for fabbi but I like the
choice from Magnus nonetheless you have
to play something that's offbeat that
does not allow a force draw and while
white is better at least black will have
some long-term chances yeah both sides
get what they want Fabiano will maybe
obtain a small space Advantage with
white very healthy position Magnus gets
a non-orthodox porn structure and active
pieces of his own as he pauses he's
about to recapture the piece and he's
just deciding how to recapture that
piece but I think either way that he
takes it it's the queen that's coming
out yes I was about to say that the ewn
will move forward gaining space over the
center also opening up the path for the
bishop to come into an active Square
perhaps
C4 yeah I like W's position I've got to
say Robert yeah I'm just imagining
Magnus reflecting on Wesley's position
why couldn't I get something like that
and the reason why is that Fabiano
started 1 D4 we didn't really talk about
his first move but he's historically
loved playing e for the Kings Pawn push
on move one he chose D4 to play a more
solid setup and for Magnus looking at
this position where is he going to
counter what pawns is are he going to
throw forward it looks like white just
has the upper hand because of the
dominance in the center I like white
center White's Knight will happily
develop to the square in front of the
king and it just looks like Harmony in
White's pieces meanwhile black still has
to figure out the piece setup that you
want the ideal Square for that Knight
would be for the Black Knight would be
C6 but that comes in the way of magnus's
Bishop right now what do you think about
this surprise that you mentioned earlier
that Fabby starts with 1 D4 this
ambitious approach of going with the F3
opening we're just seeing Fabby not back
down against Madness he's declining
repetitions in positions in complicated
positions he's going all out it's like a
Fabby 2.0 yeah I was actually planning
to save this for later to kind of see
how the uh kind of match results panned
out first but I want to say Magnus and
Wesley are victims of Their Own success
yesterday they pretty much had a day off
yes they had to play some chess but they
were both qualified there was nothing on
the line um so kind of mentally it was
easy to check out and lose momentum
whereas kowana and Abdu satoro they had
to do it the hard way they had to play
high stakes games they had to keep the
focus keep the form keep the momentum
and clearly they're fresher today uh so
far at least and uh Magnus Wesley it
feels like they're taking a bit of time
to get back in the zone and we see this
quite often in sports the team that gets
a buy because of their own success then
they might get off to a sluggish start
because they're well rested but they
don't have that on the field or in this
case on the board experience so Knight
C6 that Knight leaps out it puts
pressure on Fabiano Center even though I
like Fabi Center I also like the
approach from Magnus he is not allowing
a series of Trades he's putting
questions in Fabiano's court and I'm
looking at the clocks as well Magus is a
bit behind but I think Fabiano is going
to have to burn some clock to try to
figure out how to defend the center is
Magnus going to Castle queenside he's
done it before a few times this
tournament just to imbalance it just to
provoke the opponent he has to try
something a bit spicy a bit unorthodox
as we mentioned I think Magnus is going
to go long with this with his King and
ask questions before white has completed
development yeah uh things will
definitely get very interesting in both
these games as Wesley and Magnus have to
create their chances with black to try
to strike back and take the match to
armagen and we've been talking so much
about Fab's form his excellent play and
the kind of fight chest that he's
bringing to the board against the world
number one today and who better to get
further insights Dan a good friend of
Fabby and Levy is in Toronto joined by
grandmas Christian Killa right now let's
head over to
Levy thank you Tanya yes I'm standing
here alongside Christian Cilla
Grandmaster one half of the world famous
soon to be award-winning C squar podcast
chess coach uh director of Chess
programs Christian how are you very good
very good great to be here with you you
are Gotham chess Levy how should I call
you just call me Levy call me leevy or
Gotham you could call me you can you can
call me either or uh how's your
experience been in Toronto what are you
uh what's your role here as you're
traveling with Fabiano oh it's been
amazing uh I live in Columbia Missouri
which is a very small college town so
it's always nice to visit the big cities
I'm having good time uh as of my role
here it's mostly just content creator
I'm Fab's friend I'm not helping him at
all he doesn't um travel with trainers
when he plays rap and Blitz okay
classical it's a completely different
story but rap and Blitz you just simply
don't have the time uh to do uh the
preparation in between games yeah I was
going to ask you speaking of the
preparation big storyline today is that
he had two games on the black side in
the arhangel or the Archangel which we
have now completely changed and stolen
that name which is totally not what that
name is but the Archangel of uh opening
which was his chessable of course uh
what are your impressions of those two
games was it a surprise that Magnus
entered something that Fabby had just
made a course on or was it a statement
he was trying to make cuz it did kind of
backfire well I actually told him uh
last night to play his course um just to
advertise with oh okay I mean's he's
been uh looking at this particular
opening for a very long time he
definitely has the extra experience
compared to everybody else and I I don't
know for sure but I don't think Magnus
checked his course all I can say is by
the course okay by the course and it was
an experiment G right because what if
Fabiano played it twice and went o02
right that's then he would have said
well I didn't have my lines down or you
know Magnus then the sales go down yes
then so I mean but it but it was a good
business decision so you are kind of
here like trainer I mean you know you
got to I'm just giving him a random
advice random advice basically What It
Is Well it paid off in the black games
we have a game up here on the screen uh
most of it is just the two of them
having a staring contest um but uh
must-win situation for Magnus who now
has to win with black your impressions
how's the game looking I actually cannot
see the game very well but from my
understanding obviously Magnus is going
to try to imbalance the position which
makes perfect sense uh and he did that
actually in uh the playoffs at the
beginning of the tournament and he got a
good position with the black pieces he
managed to outplay Fabby in that one so
definitely Magnus has some good
experience wants to win knows what the
result that he's seeking is in this
particular game so it's not going to be
easy why is Fabby not playing Knight to
E2 defending the pawn what else is there
in this position is he thinking maybe
bishop B5 to trade the bishop to
completely neutralize the pressure on
the side Bishop B5 D5 maybe uh but
generally you don't want to play D5 in
this particular position you want to
keep the pawn on D4 maybe go Knight E2
Castle Queen D2 Rook to D1 defend that
Central structure and play it as it is
play for space advantage last thing
before we throw it back to Oslo Fabiano
himself I'm pretty sure has said that in
this exact situation it's a little bit
of a struggle for him sometimes where
he's up one game he has to not like you
you just have to not lose you can play
for a draw you can play for a win and he
he has this exact situation right now so
any thoughts about that especially
against Magnus especially against Magnus
because against Magnus you know that he
plays on a regular basis these type of
very imbalanced positions you know he
has the experience and generally you
know
as the player with the white pieces you
don't experience these type of
situations very often but at the same
time he's a professional player he's one
of the best CH players on the planet he
knows what he needs to do and he will
have to execute yeah Christian thank you
so much for joining us we're going to go
back out there eat some uh hummus eat
some chips we'll throw it back to you
guys in Oslo Tanya take it away always a
pleasure thanks Levy Fabby does uh need
to execute and right now he needs to
execute his next move because he's been
on a a bit of a long think already he's
touching the 4minute mark on a move that
at least in my eyes looks like something
that you need to make in about 2 minutes
time you want to develop that Knight to
the center of the board the D4 Pawn
which is currently attacked by three of
black pieces defended by two of white
species why is he thinking so much right
now what's going on in Fab's head I
think he's calculating a bit too much
sometimes these positions you just have
to play on field whether it's uh just
Knight to E2 as Levy said you can play
that move in seconds deal with the
consequences later uh whether it's the
other moves that Christian there
suggested D5 Bishop B5 at some point you
just have to make a decision no no move
kind of sticks out and uh Magnus will be
able to create some complications either
way but burning four five minutes giving
Magnus four five minutes there as well
to think has resulted in this position
he could have played knight2 first may
maybe made Magnus pause and thought on
magnus's clock um it does feel like the
nerves are creeping in here Robert maybe
it's a position where I think many
people would want to trade the Queens
let me take this Pawn on E5 and trade
the Queens but black dark Square Bishop
is ready to go out and give a check to
the white king I think this would be
very bad for white taking on E5 allowing
Bishop B4 check first when the king
slides out to F2 let's say that E5 Pawn
can be gobbled up at any moment and the
white king is not safe a queen trade
doesn't mean that we're getting a draw
necessarily huge Advantage for black I
would say huge Advantage for black and
uh in the match this could be a decisive
turn so do not get tempted the problem
is if you don't take this Pawn your
other options aren't too appealing for
example stepping forward maybe the most
natural move in the position would allow
a forcing variation the Knight will come
attack the bishop only one safe Square
for it it will have to drop back and uh
black would then break open the white
structure this beautiful Connect Four
structure will be broken down from the
front due to a pin on the defile So
fabiana's Gone a different direction
he's first pinned that black knight this
is what he was thinking about all that
time and the big question is after Pawn
takes Pawn Knight takes can Magnus
profit from the tension on the defile
feels really shaky you cannot take this
Knight though due to a pin on this
diagonal as well it's getting tactical
hence why Fabby spent the time but
Magnus now with a clock advantage and a
really imbalanced position to work with
yeah and Magnus is the player who takes
advantage of even the most minute
details in the position and the fact
that Fabby on move number 11 went into a
4 and a half minute think that shakiness
that hesit see in the opening it's got
to be making Magnus feel more confident
about his uh outcome here I think the
board is just a state of affairs where
Magnus should be feeling good about
having winning chances it's still a
level position we see the eval bar off
to the side but it's not just a
symmetrical structure there's still so
many pieces on the board but I like
Fabiano's decision because this
challenges black setup as well it's not
all fun for Magnus he doesn't get to
initiate the pawn breaks now there's a
lack of clarity and he can slide a rook
to the SE file apply more pressure I
don't think that fabi's in trouble but I
don't like his clock management that's
been his key to success his X Factor has
been leading Magnus on the clock yeah
we've been talking about that Fab's not
only been putting pressure on the board
but also on the clock but this one feels
like a different narrative from the very
start and while we're checking out uh
two of our favorite players in the world
don't forget to check out some of your
favorite TW tweens Tunes as the LOI girl
and chess.com partnership cont continues
and we've got some great music it's the
one that you've been listening to at the
start of the stream at the end of the
stream and hopefully while you're
playing chess as well and you can find
it on your favorite streaming platform
on YouTube on Spotify and on Soundcloud
hopefully the players have also been
listening to some Loi music to get into
the Mind Zone to play some chaotic chess
as well because this position is quite
chaotic that Bishop on B5 played right
now white also wants to try to get the
dond moving forward if Magnus was to
give a check on B4 how is white reacting
yeah it's uh getting sharp it's getting
concrete black can steal White's
castling rights bless you Fabby with
that sneeze there black can give a check
making sure that the white king will not
Castle the white king will be obliged to
step away I'm assuming this Square
because you want to connect Rooks as
quickly as possible and uh the problem
is again after a capture you still
cannot take this Knight due to this pin
so have you helped white this is the big
question that white king looks like it's
out in the open cannot Castle but maybe
accelerates White's development Black's
Bishop on B4 might at some point have to
step back um the move I'm looking at is
actually a capture and then just trying
to get out of the way of this pin maybe
moving the black queen out the way for
example and the reason I like this for
black is because White's King is a bit
of a Target there's a nasty check in the
air you've also opened up the rook and
white here would be forced to trade off
the beautiful Bishop pair and uh in this
position yes white can Castle yes white
can get out the way but there are enough
imbalances for black to work with also
still this pin which could be quite
annoying long term for example if black
moves out the way Bishop coming out to
C5 Fabby would have some serious answers
uh serious questions questions even to
answer uh so sharp stuff right now
Narrow Path maybe for black to kind of
keep the tension keep playing
aggressively but Magnus surely will'll
find a continuation that he likes H
Magnus Carlson uh undoubtedly the most
dangerous player on the planet and gets
even more dangerous when his back is
against the wall and he's managed to
create Chances with black in this one we
will check in with Wesley so who is in
the same matth situation as a Magnus
with the black pieces in a must-win and
to me it looks like he's managed to do
the same that Bishop from F5 is eyeing
the C2 pawn and uh I mean I just want to
ask you can he start getting greedy
already can he pick up that pawn he can
definitely capture that pawn on C2 and
Wesley will go up material but what
nybeck is aiming for is is a potential
attack against the black king there is
this annoying pin from that Queen on E3
towards that Queen on B6 the Knight
can't easily move so Bishop takes Pawn
on C2 Pawn to E6 sure black can sidp all
this with Pawn pushed to F5 but now
you're Bishop on C2 maybe it's a little
bit too deep in enemy territory your
knight on C5 is tender as I mentioned
your king it's a bit more exposed now
you're pushing Pawns in front of it so
even though black is better objectively
speaking the evaluation Bar says that
the players don't know that so it's a
risky Pawn for Wesley to grab
that's the thing Bishop takes Pawn uh
from a human point of view it's either
very good or it's very bad so Wesley's
weighing up those options if he can
survive and remain a pawn up later in
the middle game he's he will go for it
and uh if not if he thinks this bishop
might get trapped he cannot touch that
pawn and white would then get time to
plant a knight on D4 kick the bishop
protect C2 and the game would continue
so this might be a once uh in a game
opportunity to take this Pawn to take a
big risk I think the match situation
kind of suggests you should take this
pawn and go for it ask Abdu satoro to
prove the compensation but it does take
nerves of Steel and it's not normally
Wesley style to be greedy and to kind of
allow an attack he wants to keep more
control so big moment I'm not sure even
if I need the computer evaluation that I
would take this spawn because it looks
so dangerous for black yeah and that
move E6 definitely has nightmares for
Wesley from their second game in which
nag just exploded Black's King side and
it has been stopped Wesley doesn't want
to see another E6 in this match it's a
great practical decision from Wesley
because in order to play Bishop takes T2
you would have to invest so much time
and you look at the clocks n back he's
up about 40 seconds but to be sure to be
absolutely certain that you can get away
with Bishop takes C2 you need to spend a
few more minutes so E6 now you've taken
that out of Whit hands the E5 Pawn is a
long-term weakness cemented in place B2
is loose C2 is loose and I feel like
Wesley made a very very good decision
right here and look at nck he goes
Knight to D4 and the Eva bar still
prefers black some simple moves yeah
some simple moves now trying to make use
of the tension between the queens and
before I could highlight it the Queens
are off the board endgames favor Black
now because of the weakness of White's
E5 pawn and Wesley can he outmaneuver
the endgame mro himself now Abdu
sattorov that's the big question
Advantage black but is it enough he
still needs to be really accurate to
prove that he has any winning chances
whatsoever white KN tring to jump into
C5 still anyone's game and we've been
talking so much about nbec and his end
game play and just how good he is once
the Queens get traded off and that's
usually at least traditionally
conventionally thought of as a trait
that the youngsters it's not their Forte
it's not the kind of positions that they
like to enjoy but naach has been on his
top game once the Queens are off the
board is it reminiscent of how good
Magnus is in end games that is a huge
standard to live up to I think Noir
backck with continued play we'll see if
he can handle it but he is the youngest
World rapid champion in history so when
you're comparing to a historic player
like Magnus Carlson no derck himself has
had an historic achievement so he you
know is amazing endgame player we also
saw during the break those tactics that
he was Finding with James KY that was a
lot of fun but right now he's not going
to have fun because he's got this eyes
sore a backwards deep on and Wesley's
targeting it and I'm also thinking about
those NB back stairs that we've been
seeing it reminds me of a young Magnus
Carlson sitting across Gary CASRO with
his stairs not backing down of course
it's a farway off off but really
fascinating to see the parallels the
universal style between these two
players we do have the end game the dwn
has moved forward so at least defending
the E5 but now David the base comes
Under Fire with an open D line yeah open
dline Black's pieces as well creeping in
big attack now against White's B2 Pawn
the Black Knight jumping Black's Bishop
will rot itself will come to a better
diagonal in the next few moves it's
definitely Advantage black I think we
would uh well at least I would choose
black here I think we you speak for me
David it's it's nod for him Robert and
uh it is just about whether Abdus can
keep control yes he has ugly pawns
especially the base Pawn on D4 but one
weakness you might be able to hold and
whoa C5 Wesley doesn't want to play the
long game he wants the tension Here and
Now lashing out I kind of like it
because he probably felt that given time
no deck would be able to save off the
pressure and keep everything under
control but right now that's a free pawn
two different pieces can take it and
just like a game ago where no de won
with black and Wesley gave away a pawn
that couldn't be captured here it can
but you take with the pawn you lose your
E5 Pawn if you take with your knight you
lose your D4 pawn and maybe E5 next so
we are seeing the position change
completely still chances for Wesley to
over overtake I should say and outplay
Noir
B wow all right so Wesley so with the
black pieces has managed to create a
dynamic end game we will keep our eye
out on this one let's head over to to
our other fight and wow there is a lot
going on I'm taking it all in Black's
Bishop looks like it's hanging but let's
point out the pin along the defile so
you really can't go for Knight takes
Bishop cuz Rook takes Queen comes in
with a check you don't have time to
capture Black's Queen the first question
that I'm going to throw to you guys is
white really wants to get the king to
safety there's also a threat of the
queen jumping into B4 he does it but the
evalar reacts because the D4 Knight
comes Under Fire yeah I don't want to
boast but I did predict this whole
variation a bit earlier I showed it on
the board and I think castling was just
a bit premature um whes King needs to
get to safety yes but actually it could
have been okay in the center for a move
or two longer it was more important to
uh Evacuate the White Queen from this
defile pin the White Queen if it had
moved would have freed up the White's
Knight to pounce and suddenly Fabiano
he's pinned left right and Center
Black's Bishop is threatening to come
out to C5 that would be the end of the
game on the spot and it might be
collapsing Here and Now Queen F6 Magnus
the speed with which he pounced and
played it I think he suddenly realized
this is a golden opportunity yeah and
he's got a double the amount of time on
the clock as well a Fabby a very
difficult position to defend in under
four minutes he's looking at a second
rank defense wants to slide over the
rook in front of the queen yeah but he's
going to defend but Black's going to do
the same you first bring your Bishop out
to pin that Knight some more The Rook
comes to D2 then you just slide your
Rook up for black I mean white is
defending for now but black can increase
the Firepower and white can't bring
another piece to defend so I believe the
knight at this stage would have to step
back to the C2 Square I want to point
out that Knight F5 I don't think will
work out either but the B2 Pawn is loose
in so many position I was going to go
for this queen sacrifice David you got
me there uh that if you take you take on
E3 with check and then Rook takes D2 at
the end you have a rook and two Bishops
for a queen that's too much material we
do a quick count 11 points for black
just nine for the queen for white so I
think that F have to step back to C2 but
then the B2 Pawn is loose in many of
these positions is no fun I think that
Fabiano even after Rook to d8 he just is
under immense pressure too much pressure
as you say Robert it's uh not just this
diagonal it's the defile it's all about
this Knight and wow this is all
happening if Magnus moves his Rook it
looks like he has a decisive decisive
Advantage bring the final piece to the
party it's this Rook on h8 it wants to
be on the defile stack them up double
them up and white is collapsing Fabiano
in big big trouble in the next few moves
it looks like Fabby is about to lose
material in the position literally
pinned from Left Right and Center in
this one big big pressure I think Magnus
we saw him there reach out and he has
moved the Rook forward does Fabby have
any time any hope at all to try to unpin
with that Knight jumping on to either F5
or falling back to C2 same tactics I
think if you move the White Knight to F5
as we show The Black Queen can sacrifice
black would emerge with extra pieces
extra material the White Knight drops
back maybe the best bet right now uh
White oh it's really hanging by a thread
I don't think Fabiano uh is going to be
able to escape this one simply 3 minutes
on the clock yes but so much to
calculate there's so much tension so
many Alternatives too many tactics I
think for Fabian on the left hand side
of our screen he can also move his King
to the corner that way some pieces
aren't capture with check but you see
the Eva bar still in Black's favor
there's way too much to work through
maybe the computer can find some kind of
wild defense but for Fabiano he's just a
mere mortal it's not going to be simple
and I see Wesley I just saw him in the
right hand side of our screen his Knight
jumped into E3 watch out there may be
some check meting ideas against the
white king if that Knight can jump over
to the Kings side Knight G4 do not lift
your Rook off the first rank if you're
narbeck up DUS sataro that could
actually end badly wow and white knight
Retreats backward Knight moves are the
hardest to spot Abdu satov on the right
Board of our screens I think he can
force a draw right now the other white
knight can start retreating Black's Rook
is tied down to the defense of his own
Knight and look at what he's doing he
drops his Knight back into the center
Black's Rook forced away White Knight
continues to harass this black rook and
position repeats itself the only way to
keep Black's Knight alive is to repeat
and draw and handshake Abdu satov takes
it it's handshakes Abdu satov wins set
one of the semi-finals against Wesley so
he was the underdog on paper but he
shows why he is absolutely at the top of
his game and here to stay and fight for
this championship Wesley so has to win
second set to keep it going and ever the
chess player n Bea buar he looks at
what's happening between Fabiano Carana
and Magnus Carlson he's not looking
ahead to a potential final matchup he
just loves chess he wants to see the
best of the best play and he is one of
the best players so he's right there
with them but right now we do have this
other game going Tanya and Fabby he's in
trouble where nybeck was not and I'm
just thinking nck was the chosen one
Wesley chose to play against nck is that
a decision he's got to be regretting
that right now yeah he had to choose
between two evils he chose his own
poison Wesley so and it looks like
that's backfiring but another chance
tomorrow it's the best of three sets
tomorrow's second set will be vital so
uh still chances for Wesley so to fight
back Magnus Carlson trying to fight back
in this game I like the simple approach
that you mentioned earlier Robert just
bring that final piece in Blacks rook in
the corner slide it to the center back
up double your Rooks and uh still
pressure on fabian's position but for
now uh he is holding things together
Knight back to C2 was an important move
to find and it's hard to fault Wesley so
for picking n deer because when you look
at what Fabiano's done in three games
against Magnus Carlson not much easier
of an opponent not easier at all so we
are going to focus in on this game here
the Knight did Retreat to C2 the B2 Pawn
is loose because that Queen on F6 is
staring that direction and Magnus I mean
he's been like this all day I don't know
if he's uh you know feeling under the
weather or if he's just bored but even
Bor Magnus is great at the board and he
just slides his Bishop back so no trades
allowed to Fabiano okay I didn't
actually have this move on my radar I
was looking at the forcing lines the
direct routs tradeoff pieces go for
pawns uh try to capture stuff try to
turn your advantage into something
material uh but he's simply dropping
back saying the bishop pair is good
enough the white king not entirely safe
no Defenders around it and uh we know
the bishop PA how strong they are
Black's other Rook will join Black's
pawns on the king side might throw
themselves forward still a big advantage
long term and uh big advantage on the
clock more importantly and things are
just starting to get messy things are
just starting to get complicated for
white here we can imagine the bishop and
the queen lining up on the diagonal
hitting that H2 Pawn a Defender key
defender on the king side for White's
King right now another question for
Fabby the B2 Pawn is hanging I like this
approach by Magnus he wants to keep the
tension on the bishop pirs not allowing
any trade Fabby ignoring any threats on
the B2 Pawn lining up against magnet is
King yeah a good move activating his
final piece I was talking about the
black Rook joining the party that white
Rook was fast asleep snoring in the
corner and uh at least it's staring down
the black king but I don't see any
direct threats and that that means
Magnus does have the luxury of time to
activate his piece look at the
centralization for Black's Rooks right
now feels like something is brewing
something is in the air there's going to
be some kind of Bishop takes Pawn on H2
with Che I don't know when it's going to
happen but it looks like with all of
these pieces staring down the defile
black is going to win that battle you
usually do when there's a queen in line
with a rook Queen E1 play I actually
think you can take this Pawn with check
I think Magnus can grab it and then take
on The Rook on D2 and at the end he's
got this queen check that will pick up
his sacrifice Bishop but I would be a
little bit nervous if I were Magnus
because that Rook on C1 it stares
through the Knight towards the black
Bishop on C6 there will be things to
work out but I do believe magn can snag
that pawn on H2 and there he goes wow
Greek gift sacrifice normally we would
say when it comes to sacrificing on this
type of square but this one is based on
double attacks geometry we see forcing
moves the king had to recapture a trade
of Rooks and uh Robert The Sting in the
tail as you mentioned the black queen
sliding to D6 Fabiano pauses does he
have any other option he's currently
Down The Exchange Rook for Knight he has
to Simply take back and allow this check
to come black will win back the
sacrificed piece here we go double
attack check and black will profit porn
up in the end game yeah and playing
Magnus Carlson down upon the Rook and
Bishop combining and that pawn isn't any
pawn there is a potential of the H Pawn
marching down the board in the end game
creating a rook Pawn passer which are
the hardest to fight for Knights on the
board and Fabiano Karana has to do this
uphill defensive task under 30 seconds
no chance I don't like to call games
over before they're over but he's also
passive his Knight can hardly move
because the pawns behind it will be
under attack if the Queens come off the
board he's just down upon Pawn in an end
game and the bishop is stronger than
Knight because their pawns on both sides
of the board Bishop's being long long
range pieces yeah we know it's Magnus
Carlson anyone else you might stand a
chance but here the Queens are off we're
in the end game now and Black's Rooks
coming in so many Targets on that second
rank that's where all of White's pawns
are an attack against the black bishops
slows down Magnus here Black's Bishops
could simply move though he can be
defended by the king what will he go for
Magnus Carlson he's done the hard work
he's uper porn he just needs to slow
down consolidate and uh he should get
the job done eventually good move there
from Fabiano challenging the bishop he
also to bring his Knight forward to C4
which he can now do because that Rook
can't stay on the second rank so the
black Rook it's fine moving backwards
but it is just a pawn so perhaps I was
calling it a moment too soon I was
looking at fabi's clock I was looking at
magnus's confidence and you see Magnus I
mean he's perked up he's ready to take
this game he's ready to take this game
look at the nerves though on Fabiano
he's got half an eye on the clock he
played that move with three seconds left
now he's been forced to put all of
White's pawns on light squares easy
targets for Black's Bishop look at the
White Knight though contorting retrieve
shoting to ugly posts on the edge of the
board there's a threat of Knight coming
to B5 but this can be prevented and then
White's Knight will be offside really
not good news for kowana fans right now
yeah and Fab's played such fabulous
chest today but this game from start to
finish getting out of the opening Magnus
really put the pressure on he put the
pressure on the moment he went alongside
Castle saying that he's going all out on
the defile eventually won that D4 Pawn
he's up upon it's a matter of tech te
Magnus Carlson up on the clock Fabby
down to 7 seconds he wants to avoid
these complications which often happen
with a KN jumping forward A6 would be a
move that I would Blitz out what else is
Magnus thinking about here he could also
move his Rook forward back into the
second rank to go after White's pawns A6
is a great choice though Tanya because
in that circumstance you take away the
knight's forward jumps and you look at
Magnus he's just being extra careful he
doesn't want to fall into any night
Forks any tactics so A6 would be a good
choice by that standard yeah I'm in your
boat Tanya play A6 in 1 second think
later you've done the hard work you've
pocketed a pawn kill all counterplay but
Magnus he wants a more direct route to
Victory he doesn't want to allow Carana
any chance long term but there we go A6
eventually does appear and black Rook
trying to come down to the second rank
that's been prevented Fabby made that
move again with 3 seconds and a clear
visible win there as he made it Black's
Aon coming down the board targets it's a
majority attack three versus two on the
queen side can Magnus just keep pushing
he keeps rolling down the board creating
a second weakness on the queen side
attacking the pawns but right now he
first needs to keep that Rook solid in
the center if Fabby was to take on A4
the A2 pick Pawn becomes a huge Target
for black and the problem for Fabby is
that Magus is play on both sides of the
board he pushes a pawn why not push your
other Rook Pawn he can push that one
forward a bunch and just take up space
but he gets his King involved how could
you blame him Fabby goes to semiopen
line and as long as Magnus doesn't
blender any pawns he will keep this
advantage that's a scary Magnus when he
makes these chill moves on the board in
this relaxed State you don't want to be
sitting across that guy yeah that's
literally the worst thing in chess when
Magnus gets an endgame advantage and
grinds you down he's got an extra porn
as well here he just creates a safe
haven for the black Bishop to retreat to
Fabby zigzagging back and forth with his
rook and the black king surely is going
to come in soon Magnus first ties down
White's pieces to the defense of the B
Pawn and the King is Coming and there's
nothing that white can do because if the
Knight moves or The Rook moves you lose
that B3 pwn and you cannot give black a
two on none on that side of the board
but if the King goes forward some more
maybe the white Rook will start gaining
access to key squares to go after the
black king side so you don't want to go
all in but Magnus he's down under 40
seconds himself everything under control
thus far but if he drops another 20
seconds perhaps fabbi will have a chance
Fabby gets rid of another set of Pawns
suddenly some counterplay potentially
getting his Rook active the black Bishop
drops back though what a nice move there
from Magnus to keep control to remind
white of the weakness the white B Pawn
the isolated Pawn on the queen side it's
tying down White's pieces and now the
board is even more open that uh really
plays The Bishop's skills here The
Bishop's abilities compared to the
Knight dominating this white knight
really nice there but pawns have been
traded off and we see the evalar but is
it as easy as the evalar seems to imply
well white just has these two moves that
you're seeing the Rook going back and
forth and now can be freed because the
B3 Pawn is defended so Magnus he's
bringing is King forward every single
piece for him is doing its job it kind
of reminds of the end game with Ali Rea
fua where he had rook and Bishop ala had
rook and Knight and now he's just
targeting that weakness and Fab he has
to passively
defend and now he clamps down on the
king side as well taking away more moves
more freedom from Fabiano kyana the
night and The Rook all tied down to
defend B3 Zang T white just can't move
white can't move the Rook or the Knight
because the B Pawn would drop if white
moves the king black might even play
move like H4 Pawn to H4 here we go we
see it and white kingside falls apart
now full board awareness Black's Bishop
controls both flanks The Rook is so
dextrous right now attacking the White
Knight and Rook to D3 coming in King
coming in wh remaining Pawn will drop
and Magnus will win which just
unbelievable how easy he made this look
he just completely took away all squares
from Fab's pieces and then all of his
pieces marching forward taking away the
moves wins that extra Pawn is he just
going to C on B3 next I don't see why
not it looks like a free pawn and then
he can Rumble forward with his other
pawns and he takes it Fabby is going to
try to get active with his Rook but even
if he gains one Pawn there's still the
other to deal with oh Charlie the SE
Pawn marching down the board now this
seor will cost white his night long term
it's coming towards promotion an attack
on The Rook first of all Magnus slides
away and Fabiano Le keep playing no
fight left here no resources left and he
resigns he doesn't and how many times
have we seen this Magnus Carlson with
his back against the wall Rises to the
occasion he delivers and takes it to
Armageddon and I think I saw a slight
smile from Magnus he's not going to be
happy with this play overall but that
was a great game from the world number
one he outplayed Fabby from this offbeat
opening and Fabby he's going to be
kicking himself because he had this
match seemingly in the bag but when
you're playing Magus Carlson Never Say
Never and it does go down to the wire as
the players are about to give their uh
Magnus Carlson struggling there a little
bit with the pan he hasn't struggled in
game four at all the first game of their
set one the first game of this match
where really we saw Magnus at his best
getting his positions then just out
playing once he got that strategic
Advantage he immediately rites the bid
leaves it comes down to Armageddon we've
seen Magnus with his unpredictable bids
here for Fabby what does he want right
now I think both players should bid high
for white right now we've had no draws
so far in the match between these two
draws overrated play for the win and uh
you might be rewarded for your
courage and this is our bracket there is
still action left on day one of the
semi-finals as we move to Armageddon and
it will be between Magnus Carlson and
Fabiano Carana meanwhile Wesley so goes
down in set one to nck up to satov nck
played such a great match he really
deserved it and so he is able to
stabilize in game four make that draw
Win set one Fabiano he was not able to
do the just that he wasn't able to keep
it under control and now he has to do it
all over again in the Armageddon David
where did it all go wrong for Fabby for
Fabiano Carana it went wrong early
unfortunately he was caught out in the
opening burnt a lot of time on the clock
and was not able to fight back but it
was here that objectively the first real
mistake was made white is in an awkward
pin this pin on the White Knight is
really terrifying you cannot move it for
example to capture a bishop because this
move comes with check and uh Black's
Queen will save itself next turn here
very naturally Fabiano carled his King
but this allowed the black queen to step
out the way the pin persists due to
pressure on this Knight and the black
Bishop comes out now with Force instead
if he had taken a Karma approach maybe
realized he had the luxury of time and
just moved his Queen out the way
suddenly the White Knight is threatening
to take this bishop white will be able
to Castle next move and Black's
Advantage is kept to a minimum here
Fabiano would have at least survived the
opening and been able to play a balanced
game it's difficult to recover from a
loss when all you need is a draw to win
a set however you could summarize the
game as just awful chess right there
from Fabiano that's not meant to be
insulting but I think when you look back
you're like I just am so much better
than that what happened to me if he's
able to just forget about it because it
was just a bad game then maybe he can
recover in time for this upcoming
Armageddon yeah they say shown memory is
a chess player's best friend and right
now Fabby needs that he has to let go of
what just happened with the white pieces
because this is Rea time as we go into
Armageddon and that is a world number
two who has to do it all over again
against Magnus Carlson after this
[Music]
break a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal post ERS from displate now with
the official collection from chess.com
Mount them in seconds with a toolfree
magnet kit and swap them whenever you
like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code Chess at displate.com
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things hey everyone it's Ka roing
reporter for the CCT finals I'm going to
give you guys a venue tour so coming out
of the elevator that's where the players
will be entering all their games every
day heading straight into the player
Lounge so they can sit here relax if
they want coming in here this is
everyone's favorite place this is where
we have the catering and the catering KY
is awesome oh oh we yeah as you can see
best part of J store it's just right
here is the food it's amazing I'm having
an egg burrito I'm about to be so
energized for today's time the food is
amazing okay enjoy your breakfast
burrito going to take you guys in here
so I'm actually going to say this is
where the magic happens first of all in
the corner here that's where I have my
mixone when I get to interview all the
players in between games and take a look
at this take a look at all the screens
all the equipment a lot of fantastic
people are here to make this event
happen I did say that's where the magic
happens well actually this is where the
magic happens this is the venue you guys
a huge room actually and so much
equipment in here I actually heard we
have 20 cameras rolling here every day
to show you guys what's happening on the
boards should I try a chair not sure if
I'm allowed though but okay loving the
CCT finals and thank you for joining
this venue
[Music]
tour
day
back
[Music]
toight
well number one Magnus go he does it
when it matters the most he gets that
comeback win in the final rapid game and
takes it to
Armageddon Armageddon it is the sudden
death of Chess that will decide the
winner of set one in this match and you
ask what it is take a look welcome to
the most exciting format in chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in turn white must win a draw
secures black the match point white
starts with 15 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black and those coveted
draw odds let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence it's going to be the ultimate
mind games and Kaa is with the players
to find out their bids and
colors there will be armagedon to decide
the winner of this first semi-final
match so you guys go ahead and turn
those boards and let's see the bids I
see 10:01 for Fabby 856 Magnus you will
play with the black pieces you did
Circle but I I assume yeah yeah sure
what was the thinking behind this bit um
I didn't think too much it seemed normal
to me you have had success with the
white pieces in the armagedon so far
though so um want to try something new
here here well I I think Armageddon like
this is fairly fairly balanced so I
don't know we'll see and Fabby 101 are
you happy with the white pieces well
there's no way I would go as low as 856
so whatever I bid it anyway I was going
to get white all right well it's going
to be exciting thank you for placing
your bids back to you
guys thanks K Magnus with an 8 minute
50c bid gets the black pieces Fabby will
start with a six-minute advantage on the
clock this is the lowest we've seen
Magnus go down so far well Magnus
believes in having the draw ODS which is
interesting because we've had zero draws
thus far in the match I'll have to say I
would give a slight advantage to Fabiano
just because that's a huge lead in the
clock but the look on Fabiano's face
there he did not seem like a happy chess
player he seemed a bit deflated we'll
see if he can bring his best in
Armageddon that's exactly what they need
to do it all comes down to sudden that
it's all about Armageddon and before the
games get going let's check in with the
crew in Toronto guys predictions for the
big
one thank you Tanya yeah James I mean
856 is a 856 a low bid now I will say I
do think it matters less that it's a
six-minute Time Advantage for white I
think it's mostly how much time do I
personally have to equalize the game and
not lose so I think Magnus thinks 856 is
enough is enough a56 is very very low he
really wanted the black pieces there of
course I mean he says hey you know what
look we're going to he says balance is
what he said that's the the terminology
he used fairly balanced so he was like
yeah we want to imbalance it here by
having low time no increment and a black
pieces so this is going to be wild here
yeah I mean this is uh but he did just
have a really successful game with the
black pieces he imbalanced things
exactly like he does and he won on
demand now he doesn't need to win on
demand but I think my prediction is he's
going to go again for imbalance rather
than stability stability white can play
Forever yeah but who knows who knows
yeah who knows he might just play before
being in a stable opening how he just
said you know he I think he gave us a
little bit of hint there he was like
yeah it's fairly balanced so I chose a56
to really tear it up and un imbalance it
and also take black because I got the
draw odds so not only am I imbalancing
and with of time you know see what we do
I also have the black pieces as well so
we really trying to win this and knock
it out right now this is a crazy
balanced game so far so we going to see
what happens in this Armageddon what you
think going to happen here oh I don't
know I don't know and and and the good
news is you don't care about us so let's
throw it back to Oslo and let's get
these boys rolling Armageddon
semi-finals day one starting right now
oh wow it's going to be a lot of fun ly
by the way great shirt as well David
what do you think about these bids and
Magnus playing with black I've got to
admit I'm surprised it does feel
extremely low I'm on fabby's side here I
think online you can get away with 856
over the board it's going to be tough
physically to make that number of moves
but we'll see who's rewarded ah yes
Magnus with the Fantastic game for win
which he made look easy with the black
pieces can he get those earlier opening
imbalances and we are about to find out
but this time Fabby starts with the
Kings Pawn opening we've got a sicilian
on the board and Fa and a one in game
two the wh side of a sicilian but we
don't have the Rosal liimo that we saw
them playing 2018 World Chess
Championship we said we have a con
Sicilian a different line and for
Fabiano he's played this for the white
side he's played it from the black side
we'll see what variation he goes down
can he win yes he can the Sicilian KH
it's a risky choice I must say for
Magnus Carlson so definitely not playing
for stability uh definitely not kind of
trying to lock down this game playing
straight for the draw keeping all
options open but you're walking up
against one of the best prepared players
out there and look at this last move
Queen to E2 from Fabiano has forced
Magnus to pause Magnus prevents the
white ewn from stepping up even further
but this one is guaranteed to get a bit
wild now and Fabby throws pawns forward
this is the ideal position in a must-win
situation for white Fabby with 15
minutes has to win a draw me means
Magnus wins set one and with that last
move Fabby reinforcing the threat that
was previously stopped by magnus's D6 E5
always in the board in these positions
white is often looking at even the G
Pawn marching up the board and we can
expect some early fireworks I just feel
like these are difficult positions to
figure out so you need time on the clock
and after night bd7 I'm surely thinking
about playing G4 and Fabiano had bad
clock Management in that fourth game
here he's playing at a much quick pace
and look at that pawn go he's not
holding anything back right now yeah all
the pawns storming forward and Fabiano
he has pretty much said the white king
is going Queen side he's going to Castle
uh To the Left Flank so why not develop
the bishop keep the pace going keep the
speed Magnus he's cramped he's kind of
having to contort his pieces and uh the
clock time still in White's favor
actually Fabiano has spent way less time
than Magnus right now still with a over
six-minute time Advantage oh I really
fear for magnus's position I feel like
Faby can continue pushing up on the king
side use your Rook Pawn now keep
throwing those pawns forward prevent the
black king from castling and that famous
game that Magnus lost to Andre yeno I
remember pawns were going up the board
and Magnus maybe bid off a little bit
more than he can shoot tactically
speaking for Fabby this is the exact
type of position you want in a must-win
game in Armageddon yeah but he needs to
keep up on the clock he really cannot
afford to start taking so much time so
early on in the game now he goes on the
queen side yeah playing on all flanks
this is greedy from hi from not Hikari
from Fabiano even and I love it pushing
all the pawns forward trying to gain
space on the Queen's side now that he's
pretty much conquered the king side with
his pawns and it's really tough finding
counterplay here for Magnus Carson where
the black Bishop's going where's the
black king going so many questions to
answer so little time I wouldn't have
played it myself but I actually really
like to move A4 because one of Black's
Big Ideas is to push that B Pawn forward
get counterplay of your own look at how
cramped Black's position position is
that Bishop on C8 that light Square
Bishop for Magnus it can't get out your
Bishop on E7 staring into that G5 Pawn
that wall of Pawns and here comes
another Pawn where is the black king
going I hear you guys Fabby playing on
the right side of the board on the left
side of the board but to me that begs
the question where is Fab's King going
to find safety is not going to head to
the king side with the H and the g Pawn
up the board do you really want to
Castle Queen side after you've committed
a A4 maybe it's going to stay maybe both
sides are going to play a guessing game
they both have commitment issues these
Kings right now neither side wants to
kind of declare their intentions and
here we go Fabiano yeah he's not holding
back it's all about pushing pawns and
it's such natural easy straightforward
play for white throw pawns forward until
there are no more pawns to throw forward
for black it might be decision time
where to put that King and if black
Castle Queen side right to the left hand
side of our screen here why can continue
throwing up pawns on that side of the
board you first have to cover your bases
make sure you don't drop any pieces
along the way but you have to watch out
for all sorts of sacrifices and pawn
pushes the black king is going to be
exposed no matter which direction it
goes in if you Castle King side I worry
for you there as well Magnus by the way
he's down to 6 minutes 45 seconds no
easy choices ahead I'm going to predict
a queenside castle for white I don't
know where magnus's King finds safety
definitely Under Fire but I think for
white I would want to get that King all
the way to B1 oh maybe not anymore yeah
at least we know Magnus won't Castle
Queen side now he's pretty much taken
that option off the table for himself
the black king is rooted to the center
of the board for now can still Castle
King side but that feels like it would
be castling into the eye of the storm
and for Fabiano it's just about
improving pieces right now does he
Castle it feels a bit risky lining up
against the black queen and Rook how
does he prepare the further advance of
his pawns Rook to G1 there we go I like
it he's just waiting for Magnus to make
a big decision and Magnus is kind of
running out of waiting moves he has all
of his pieces on pretty much ideal
squares can he really push a pawn I
don't think so white on the other hand
can initiate a pawn break maybe Pawn G6
maybe Pawn F5 maybe Pawn H6 you have all
sorts of options and wo after G6 maybe
the white Rook should slide back to
where it came from waiting for that open
file quick call there Robert once The
Rook has done its job on one side on one
file it moves on to the other one
preempting an opening up of the hline
and Magnus first strikes with G6 and now
in the center forcing a decision do you
capture that E5 Pawn because that gives
black a really
nice hold with the Knight jumping on to
E5 I'm mainly wondering if white can
take on G6 right now because black can't
take towards the center like you
typically want to because your Rook is
loose at the end of the file and if you
take have to take away from the center
you cannot touch that Knight on D4
that's just giving white a huge attack
and a pass Pawn so Fabiano goes for it
and Naga takes away from C David what do
you make of this yeah it's not ideal for
black long term now black is suffering
on the H file a really passive Rook here
a big Target in front of it this
backward Pawn that being said fighting
for squares as tan mentioned and it
might be important in the next few turns
to capture on F4 as he has just done and
at least carve out one square for his
pieces black is so cramped there's a
traffic jam of pieces over on this flank
so it's time Drop That Knight into E5
maybe even tradeoff on D3 first and
black is alive black is breathing whose
King is weaker that's the key question
right now and it's a question I don't
have the answer to it just looks like uh
both Kings will come under heavy fire in
the near future but this is exactly the
kind of crazy position that you want in
an armagedon playing with the white
pieces Magnus Carlson now under 6
minutes no increment uh the game for all
three results the position where
anything can happen uh and as this one
heats up take a look at what's happening
in Toronto it's all eyes on the
Armageddon as everyone's there Wesley as
well watching the game we got Danny and
the crew there give us a wave everyone
if you can hear us hey guys can you see
us the answer is no they're not
listening they're following the action
because this game is really heating up
in the center of the board I think
Magnus did the right thing though when
he pushed that pawn to E5 it was just
the right moment we see look how
intensity they're all looking I think
James is looking with the computer
engine is this the best choice the
engine says it's about level but that
means nothing right now so who can find
the accurate continuations Knight E5 a
very good choice to Magnus he hasn't
committed his King over to G8 because
you Castle King side that white Rook on
H1 is going to barrel down the h f and
cause some pressure against the black
kings I like how Magnus is handling this
and the clock times is still dramatic
whose position do you feel is easier
more instinctive to play it's just under
11 minutes against five minutes and a
half here I'm liking Black's position
right now but I'm not liking his clock
situation right now and I think it's
still got some questions to be answered
for Fabby this Knight that you're
pointing out that Magnus has planted on
E5 there's really no happy way to
capture it if you take it with your own
Knight Black's Bishop suddenly opens up
and finds itself on a nice diagonal if
you give up the bishop for it you've
given up a key Bishop air in an open
position with a big G5 weakness I'm
wondering if fb's in a castle Queen side
at some point that Rook on A1 if that
were in the game we might be talking an
advantage for white but if he castles
Queen side you're walking into the eye
of an attack so instead he backtracks
with his Bishop to E3 maybe he also
rerouted some more the B6 Pawn a little
bit tender I like that move it actually
forces Magnus to come up with a choice
and wow he castles into the line of fire
that shows Supreme Confidence from
Magnus Carlson castling on a side it
looked like he was getting attacked on
but now suddenly the seventh rank has
cleared and the one weakness the black
H7 Pawn can easily be defended by the
black Rook or even the black queen and
uh it's all about the white king first
there a threat Knight takes Knight you
need to resolve that tension and uh
Fabiano needs to get his King to safety
as quickly as possible he's really
regretting putting his white Pawn on A4
if that was back on A2 you Castle Queen
side with impunity you just Castle get
your king into the corner but it's the
white king stranded in the middle right
now and Fab does take a decision he
doesn't trade on E5 opening up that
black Bishop jumps in the center and he
castles into the line of fire wow even
giving up the A4 Pawn black can even go
and take it now the black queen can
slide over due to a pin on the C file
White's Knight on C3 not really
protecting that pawn but Fabby doesn't
care a pawn is a pawn as they say but
right now it's more important to get the
king to safety white will just park the
King on B1 and say you're not going to
Checkmate me and he plays B5 does Magnus
he doesn't want the pawn he wants to
continue the attack and one thing that
Magnus need to keep an eye on a rook
takes Pawn on H7 it's a whole Rook
sacrifice you seem to be very careful
about ideas like that because the White
Queen sliding over the next Rook coming
in there could be the makings of a
checkmating net but for now B5 it looks
like the white Kings in more danger yeah
big move from Magnus Carlson not
materialistic at all as I mentioned he
could have won a pawn but who cares
about pawns it's more important to
attack throw pawns forward throw pieces
forward and actually Fabion is
hesitating trading off a set of Pawns
because suddenly the a line would come
open uh available for Black's Brooks
long term I would not envy Fabiano's
decision right now it looks really
really difficult to whip up an attack
against the black king you're basically
relying on those tricks you mentioned
Robert just some tactics something
Landing but if it doesn't land you might
just be collapsing on the other flank
and he does trade off pawns that is a
surprising decision I thought he would
start with King to B1 but maybe he's
saying to Magnus I don't see your
Checkmate just yet that Knight on C3 is
no longer pinned it can jump forward
into D5 and Magnus presses forward oh if
Fabiano's dropping back with his pieces
I'm not liking his chances yeah but now
black can double up on the open a line
and start targeting that Knight on A2
two obvious moves to me Queen A4
followed by The Rook lining up with that
Queen hitting that Knight that had just
moved backwards to me it just feels like
all the attack is Advantage Magnus right
now yeah retreating in this type of
position in any open Sicilian taking a
step back is like falling off a bicycle
it means you stop pedaling you will get
punished you will be in for a world of
hurt and opening up lines even further
for his Bishops this is really
instructed by black but that Rook
sacrifice that I was saying you need to
keep an eye on can Fabiano go for it his
position is getting really bad it's
actually on the verge of getting out of
hand Rook takes H7 the king takes back
I'm looking at Queen H2 check the Knight
on E5 is loose over here as well so you
know if we go King G7 I got to take the
Knight with check I'm bringing my Rook
over maybe I'm playing a little bit of
that what they call cof me house chess
I'm playing for tricks but I need to do
something right yeah you need to try
something and now might be the final
moment Fabiano is able to create any
counterplay at all the evaluation bar
still says good for black but it's not
entirely winning you're setting traps
you're forcing Magnus to burn clock and
uh here big threat if you aren't able to
run into the center which I don't think
is too appealing because this Knight
drops suddenly your King still under
heavy fire from all angles uh then uh
yeah what else to do with Magnus uh
magnus's King here maybe you move the
bishop out the way in that position to
guard across the seventh rank but uh
it's really really difficult it might be
now or never for Fabiano to muddy the
waters take this Pawn before it's too
late you need to try something I'll just
mention that Queen to H2 is not good
enough looks like a double attack but
this way round the move order doesn't
work black just simply defends the
Knight defends the pawn and everything
is controlled and Fabby pauses he's
having a think and I think this is
exactly the line that's running through
his head Rook into Pawn to try to muddy
the waters will Fabby go for this
because if he doesn't it feels like
Magnus just gets a free hand to execute
his attack hiar now you said it before I
was going to actually compliment him but
I was going to say that Fabiano and
hikara said this doesn't like
speculative sacrifices not somebody who
just says oh let me go for something and
hope that it works he's a calculator and
he's a calculating machine and he's
looking at Rook takes H7 he's trying to
prove that it works we saw the eval bar
it says it shouldn't work out for white
but shouldn't doesn't mean that it can't
and it is going to be a Scramble for
Magnus a lot of pressure around his King
and how many times have we seen that
it's all about making these practical
POS decisions in these positions it's
not about what is objectively the best
move right now he needs to pose
questions to Magnus give him the
opportunity to go wrong in complicated
position under 5 minutes on the clock no
increment but the more Fabby thinks the
more time for Magnus to think yeah and
we saw Magnus on the camera I don't know
if you missed it there but he I mean as
soon as we mentioned Hikaru he was doing
the head Bob he looked like he was
dancing he had something going on in his
head maybe he was just confirming with
this long variation this kind of
complicated line Rook takes Bor and he
was thinking oh maybe I am surviving yes
I'm calculating on your time Fabiano and
the longer he waits the less likely this
trick is to work Rook takes H7 if not
then yeah Black's light Square Bishop
comes to life the white king will be
doomed long term you're playing without
a white knight on A2 you have to do it
Fabiano you have to try something you
have to gamble he's invested three
minutes already so right now his time
Advantage it's almost out the window so
for Fabiano it's one of these situations
where if you're playing a bullet game
and you're playing online you just go
for it and you hope that it works out
but Fabiano if he doesn't go for it his
position is falling apart Magnus just
plays move D5 he's trying to break open
the position even more the a file is
open the C file is open white king does
not have too many defenders in front of
it so this is going to be a situation
where as we're talking about now or
never for Fabiano I think you just have
to go for it and if you pray and it
works so be it on the board bang and who
has calculated better it's a check
Magnus has worked this all out in
Fabiano's time big threat of Checkmate
on the board Queen to H7 would end the
game Magnus needs to guard against it
but was Magnus only expecting Queen
takes Knight because after Rook H1 with
this idea had he taught this true he
would Blitz out his next move it kind of
reminds me of his game against Wesley so
where Wesley beat him in Armageddon he
threw a ton of pieces at Magnus Magnus
defends a seventh Rank and defens KN but
Queen H eight check oh wow Bishop F4 I
was not expecting that move maybe Magnus
wasn't either I thought he could
continue checking against the black king
and pick up that 95 this is really
complicated really really messy Let's
ignore the evaluation bar which is
misleading right now with best play
Black defends black has an extra rook
and will win the game but that black
king is about to come come under heavy
fire threats against the Black Knight
too this is far from Easy with just 3
minutes on the clock Magnus makes a
mistake he gives up his Queen
potentially but he's counterattacking
against the White Queen is this a
mistake or is this genius to try and
save this game and Armageddon draw would
be enough at this point the players are
just making moves they're not thinking
about what is the best move it is about
saving the position move by move Knight
jumps in White's Queen is attacked black
Black's Queen is attacked you really
can't trade off Queens in this position
can you crazy tactics here Robert yeah
the black Queen's kind of trapped right
if white just moves the queen one step
forward where's that black queen going
but black will make a draw I think black
can just take the white Bishop give up
the black queen and black has Knight D2
check the white King's forced to the
corner Knight B3 check and there's a
Perpetual check Black Knight Will trap
this white king Magnus has spotted it
all and I think Fabby has just spotted
it all that is brilliant it's one of
those decisions where it's given a
blunder symbol because the evaluation
gone to the middle but all Magnus
Carlson needs is a draw and he's about
to force the draw this is unbelievable
recognition we just saw that video
during the break of them doing tactics
Magnus he's been doing his tactics and
just Uncorked a beautiful four straw
sequence you got to break this down so
white cannot take Black's Queen because
the endgame after all the trades favors
Magnus Carlson if white was to get out
of the queen trade with the queen move
David explain it one more time the
Perpetual yeah if the White Queen steps
away from the second rank then all black
needs to do is remove White's Bishop
first of all if for example Queen to H3
black will take the bishop in either
direction Rook takes Bishop as soon as
the White Knight goes and captures The
Black Queen on G7 there's a Perpetual
check Black's Knight comes down to D2
Fabiano allows the Queens to disappear
instead he's fighting for the win but
with lack of Queens with uh this will
mean lack of attack as well and Magnus
trades off Rooks this is just over it
could have been a draw that would have
ended in the same result Magnus is going
to win this arm again and it's not
because Fabby missed that Perpetual
check it's because it's the same he has
to fight this out till the end a draw is
a loss at this point for Fabiano Karana
he had to choose the Lesser evil in this
position which is going to a busted end
game but the game goes on yeah but Fab's
head was in his hands I mean he's down
an entire Rook he's just playing on for
the sake of it he could just throw in
the towel Magnus Carlson brilliant
tactical awareness to take this
Armageddon yeah it's a surprise this
game is still ongoing 3 minutes for
Magnus is more than sufficient but
Fabiano just frustrated he got so close
he tried what he had to but in the end
handshake Magnus wins it is match over
as Magnus cson with the brilliant
tactics on the ball that he spotted in
seconds and it was all over takes the
win in the Armageddon that is set one to
Magnus set two Fabby will have to strike
back and that's something that Magnus
should be proud of I know he's been
upset about his play it was shaky
earlier on but to defend that position
and to just end it on the spot he did
not even allow a semblance of Hope to
Fabiano caran and the Armageddon
ridiculously good game from Magnus and
once again Magnus shows it even when he
is off F even on a bad day Magnus even
as off is actually on and you just
cannot write him off uh and we see him
getting that big dub in David I think it
all comes down to that moment that you
were pointing out which was the tactics
that Magnus spotted that decided the
armagen let's break it down Tanya let's
do a proper Action Replay of that
tactical flurry just genius by both
players but especially on the side of
Magnus Carson to guide the game towards
safely uh safety there and it was here
where Fabiano correctly chose to gamble
to risk it maybe playing this same move
quicker would have been better but he
decided Rook takes H7 before it's too
late before there's no sance of at all
of an attack Rook takes H7 dragging the
black king out and a check forcing the
black king back now threatening
Checkmate Magnus found the key defense
this square is the mating Square he
simply played Bishop D6 defending his
Knight covering this post yes Fabiano
could have given a check yes he might
have been able to give other checks for
example but unfortunately for him his
Queen here in the corner would have been
trapped a queen exchange black would
emerge with extra material he instead
chose the very clever the very sneaky
Bishop F4 move but Magnus had worked it
all out instead of delve even deeper
deeper into the complications he played
Queen to G7 the computer says it's a
blunder but this is a genius move now
the queen looks trapped Knight to E6
Magnus though counterattacks against the
White Queen and if the White Queen moves
this was the Crux of the matter Queen to
H3 would have left the D2 Square
undefended by all other than the bishop
so remove that piece Rook takes bishop
and after the black queen disappears a
beautiful drawing Motif check the white
king is forced into the corner another
check the king is forced back and the
position would have repeated itself
instead Fabiano gave up more material
but was not able to save the game puzzle
Rush on display live just to see that
all the way back when why had two pieces
covering the D2 Square wasn't on our
radar but Magnus Carlson he proves why
he's the number one rated player in the
world even when his back is against the
wall he can come out on top that was
really brilliant stuff from him that was
a stunning stunning find there by Magnus
and played out in seconds and Fabby had
no option but to go into the lost to end
game and this is where we are after set
one of the semi-finals we started with
eight players four were knocked out
going going into the semis and uh this
tomorrow we continue with set two as
Wesley so has to strike back against
nbec Abdus satov Fabiano Carana who did
take the lead in the rapid Magnus took
it back in game four equalized the score
and then one in the Armageddon wow that
was uh that was thrilling especially
considering that Magnus got the black
pieces he bid for the black pieces it
got really messy at the start and then
finding tactics with just no increment
yeah thrilling for Magnus I can't Heap
enough Praise on his play but
heartbreaking for five of Carana
throughout the first three games of the
match it could have been over in Fab's
favor he was up a queen in the first
game and still lost in that bullet
scramble so for Fabby there is no
consolation prize right now he lost
today's set one he needs to come back
tomorrow and win set two and then if he
gets there to a third and final set but
I you know he's going to just be
heartbroken after today's Affairs yeah
that's the beauty of the format we
always find a winner but it's also the
downside nobody deserved to lose today
they were trading punches both at the
top of their game Fabby in the end it
was just such small margins in the end
it was Magnus Madness that got it
through and uh yeah I'm still recovering
from all of that action it was really
really entertaining to watch yeah really
entertaining especially that line that
you pointed out with the Perpetual at
the end the night jumping from D2 to B3
to just find that kind of Chess this is
the beauty that we love when the very
best play in the world
now for Fabi it's been heart break but
he doesn't have that much recovery time
and there's big action coming up for all
four players tomorrow and for more
breakdown on everything that we've just
seen we're going to head over to our
gang in Toronto Danny what a day of
Chess once
again what a day of Chess this has just
been wild I I agree with what David just
said guys it felt like nobody deserved
to lose but somebody had to win in the
end
it's Magnus again I guess that happens a
lot yeah it happens a lot it's really
interesting I'm I'm kind of uh I guess I
kind of expected it when James and I
talked about the Armageddon time choice
and even though you're down 6 minutes
you still have enough time to think
being down 856 versus 15 is not the same
thing as being down 556 versus 12 like
the time Gap is the same but you you
yourself have enough time to create an
imbalance in a Sicilian Defense which is
what he went for and he just timed it
perfectly and ultimately that's what
what it comes down to I mean Magnus is
either going to beat everybody over the
course of a game from start to finish or
in just two or three critical moments
and that's what he did there against
Fabi I think it was important what he
said about the timing there the timing
was really nice is uh you have black
right I chose to go with the 8 minutes
836 or whatever he chose there I chose
to get that time I chose to imbalance it
I knew you were going to come at me him
being Fabby you're going to gra be
aggressive try to win here I'm going to
chose something that's going to give me
some chances and if I find that draw
then I win the game which he was able to
do it was amazing how he found that draw
cuz he played a line that was
objectively of course not the right way
to defend but Force liquidation
although I'm going to kind of disagree
in that the way this one started he goes
into Aon Sicilian Fabiano Carana is as
dangerous as anyone we're sitting there
with Maxim bash lrav who's been on the
black side of some sharp open Sicilians
against Fabiano and it felt like it felt
like things were going his way right and
then and then the gloves came up but
because of what you said because of
well-timed counterattacking moves by
Magnus G6 and then then E5 obviously
this was this was crazy I think we're
about to be joined by the Champs so
let's just scoot over and get him in
here
um Magnus it's uh I don't know where you
want to be you can be in between all of
us or on the edge or call
but you you've now won two must-win
games as black to force Armageddon but
uh take us through your thoughts on
today's match this felt like one that
neither of you really deserve to lose
but in the end somehow you snatched a
victory I could look at it both ways
like we kind of also Both Deserve to
lose because we made a lot of mistakes
um to be fair I think the first two
games were quite poor um I mean I just
made a really really childish mistake in
the second game cuz I can only like ever
trade Queens if his King doesn't get to
the center and I noticed immediately
after I made the move that he gets his
trick with King F1 and then it's quite
unpleasant for me already
at least then I have to Cease the moment
to force his Knight to D2 but I was so
pissed at myself and after that I think
he played flawlessly but
um uh yeah um I think third game he just
outplayed me I mean I didn't even feel
that I played that badly but I was just
crushed um and uh you know losing two
games in a row of course I didn't have I
didn't have a lot of hopes but these
Armageddon sorry not Armageddon games
but these must win games would like they
never they never seem to be
quite as straightforward as they as they
should be um and um yeah
um I I wouldn't say that I particularly
believed in it but I thought let's give
it give it a shot like
remember uh you know complicate the game
don't be too desperate and so on and
yeah the opening was a dream for me and
from there on it worked quite well
Magnus I have a question um obviously
game for of Rapid you have to create
imbalance to play for a win because it's
two to one but when you're playing
Armageddon I mean some people play E4 E5
they just try to hold with black I mean
you played Sicilian it was a cons
Sicilian it was complicated everybody's
sitting out there looking at all the
Tactical possibilities do you have to
make a conscious effort to play a
sicilian or an e45 versus the opponent
or I mean are we overanalyzing as
commentators I think it was more about
my mood um I didn't want want to get
back in sort of a defensive mindset so I
was trying to treat it more like a
must-win game or at least at least one
where I should not
um um you
know not try and avoid the fight
so I I also felt like trying to provoke
a crisis in the game earlier might be
okay for me since I have less time okay
uh I just didn't want to be in a
situation where I get ground ground down
I mean I didn't have the energy or the
nerves at that point to to play
like a long um long game at all so I
just wanted
to get a quick fight and see see what
happens and it also felt to me that he
would be he would be shaky after the the
last game he probably wouldn't expect
anything particularly sharp in the
opening so I I I hope that I could
surprise him but I mean I mean of course
it's um it's extremely risky especially
considering that my position from is
objectively I think pretty dubious this
chess left of course you have one more
match so uh you know say we win and we
go to the final who are we looking to
face or you want would you rather Abu a
tour off or wesle so as strong as they
are right now I think it's far too early
for for for that okay um I mean the way
that I'm playing the way that Fabi
played me in game three
especially um I wouldn't wouldn't take
anything for for granted I mean I think
that's fair what would you say your
mindset then is because I mean game one
you kind of got away with one right
right fobby was two moves away from
winning and then even though maybe it
was back and forth games two and three
goes go his way what are you doing
tonight to maybe feel like hey like I
don't know that I played my best chest
today
tomorrow bring yeah I guess I got to do
something else before the game because
like the
last 3 days really I've just turned up
and felt horrible so that's that's the
yeah that's the thing really um i' just
not been not been ready from the start
at all just feeling super sluggish so I
think that's that's where it is I know
of course that I can play that I can
play good chess but um the way that it's
been the last few days I feel like I'm
on the back heel um on the back foot
from from from the GetGo and yeah that's
um you can't yeah you can't rely on
swindling your way through matches like
I I was going to say though but the
content is great so maybe you can I mean
obviously I'm making jokes about the
content but Ser it's amazing cuz you did
have to come back but you know good good
honest thoughts that you want to show up
a little bit more ready right out of the
gate tomorrow no no I mean of course it
feels great to win on even on days that
I'm that I don't feel so so great and
that I don't play so well but um yeah I
don't think you can can rely on it yeah
well would you can rely on it or not you
did put on quite a show that was amazing
to watch and so we wish you the best of
luck tomorrow and uh
I guess we'll see you again yeah thank
you thank you no no other no other last
thoughts no I didn't hear any
predictions okay you were about to I
haven't uh you know I haven't felt
slighted in any way so you gave me a
smile that made me think you had
something else to say but anyway we
appreciate it man good luck enjoy the
night we'll see you tomorrow thank you
see you all right and that was the guy
that's the man Magnus he gets the job
done in crazy crazy fashion today a
comeback victory as we said he wins with
black to force Armageddon for the second
time here in Toronto and ultimately gets
the job
done oh man it was crazy but okay he
wasn't the only winner in this
semi-finals matchup the youngster the
19-year-old that dude didn't even need
Armageddon tie breaks guys he didn't
even need anything but three you know
four I guess he needed four games cuz he
lost the first one but he took two and a
half points and ultimately defeated
Wesley so and Ka caught up with him
right after his
victory it's a massive Norbeck Abdu
saturo takes the first match in the
semi-finals congrats nor than you thank
you how are you feeling right now after
managing to beat the unbeatable Wesley
so in an entire match yeah it's it's
been quite an achievement for
me um yeah I this is my first um match
win against Wesley so yeah it feels
great and yeah but it's uh it will
be um it will be decided tomorrow yeah
so he's going to reach fin so yeah we'll
see but let's first look back so what
are you the most happy about with the
way you played today yeah I'm quite
happy um I got um I played good chess in
every
game um yeah I'm just satisfied with my
result today
and also I think Wesley um
Wesley was
a um was in not like good shape today so
I think he will he will get give me a
tough fight tomorrow yeah and what will
it be about tomorrow then to be able to
actually win the semi-finals here and go
to the
finals yeah I
mean um there is you know there is a
match ahead of me and so I need to
first um win that that match so it's
quite a long way say yeah what what will
you do the rest of the day here in
Toronto today um just rest you know just
have a walk
and just um enjoy the time here who who
do you have with you here in Toronto I
have my mother with me so actually we
are we are going to the like shopping
center every day so we are just um yeah
we have we have we are having a great
time here if he you to the shopping
center or are you actually enjoying
that I mean both like you know I just
want to forget about the games and just
uh just rest all right well can you
reveal any great finds have you bought
anything uh you're really happy with um
yeah we have about
um we have about uh perfumes so so yeah
we are I'm I'm happy yeah all right so
are you going to so it seems like a
recipe for a success for you you uh will
you go to the shopping mall today as
well then um we'll see I think she's
already
there
so fantastic n um go enjoy the mall
enjoy your Victory and good luck
tomorrow thank you all right well you
guys that seems to be the recipe for a
success just go relax at the mall back
to you
guys well maybe that's how you deal with
your nerves as a mom instead of watching
your son win the most important chess
match of his career maybe you go
shopping but that's what he did guys
95.5% accuracy he beats Wesley so
without even needing Armageddon and uh
all right guys let's let's talk about
this one a little bit cuz obviously
Magnus and Fabby steal the show usually
but let's not let Notre Beck get away
without some big compliments or whatever
we want to say Levy I'm going to start
with you what can you say about the
young man from usbekistan it started
literally the worst way possible he was
playing with black he gets outplayed in
a super super long drawn pushes and then
loses I mean he loses it's okay it's
back back to back to business Wesley so
6 and0 in
Toronto and then you know then he loses
he loses to Fabiano but like Wesley
could have won seven and0 I mean he you
just lost to Fabby and the Armageddon so
we're like all right great you know back
to business and then he Notre gets white
no problem then wins with black and then
and and then absolutely no problems in
the fourth game either so really
impressive really really impressive
Danny dubbed it uh NY the IAL mythical
everything go Dragon he is I mean that
man you know I'm going to get
confirmation from him on the nickname I
think that's fair while we're just
called him that the whole show I've been
calling him that I think since he was 15
years old okay so the mythical dragon I
like it the Magic Dragon the Magic
Dragon okay that's what it is you know I
don't know how it started but frankly it
started with me thinking there was an R
before the D which there's not nor so I
don't I'm going to get permission to
continue using it but jokes aside I do
want to go back cuz Levy you and I you
and I were in the mix Zone and Fabby
loses in heartbreaking fashion right but
Notre Beck also lost in kind of
heartbreaking fashion he over pushed and
and then Wesley so punishes him and yet
he turns it around that's the type of
makeup the type of mental makeup we're
watching of someone who's a future
champion because that takes guts yeah
yeah he's he's ice cold water in his
veins uh time is ticking and the first
game didn't go his way but they just
come right back and the first game
didn't go his way exactly in the style
of that mat no back the aggressor the
Young Gun right the magical dragon you
can say it he likes it Wesley is is cool
common collected defense you know
defensive resources like through the
roof and no to come back to win the
second and the third game two in a row
from a defeat is uh is massive so what
can you say that's beautiful I mean you
got to know that also Notre backck a lot
of times we forget this he is a rapid
Champion so playing this format I'm fre
Champion I it's it's really fair and you
know was sitting with with Wesley out
there and he was having fun which again
just shout out to Wesley and his
General deme who he is I gu his
wholesome demeanor because he sits down
with me and he goes yeah after I won the
first game he uh he turned it on and he
just outplayed me after that I'm like
yeah he goes I guess I got to play
better tomorrow I'm like I think you
will he's like okay but it was just like
like no part of him that was you know
backing down from the fact that Notre
Beck outplayed him and we'll see what
kind of mindset Wesley has going into
tomorrow cuz is facing a world rapid
Champion despite how good Wesley is in
this format he did also talk to Kaa
right after the loss Wesley so telling
me just before we came on that life is
good you can't win every time so are you
okay even if you lost a match today
Wesley no no I'm very much okay I mean
first of all my opponent played like
perfect chess I mean I look I had a few
minutes that I look briefly in between
match and he basically gave me no
chances okay I shouldn't have lost game
three like that was very stupid but at
the same time it happens when you get
low on the clock just things explode
becomes unpredictable so I think he
played really well well well I mean I
think I didn't play that poorly today
it's just he played better so it is what
it is I mean you can't you can't win
every day as they say uh so it's not
what I was hoping for but the same time
it's it's a good day I got another hands
tomorrow no I want I think I'm going to
make a shout out to my boy Anish giri
for holding the fort and on Twitter you
mean yeah and for watching the games on
S guest on the on the Spain y yeah
because I saw that lenier Drew against a
2350 I mean ler is a good friend of mine
but at the same time uh you know we're
we're competing so so uh yeah and and
then tomorrow another another day I'll
give my utmost best and at very least
I'll get some practice I'm not going to
bother you too much with what happened
today but in an interview here nard bik
did say that he felt you were a little
bit shaky uh when you came into time
trouble so that was part of his tactics
did you feel shaky in time trouble today
yeah for sure he was always ahead on the
clock but again I didn't think I played
that poorly maybe my time management
wasn't the best like in the openings I
was spending a lot of
time uh so that could be improved like
I'm always down on the clock and then
later he would catch up and then we'd
get
even um and in a Time scrambles you know
he's a young kid so he's he's very good
and what will you do today now to just
forget about this and get ready for
making a comeback tomorrow well I'll
watch the Armageddon game uh I'll just
uh relax try to find some ideas uh and
uh TR to sleep well not to be too
stressed and uh hopefully I can come up
in very good form tomorrow and and then
we'll get a match best of luck tomorrow
wesy thank you for stopping by yes
anytime all right Wesley so he's going
to make a comeback tomorrow that's the
plan for him back to you
guys well do you think he makes a
comeback tomorrow Levy I mean I have no
idea I guess it's too late to change my
my pick I chose uh Carlson and I chose
so that has nothing to do with Notre I
just thought Wes was in great form but
this is actually Wesley's worst
situation that he's been in in the two
years of events in Toronto last year he
won the entire event and this year he's
on the verge of elimination so tomorrow
he is fighting to win the set to force a
tie break and then ultimately to make it
to the finals um I mean I can't just
change my pick knowing the result of
today's match so I'm I'm sticking with
Carlson and so we'll see if he can make
a comeback and if no wins listen that's
the future yeah he is the future so I I
am sticking with my pick of Carlson and
so but I as a Jedi I do feel a
disturbance in the force here with uh
with Abdus satoro the way that he's
playing right now so it definitely is a
shake up of course W is coming from
behind but Abdus zorov is not going to
slow down so it's scary but I'm still
taking you know my PS there so you said
shake up before we go I want to give you
both a chance to react to that because I
think the most critical takeaway of both
players being honest there was that
nottock said he felt like Wesley was
shaky yeah that's not something we
normally see right and Wesley kind of
acknowledged it so what what's going on
with that I think nerb just speaks his
mind maybe maybe there's a little bit of
spice on there maybe there's a little
bit of trash talk but I think he's just
young hungry confident like we have to
remember nck is the pride of his country
like usbekistan where he's from is fully
on board with his chess career he's like
meeting the president they're naming
academies he's getting cars they bought
him a Chevrolet what about a
BMW disrespect but next time when he
wins this get him a BMW sponsored by
Chevrolet if Chevrolet wants to sponsor
it they can there you go or BMW go ahead
my point is also like I keep saying this
but he's the only guy up here not named
Magnus Carlson who is a world champion
he's the 2021 World rapid Champion he
knows what it takes to win a world
championship title and this year after
this event he's got a you know he has a
chance to win one again over there in
usbekistan so he he knows what it's like
to perform at the highest level at the
age of 17 only small correction Wesley
so did win a world random Championship
yeah we need like a few of those to make
it I I I know I know no no but your
point is very well taken and and I'll
even double down on it he won a World
rapid Championship that's what we're
doing here we're playing rapid chess so
that was 1510 this is 15 it's the same
it's basically the same um so he he
knows what it takes and yeah he he might
make us all put our foot in our mouth
and maybe he wins the whole damn thing
and they get him they get him a statue
and a BMW and a BM if he wins the whole
damn thing here you're getting him a
statue and a BMW
inal ABD Sato
what we're going get engraved on the
side too guys this was incredible we we
the stage has been set for tomorrow
Notre Becka to tur off the underdog the
underdog is up the Underdog's on top
right now and he's going to shine until
the chest stops maybe we'll see the uh
other matchup of course the underdog is
not on top Magnus Carlson is leading but
he didn't play his best chest today
we'll see if Magnus can finally figure
out his slow start that we've all been
talking about for a while but all right
for the crew for Levy for KY for every
going crushing it working super hard
there's a lot of people here bringing
this thing to you everybody in Oslo we
love you we know it's late hope you're
going to enjoy your evening the first
day of the semifinals here at the 2023
Champions chess tour finals is in the
books we're going to take a very very
quick break tonight but we'll see you
bright and early for the second day of
the semis here from
[Music]
Toronto give with check he just
blundered the poem with check Magnus
Carson does the unbelievable he wins
down the queen oh he's training off all
the bishop brilliant and NY back he's
resigned ABD SRA of the comeback K
strikes again leveling the game and in
what style amazing performance Fabiano
caran are really bringing his aame today
n back Abdu satov also gets the backto
back Victory Fabiano just frustrated he
got so close he tried what he had to but
in the end handshake Magus
[Music]
wins